bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur ce
nouveau live de la projustic tout était
prêt sauf la caméra de Kevin sur la
deuxième image salut mon cher Kevin
est-ce que tu es chaud pour cette
semaine 3 de la prochaine SIG avec
Daniel duboff avec Magnus Carlsen avec
d'autres grands champions
tu me trouves beau
moi on m'a dit on m'a dit que c'était ah
on attend paquet ah ben voilà c'était
une chance sur deux mon petit keV alors
attends tu vas répéter exactement ce que
tu étais en train de dire j'avais une
chance sur deux j'ai changé mes
écouteurs alors j'ai changé mes
écouteurs je le dis aux gens
j'ai changé mes écouteurs pourquoi parce
que j'ai oublié mon écouteur j'ai oublié
j'ai perdu mes écouteurs dans l'avion en
fait je les ai oublié ce weekend c'était
une histoire encore assez brillante et
donc du coup tout a été à refaire
j'étais particulièrement ravi est-ce
qu'on t'entends Kevin salut tout et je
sais pas du tout si on m'entend mais en
tout cas merci à toi stouf de t'inviter
à la technique je trouve grand
technicien aussi et j'espère qu'on
m'entend maintenant
vous remarque ouais on t'entend on
t'entend ah c'est magnifique magnifique
donc tu faisais une remarque sur ma
coupe de cheveux pas on avait dit pas le
physique mais bon donc ma coupe de
cheveux me va bien ce qu'il paraît je te
suis
fait 5 à 10 ans de moins comme ça la
dernière fois Laurent je je me demandais
un peu ce qui se passait mais là ouais
tu es transfiguré je vais mettre à
pleurer on m'a dit que c'était trop
court bon déjà honnêtement on dit que
c'était trop court
c'est sympa ça fait toujours plaisir à
entendre mais bon peu importe on va pas
faire le Strip sur ça ils sont honnêtes
ils sont honnêtes ils sont là maintenant
moi ça me plaît bien alors ça me plaît
bien alors voilà donc
regarde mon petit mon petit caisse ça va
être beaucoup mieux que que tout à
l'heure on va voir les deux les deux
forces en présence on a d'abord tous les
deux ce qu'on va voir c'est les levitov
chef Wizards face au yogi donc une
équipe russe contre une équipe indienne
et ensuite tu passeras le relais tu vas
mes informateurs m'ont dit que tu allais
à une compétition badminton
tu sais bien c'est important en jouant
en avant dernière division et si je n'y
vais pas c'est forfait donc du coup là
c'était j'avais pas le choix donc bon
ben voilà c'est tu fais toujours la
première partie et la deuxième partie
évidemment ça sera Magnus Carlsen le
grand avec notre ami stouf qui me
rejoindra aux commentaires donc restez
bien pour le deuxième match qui sera à
partir de 19h mais déjà pour le premier
on a regarde on a deux belles équipes
avec ma médias
Shimano flashéo qui Nina pour les
Beatles
et ensuite en face on a voilà
les meilleurs indiens quasiment et le
problème mon cher mon cher Kevin c'est
qu'on peut pas faire jouer tout le monde
en même temps exactement et donc on va
découvrir tous les deux
ils ont décidé de titulariser qui et
bien pour les levitors chez sweeter ça
sera Daniel du bof paraviane lasavie
quand je sais pas si tu l'as vu avec moi
mais alors lui il est bon il est pas
connu mais ici je t'en avais parlé on
l'avait vu justement avec stouf au
championnat du monde Blitz et rapide il
nous avait fait forte impression parce
qu'il a un petit hello par rapport à ce
qu'il envoie il est très très dangereux
et on avait l'occasion de les
commentaires laservic et gounina tu te
rappelles pas
qui est capable de tout mais évidemment
super joueuse c'est vrai que tu arrêtais
pas de critiquer la dernière fois
effectivement ouais c'est ça c'est ça
exactement
mais en tout cas Prague et Sarine cette
réforme avec la sœur de Rago City qui
est là et pranesh un joueur un peu plus
confidentiel mais deux équipes très
fortes ça se voit sur le papier non
ah ouais alors en face c'est pranesh je
connais pas trop weishai c'est la sœur
de prendre lambda on a ni elle Sarine
qui est l'expert de ses Blitz online et
Praga denda qui est aussi bon bah la
jeune génération montante on est-ce
qu'on en profite Niels il jouait à
Djerba on a il a perdu contre Maxime la
garde en demi-finale qui lui-même a
perdu en finale contre notre frère notre
le roi le roi de France le roi de France
peut jusqu'à en août prochain le
champion de France en titre
celui avec qui j'avais le l'immense
plaisir de faire les soirées mousses
Jules Moussa exactement bah le film
Le français le plus plus en forme de
toute façon et il a effectivement même
changé de statut dernièrement Laurent
bah toi tu le connais encore mieux enfin
on se connaît tous mais c'est vrai que
tu l'as beaucoup plus suivi tes derniers
temps que moi mais c'est vrai qu'il a
assez incroyable
en termes de régularité de résultats
on sentait le potentiel et là ici est
mis un peu comme moi avec la technique
même si je viens de faire tomber mon
écouteur tu vois il suffit de s'y mettre
en fait on sort le on sent le potentiel
du du gars mais
au niveau de la comparaison je suis pas
sûr qu'il soit si flatteur que ça pour
ça sera à lui de s'exprimer mais je suis
pas sûr que il estime que ton niveau
technique en Obs soit au même niveau
technique que lui aux échecs mais tu as
le droit de t'avancer un petit peu
Laurent c'est tout à ton honneur c'est
pas ravi de la de la de la comparaison
mais
regarde c'est je vais je vais
m'organiser toi tu vas tu vas meubler
mon cher mais je vais me lever assez
facilement puisque je vois que tout fait
particulièrement déçu de pas avoir ma ma
veste doudoune mais j'en ai mis une
autre une petite veste Le Coq Sportif
qui est très sympathique stuff un peu
plus légère tu sais qu'on file vers les
beaux jours sauf donc très prochainement
j'aurais des tenues encore plus
décontractes je vais pas sortir quand
même le Marcel pour les échecs qui a pas
besoin de montrer les muscles mais en
tout cas voilà se trouve pour te
répondre en tout cas tu parles de beaux
jours tu as été breton c'est ça c'est
génial
bleu grand ciel bleu Laurent tu le sais
à chaque fois tu le sais c'est une
légende ça
[Musique]
il y a des gars après tu fais bien de le
préciser Laurent c'est pas c'est un
monde d'écart c'est ça donc on va voir
on sait pas qui en a donc là j'ai pas
les appareils mais malheureusement
j'étais prêt mais pas pas sur ça donc on
va essayer mais regarde on a tous les on
a tous les joueurs je peux les faire
défiler on voit Valentina Gouny alors ça
c'est qui non non non non c'est pas bon
ça qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là
je comprends pas
non mais non
en tout cas ça nous plaît alors en début
de stream comme ça c'est vraiment comme
je les aime voilà
comment ça se passe comme ça c'est
vraiment top
joueur 5 en fait il faut que je change à
chaque fois le truc
ok
tu vois c'est qu'à confirme qu'il fait
toujours beau en Bretagne bien joué rcka
et au fait Kevin tu pars toujours au
States yes c'est un projet dans peu de
temps donc peu de temps aux États-Unis
donc
tu vas faire aux États-Unis vacances 15
jours voilà alors je peux te dire que
c'est beau la vie de touristes quand
même ouais mais c'est même pas trop
choisir en fait c'est bien comment ça se
passe à la maison
il a fait rallure et tout ça et puis il
parle de Marseille et tout ça puis à la
maison qui est quand même un peu plus
petit est-ce que je veux dire
il est quand même c'est quand même c'est
bon il essaie de temps en temps il a les
petits incursus
keV tu es lourd qui rappelle tout le
monde à l'ordre normalement
un peu plus pénaux alors
[Rires]
elle m'envoie toujours la dernière
minute en fait je veux pas blâmer les
autres c'est ce que je vais faire
d'ailleurs mais non non monsieur tu te
débrouilles bien tu te débrouilles bien
faut que je change tout je comprends pas
pourquoi c'est pas la même la même
source mais bon ok on a vu Niall Sarine
et on te aperçu comme
on va voir quelle est la première partie
a débuté à quelque chose mais est-ce que
tu es sur le truc de
normalement là ça devrait être bon voilà
donc on peut voir tu veux voir qui
est-ce qu'on peut faire un petit rappel
des règles avec le petit screenborg que
tu as évidemment j'ai pas vérifié si
c'était le bon alors là ça va être la ça
va être oh là cadence 10 + 2 composition
d'équipe de parfum dépassez-moi de 2500
50 yes chaque joueur affronte tous les
joueurs de l'équipe adverse pour total
de 4 ans évidemment la première équipe
A4 à 8 et demi remporte le match et en
cas d'égalité des partages détermine
l'équipe gagnante dans des départages ou
tous les joueurs
effectivement comme je le disais alors
que je m'étais fait j'ai mauvaise
d'ailleurs je m'étais fait corriger tu
t'es fait un peu rouler mais tu avais
senti le truc tu avais senti le truc ça
avait pas de sens sinon
yes et on a déjà vu des matchs nuls ça
peut exister avec avec dans ce cas là le
départage ça peut durer pas mal de temps
on passe en e+2 en never sans les
couleurs voilà là
Laurent c'est une des rares fois où je
vois que finalement il y a un départage
où ça peut jouer en illimité c'est à
dire que normalement il y a toujours un
système Armageddon et là ça peut durer
jusqu'à demain si les gens s'arrangent
pour faire nul à chaque fois ils peuvent
tuer le système tu rates tu rates ton
badminton tu restes avec moi
j'ai bien compris il faut que j'appelle
le capitaine etc quoi ça serait alors
attends je vais essayer de voir je pense
qu'il y a une partie qui a a
qui a commencé
avec ce démarrage en décalé ben si on
voit tout on voit tout ce que je fais
bon non c'est super là c'est bon alors
ça fait partie aussi de la magie du
direct vous inquiétez pas j'ai un peu
perdu la main mais ça ça revient mais ça
revient vite ça revient vite on a un
deux pour voir que les parties toi toi
qui est là depuis longtemps que les
parties en cours
elle est partie en cours bah si tu les
as pas là
c'est qu'elles sont pas en cours
normalement il y a le je pense que le
petit délai
pourquoi
je vais mettre en plus sur chasse comme
moi ça c'était une question fondamentale
pourquoi Duba fait décalé c'est je vais
surveiller si tu veux en même temps au
niveau de l'événement que ça part bien
mais pourquoi il est décalé d'où box je
vais vous le dire parce qu'il manque un
joueur dans le col
donc voilà tout le monde n'est pas là
encore ok tout le monde dit un joueur
qui est là mais qui a dû perdre la
connexion internet alors c'est en plus
il y a un joueur qui peut à collection
internet fait des blagues terribles on
n'est pas bien du tout
donc
les joueurs
c'est parti l'orange je trouve du
bofranech
c'est vraiment parti yes tout est en
train d'arriver vice Chili par
Aviane pièce blanche tu vas voir les
parties viennent de n'apparaître donc
Daniel duboff avec les noirs on va le
chercher face à pranesh alors pranesh il
va être là avec les Blancs on va être
c'est lui c'est pas la tête qu'ils ont
mais attention que je connais pas donc
oui si c'est la bonne équipe c'est sûr
que ouais on va dire c'est lui
et du bof je note du coup qui équipe
parce que sinon
mes remarques on va peut-être se
souvenir avec ta mémoire ta mémoire
d'éléphants infaillible et Daniel il est
décalé mais je vais pas le décaler parce
qu'il manque par Aviane dans le col bon
du coup on va montrer à l'heure
que tu vas critiquer qui n'était pas la
dernière fois je crois qu'il y avait un
problème de colle donc là c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas du bof
mais c'est pour vous compreniez pas très
bien joué la dernière fois par rapport à
d'habitude
alors
en tout cas prenez pas bien vieux non
plus l'ami l'ami pranesh
né en 2006 je l'ai été regardé
donc 17 ans quand même ouais c'est ça
on a et bien un anti Marshall mon cher
c'est voilà le espagnol
je rappelle que je suis parti pris dans
cette dans cette histoire parce que
Daniel de beauf c'est mon collègue dans
la team Magnus dans les deux derniers
matchs et donc on a regardé énormément
d'anti Marchal c'était le thème du match
entre Yann les premiers Thompson Magnus
a joué 7 ensuite il a switché sur tour
B8 et Daniel fait B4 qui est l'autre
grand coup en fait pour protéger ce pion
parce qu'il y a quand même une menace
clairement on n'a pas envie de prendre
là parce que ça ferait une structure
vraiment pas terrible avec ce pion
faible donc il y a ces trois coups qui
sont possibles qui ont une valeur à peu
près équivalente mais c'est une question
de goût disons que ça c'est le plus
passif donc c'est ce que je préfère
et moyen et B4 et le coup le plus actif
mais ça donne beaucoup de cases avec
quatre stratégiquement c'est très très
risqué on voit exactement des fois on
voit des thèmes avec A5 aussi blanc pour
d'ailleurs montrer la faiblesse et le
fou passant peut passer en A4 ça donne
encore des cases et on peut dire aussi
que dubaf il a quand même une
particularité pour moi qui aime bien
voilà regarder les joueurs de haut
niveau il est quand même très créatif il
a énormément de très belles idées dans
les ouvertures alors en toi qui
travaille avec lui il est très très
productif il a cinq incroyable pour ça
c'est même trop parfois parce que ils
disent merci un peu
quelqu'un qui va donner il va donner une
idée 5 minutes plus tard il en donne une
autre mais attends attends mon jeune ami
on regarde d'abord la première et
ensuite on regardera la deuxième donc
faut se pour le canaliser mais c'est
extraordinaire d'avoir quelqu'un d'aussi
créatif comme ça dans une équipe mais
après c'est vrai qu'il faut au tour moi
mon rôle tu vois au fil des années
finalement il a changé au début j'étais
plus je cherchais des idées et tout ça
mais à la fin
c'est vrai qu'avec quelqu'un qui
bombarde tous les 5 minutes d'une idée
en fait il mène la danse dans l'équipe
donc ça peut être frustrant des moments
quand même pour faire attention pour
certains certaines personnes mais
globalement on passe la majorité du
temps à regarder les idées de danyle
mais il fait certainement bien aussi que
bon c'est dur de c'est compliqué quoi tu
vois c'est
le chef de chantier maintenant alors on
pourrait mettre un petit peu ouais je
lui dis de se calmer de bien expliquer
les trucs de voilà j'essaye de surtout
là ça va ça c'était le dernier match ça
allait mais celui d'avant ça vous partez
vraiment tous les sens en 2018 il était
très jeune il avait 21 ans donc voilà
c'est ça donc faut aller il fallait
derrière lui en fait parce qu'il peut
trouver une idée mais il la garde sur
son ordi donc ça a pas trop servi à
Magnus mais donc des quatre D6
puis on prend et cavalier prend ok
l'autre coup c'est puis on prend mais
qui prend un coup tout à fait
raisonnable que j'ai joué moi-même qui
est BD7 voilà on fait comme ça on va
certainement mettre les pièces comme ça
à 5 fois F6 cavalier prend cavalier
prend cavalier F1 on va aller là et là
ou alors là et là c'est tout à fait
classique ce coup de cavalier et là on
fait fou aussi on pose une question on
dit écoute qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
est-ce que tu veux prendre et m'ouvrir
la colonne
en couple pour rétablir la structure ou
endommager celle des blancs
je vais essayer de couper non
est-ce que Jul a plus de potentiel que
Daniel Dardar Daniel darda est plus
jeune c'est pas trop comparable en fait
ils ont pas le même âge je pense que je
l'avais
[Musique]
j'ai joué au j'ai découvert et jouer au
Cap d'Agde
c'est ce que j'ai dit après le tournoi
c'est le seul qui calculait dans le
tournoi alors le seul qui calculait
c'est un peu et moi moi moi le premier
qui calculait des ventes précis c'est à
dire que il pouvait dire après la partie
c'était clair quoi c'était clair selon
ses couilles et selon ses analyses après
parties que il était le seul finalement
à avoir des ventes précis c'est à dire
que il disait pas c'est pas 5 6 coups
moi c'est trois quatre coups et puis
c'est pas clair mais ça me plaît donc je
joue lui c'était boum boum boum boum
boum je gagne je fais nul je perds voilà
donc c'était beaucoup beaucoup plus
précis et donc ça c'est quand même une
qualité qui est
primordial de bien calculer aux échecs
ça c'est en fait on vient d'apprendre
Laurent que jouait au hasard et donc
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ceux qui sont en
dessous de toi en terme mélo il joue
complètement au hasard quoi c'est ça
moi je suis chanceux dans mon hasard un
peu plus chanceux que les autres et pas
pour moi que d'autres d'ailleurs
tu vois donc
les gens qui calculent très précisément
c'est très très rare faut pas je sais
pas un truc que je dis en l'air c'est
les gens qui bien sûr on a compris que
tu étais sérieux ça nous fait encore
plus mal Laurent dès le début de stream
mais ouais j'arrive pas j'arrive pas à
le changer à enlever le petit bout de
verre bon écoute c'est pas grave Kate 5
jouer tours français un tour reprend ou
d'un prends j'en sais absolument rien vu
que je calcule rien non mais on peut
dire que c'est un peu plus facile à
jouer avec les Blancs parce qu'on met de
la pression on a il y a plus un peu plus
de cible mais c'est sans doute peut-être
pas assez mais au moins on va pouvoir
triturer l'adversaire dans cette
position on va voir peut-être
l'échiquier numéro 2 par Aviane contre
avec les Noirs contre weishai par Aviane
qui est
qui est là
très fortement c'est incroyable ce qui
s'est passé contre vaichaïli je sais pas
quel numéro elle va être celle-là
surprise c'est le premier match on va la
trouver tout de suite
je vais peut-être noter non ça c'est
programmable
pour pour paraviane qui a un pion de
moins et les compensations ont l'air
vraiment maigre
peut-être qu'il va pas perdre peut-être
qu'il peut tenir mais il a pas trop de
raison de gagner cette partie en tout
cas et qu'on vaille Chali avec l'écart
de niveau quand même il pouvait espérer
enfin il devait pour la team et c'est de
l'emporter même avec les pièces noires
oui effectivement oui il gagnera pas oui
ça c'est sûr ça va probablement faire
nul cette ce genre de finale on
s'organise quand même assez bien contre
le pur en plus avec le roi qui peut être
actif les blancs vont tôt ou tard
prendre probablement donc
ça paraît
ça paraît tenable quand même pour les
noirs très très largement oui mais maman
on souffre un petit peu et il y a
ampoule qui rebondit sur ce que tu
disais Laurent en disant je joue pas au
hasard les 600 hello sur chetcom en 3000
je le prends comment en rigolant il y a
un petit smiley
un peu sans calculer aux échecs déjà en
déterminant à peu près l'urgence de la
position et en calculant très légèrement
on arrive déjà à des belles choses ça
que tu veux dire il y a pas besoin de
d'être un hypercalculateur pour pouvoir
jouer aux échecs heureusement
Dardar il m'a fait un truc très choquant
ou tu vois il allait prendre un pion h
et tu vois ça me semblait tu vois assez
déraisonnable comme truc j'avais pas
trop regardé je me suis s'ils veulent
prendre bon appétit et il m'a calculé il
va rendre de 10 coups très très concrets
où il faisait nul tu vois il était en
difficulté c'était un moyen concret de
de résoudre tous ces problèmes moi
j'aurais pas du tout fait ça sa place
j'aurais même pas regardé en fait cette
prise de pub mais je pense que j'aurais
défendu quand même tu vois donc ces deux
styles différents mais c'est vrai que ce
truc de calculer en général c'est quand
même pas mal parce qu'ils ont les deux
au fur et à mesure toi tu vas être plus
technique bien sûr que lui surtout qu'il
est jeune mais il va plus facilement
peut-être acquérir avec l'âge la
technique que le calcul évidemment donc
c'est c'est un jeune très prometteur on
a iriga ici que stuff appellent souvent
l'acrobate qui est dans ce style là à
aller chercher des pions
et des fois c'est impensable on se dit
que il y a bon des fois c'est chaud
d'ailleurs des fois il le fait
l'acrobate ça lui va bien sur le fil
mais des fois c'est hyper pertinent
c'est beau quoi c'est juste beau c'est
très créatif tellement ça a l'air bête
quoi
oui effectivement donc c'est c'est deux
styles de choses échec évidemment la
nouvelle génération bercé biberonné j'ai
envie de dire
par l'ordinateur et bien écoute bah ils
ont pas le même style que nous hein mon
cher Kevin on est quand même je te mets
dans le je te mets dans ma génération ça
te ça te choque pas tu rigoles ou quoi
alors
je suis hyper choqué alors attends on va
chercher laservic laservic c'est numéro
6 regarde ça regarde ça sous tes yeux
ébahis
techniquement c'est très fort ça joue
bien quand même pas ça NiAl
farine voilà qui va être là qui va
apparaître sous vos ébahis et on a une
position écoute ma foi
je dirais à peu près équilibré
ouais bon c'est toujours légèrement plus
agréable sans doute pas avec les Blancs
parce que on va presser les pions
pendant ça manque un peu de de
perspective peut-être on tourne ces deux
tours c'est peut-être tout simplement et
puis on voit bon après c'est pas il y a
encore tout reste à faire puis là le
cavalier en blitz Niels le cavalier
Niall Sarine avec le tandem cavalier il
peut faire mal c'est sûr alors on va
aller voir le dernier match pour faire
un petit tour de tous les joueurs et
joueuses justement parce qu'on va
découvrir 26,9 tu as tant critiquer la
semaine dernière on a reçu des lettres
de gens qui se plaignaient incroyable
non elle a les blancs en plus elle a les
blancs si si j'ai reçu moi j'ai reçu je
reçois des mails alors ça m'embête un
peu de te de te défendre mais bon je
l'ai fait quand même ah merci merci et
donc elle a les blancs face à pragamanda
qui va apparaître sous vos yeux le jeune
pra qui vient de terminer le tournoi du
soldat je sais pas si tu as suivi mais
voilà cette jeune génération qui est qui
est en train de s'affirmer là dans les
meilleurs joueurs du monde entre entre
gouquettes
ça s'affirme bien et Yann Gustave son de
me raconter il a fait un voyage en train
le lendemain du tournoi avec Google chez
lambda alors attention ça rigole pas
dans le train c'est exercice sur
exercice voilà ils adorent ça quoi c'est
toute la journée non-stop
à résoudre des exercices dans le train
tout le temps le lendemain d'un tournoi
moi franchement si tu as tu vois j'ai
pas pour toi mais je joue à toi de neuf
jours je fais une petite pause quand
même après ouais ouais la mentalité est
un petit peu un petit peu différente
après ce qu'il faut c'est sur le long
terme garder cette fraîcheur là tant
qu'il la garde on a vu d'autres joueurs
comme s'écraser un petit peu après j'ai
l'impression que ces joueurs là sont
infatigables pour l'instant en tout cas
et après ils sont très jeunes aussi
Laurent alors que Kévin si vous voulez
je lui demande en fait mais je sais où
il est moi si vous les trouvez dans le
train mais il est là il est la voiture
bar du train voiture
il parle pas d'échec il refait le monde
vous inquiétez pas alors
regardez manuscritsen il est pas dégoûté
et pourtant il gagne tout le temps
alors H6 ok qu'est-ce qu'on en pense
donc ça c'est très intéressant Kevin
c'est un thème très intéressant on a la
paire de fou mais on voit que la
structure empêche les fous de jouer
c'est assez terrible d'ailleurs et donc
les cavaliers ne sont normalement plus à
l'aise dans le genre de position
et est-ce que cette position fait
exception je crois pas non non on est un
peu coincé on le voit bien je vais
essayer de trouver des contre jeux par
F5 mais c'est difficile
simplement ça va prendre et puis ça va
être dur ouais ça va prendre le temps de
jouer un petit damage 3 voilà c'est ça
c'est ce que je regardais mais c'est pas
c'est pas si simple il y a même
peut-être est-ce que j'ai droit de jouer
des cavaliers G4 dans ce genre de
position cavalière ça c'est très méchant
mais bon je peux prendre un chèque je
suppose
je mentais pas tout à l'heure
cavalier G4
je sais pas ce qu'il faut faire faut
prends peut-être faut prendre et à tout
reprendre est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer le
calme tout à 5 ah non on peut pas on n'a
pas le temps on a cavalier
ce tour à 5 tu vois on va pas le coup là
alors vas-y attends je vais le mettre je
triche oh non
c'est bon quand c'est bien joué c'est
pour ça que c'est pas bon attention
alerte gaffe
c'est pas si facile à voir ce truc avec
vous prenez F5 en plus
c'est assez logique pour les banjo F5
mais est-ce qu'elle va le jouer ah ouais
normalement il attaque c'est tout elle
ça ouais est-ce que Magnus il bosse dans
le train après après les tournois ouais
Magnus c'est un vrai passionné aussi
hein vous le verrez faire des Blitz
c'est tout ça il est il est assez
incroyable il peut aller sur sur chaise
com et faire des matchs de Bullet comme
on a vu récemment voilà donc il est il
est infatigable aussi donc
ça il y a pas il y a pas de il y a pas
de problème
donc on va voir et elle a joué des cinq
thèmes 7 et tour 5g3 ok encore plus
fermer le jeu ça semble maintenant le
roi alors on connaît la manœuvre la
manœuvre de Carpo c'est vrai que le roi
C7 là il est dans et ensuite on va
ouvrir gentiment à l'aéroport ça
pourrait c'est un plan tout à fait
possible je tourne G7 où j'ai apprécier
j'ai l'impression qu'on va voir un Rouen
C7 dans cette partie tranquille je le
crois en tout cas j'en suis j'en suis
absolument
convaincu qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu
as envie désagréable en tout cas
désagréable
ça chauffe chez du bof on va aller voir
on est parti ouh là là là là là là là
c'est la boulette
donc double voilà on a 7 7 positions
et je vais tout de suite
donc danil avec les noirs
et Dany Li est parti aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe il y a un problème de caméra c'est
assez terrible il est aussi en grande
difficulté sur l'échiquier parce que
s'il a pas de contre je vais tout de
suite mais il en a pas je crois il va
jouer un petit cavalier FC
d'ailleurs au jeune pranaish qui a les
blancs donc
et ouais si les joueurs ont internet
instables en plus on déballe barré moi
je vous le dis exactement
donc
poubelle il a plus de caméra il a 50
secondes à la pendule autant vous dire
que la situation ça pourrait être une
énorme surprise
oui oui grosse surprise dès le début
après bon c'est encore long mais c'est
équipe indienne elle va pas être facile
à manœuvrer qu'on a vu
vache à lit
qui était vraiment pas mal contre
parvient plus celle là
ça rime contre lassavique ça reste à
l'équilibre et pas qu'on a il était
favori donc du coup
ça peut faire cher dès le début
exactement
puis bon on voit que ce petit pranache
si c'est normalement le maillon faible
annoncé
c'est un gros gros joueur en fait donc
attends il y a eu plein de coups
pour prendre à me prendre et me prendre
ici d'un mec 4 évidemment il veut garder
les dames Dany le matin Sion il y a pas
de dame parce qu'il y a F7 on
perds un peu ouvert dans le 3 peut faire
donc
il faut faire un petit peu gaffe
il faut faire très très attention à un
cirage de ces dames-près F4 c'est roi a
changé il y a cavalier au 4e qui peut
faire
je continue mon
j'ai pas le droit oh là là attention
attention là il a essayé trop de contre
je note jeune ami il a pas été
[Musique]
un peu un petit manque d'expérience là
pour le coup
il peut être mal même
il doit être fumasse parce qu'il n'avait
pas besoin de laisser ça qu'est-ce qui
vient de faire il a joué
vous pouvez contrôler la diago sans
doute
bien déconné
4 jouer tout rond en taille variante 9
secondes
il peut prendre dans 7 sur chaque
cavalière
je crois c'est pas jouable maintenant
c'est peut-être jouable d'ailleurs en
tout cas il réfléchit donc ça veut dire
que
très très chaud il est pas sûr non plus
après ce qu'on peut pas faire rouage 2
Roger qui est une gaffe d'après
l'ordinateur il fallait jouer il fallait
jouer
peut-être G3
aussi quoi tout est chez
moi c'est très choqué épreuves 4 menaces
il peut se faire mater ouais ouais ça
peut être
ça peut être très très chaud évidemment
vous avez les update vous voyez Daniel
du bof ah mince on a le
c'est pas ça que je voulais montrer F4
bon il a fait nu mais on regarde la fin
de la partie quand même vous avez les
update ici il y a toujours un petit
délai de 30 secondes parce que pour leur
petit triche et vous avez le score en
bas alors évidemment le score en bas
c'est le score global du match alors
évidemment comme c'est la première ronde
ça sera le score aussi de la de ce
dimanche
3 puis on prend et ça répète danil qui
s'en sort bien dans cette partie est
nulle donc dans la première paraviane
qui est toujours en train de défendre
qu'est-ce qu'on va voir on va voir
programme dedans on va voir la Master
Class de programme neuf à Valentina
gounina oh laservic Sarine qui est ça va
être de dommage très intéressant et tout
à fait on a cette position chez les deux
joueurs entre eux Nina et
praganda donc elle a les blancs
elle a les blancs elle a les blancs vous
allez avoir apparaître à l'écran dans le
voyez le fou malheureusement de
Valentina qui est en murait complètement
le seul la seule possibilité c'est de
jouer un moment F3 qui laisserait un
pion arrière en E3 à une belle case 4
pour le cavalier des 7 donc c'est
position très très difficile
il faut que Prague évidemment évidemment
que c'est la c'est la cible face à cette
équipe donc Prague il va essayer
évidemment de marquer un point il est
très très bien parti pour ça exactement
là tranquille peut-être que la Paris
partie la plus décise maintenant que tu
as mis les cames Laurence c'est celle de
Sarine contre la zavie quoi
c'est très très égal très pénible très
papa intéressant à voir
j'ai l'impression que tu veux nous
laisser sur sur ce match là
un peu près minute tout ça il a laissé
la tour passer en 8 parce qu'à tout
moment maintenant il pourra jouer contre
le pion E3 facile ouais ça va être dur
là ça va être dur on n'a pas froid dans
de bonnes conditions malheureusement le
foot n'a toujours pas de diagonale
il a même pas eu besoin de ramener son
roi là-bas alors on va voir j'avais
parié comme dans les plantes françaises
qu'on voit des fois
est-ce que la dame va passer par là la
dame peut venir ici maintenant le roi va
passer ça va être assez vite terminé
elle joue toujours G4 pour empêcher
justement l'incursion du roi du de la
dame pardon mais je crois que il va
doubler un Prague
F5 histoire de bien verrouiller les
possibilités de F5 voilà
et
du coup là c'est coincé
c'est dur à jouer un euro ce qui est en
plus non seulement la position est
mauvaise pour les blancs mais elle est
très très dure à jouer donc exactement
on va regarder la fin de ça évidemment
vu que tu tiens on le sait
faire
[Musique]
plutôt bien joué déjà
c'est bien
mais c'est toujours désagréable quand
même même le fou qui trouve sa diagonale
en fait et après on sait pas trop le
mettre voilà j'ai 7 comme tu l'indiqué
Laurent et la remis tu vois c'est un
coup évidemment qui va jouer tout rache
8 quoi d'autre elle contrôle vous voyez
ah ok cavalier
mais
quatre menaces aussi il est très fort il
est assez normand de souplesse à ses
pièces alors on peut dire que c'est la
force du grand joueur
ici laisser tous les possibilités ici
cavalier E4 dans le 4 dans point F4 tour
H8 tu dis pas comment il va mettre les
pièces donc c'est dur à surveiller
est-ce qu'on commence par un échec ou
pas les petites finales sont sympas
quand même pour les Noirs aussi on
pourra tout encaisser après dame jouer
elle veut pas de finale mais
regarde la poubelle regarde les
faiblesses c'est foutu avec le roux en
plus qui va être actif dans la finale
ouais c'est ça on va être obligé plus ou
moins à le faire 5 elle essaie de
trouver du contrôle
terminal à mon avis
à 100 % pour reprendre aussi un sans
prise moi j'aime bien pour c'est un tour
reprend et puis on prend aussi
qui doit gagner mais pas sur un mille
pour cent
, je sais pas c'est quand même assez
agréable
on va voir on va voir il a le temps de
décider il fait il fait tout ça d'accord
on peut plus vraiment bouger en fait on
a
gros gros problème comme ça on doit
garder la protection du pur H2 et on va
au 5 on encaisse C4 c'est terminé pour
Nina qui est proche de remarque
et roi des trois il y aura B5
finis cette partie on va aller voir une
autre partie bravo à Prague qui a
terminé ça parvient à gagner mais non on
avait dit qu'il pouvait plus gagner sauf
livraison sauf gaffe et apparemment
parce que
ça remet bon pour l'intérieur du marché
bien
mais la partie entre
laser et qui a les blancs donc un pion
de plus face aux jeunes prodiges
il y en a qui est parti bon ben je
ça c'est pénible les types qui ont pas
de faveur en même temps
après quand tu travailles aussi bien
techniquement et qu'on te fait des
blagues c'est pas agréable
tout à l'heure ça avait l'air d'avoir
une bonne tête mais
ça devient de plus en plus chaud
j'aime pas du tout ce qu'il a fait
attention il peut jouer avec très peu de
temps très rapidement c'est le champion
du Bullet Niels
très très fort en Bullet
sans doute c'est
un peu plus friable à cette cadence là
mais ce n'est très fort regardez-moi ça
qu'est-ce qui se passe
on sait pas ce qui se passe
non mais là ils ont pas le droit de
faire ça franchement
toi qui a tout préparé
ils peuvent pas ils sont très sympas
mais ils peuvent pas partir
ils ne peuvent pas partir pendant le
direct c'est pas possible
c'est juste
il faut leur dire non elle est revenue
ok donc
là c'est nul ça va faire nul
la tour en B6 et dès que le pion passe
cette ligne Maginot
et bien on va derrière et on colle des
échecs là on peut simplement
il connaît
et prendre l'opposition et surtout le
verbe qui compte c'est prendre
l'opposition c'est à dire se mettre en
face à face avec un nombre de cases
impair donc une case d'écart entre les
deux rois ça marche bien on va voir ce
qui s'est passé
c'est la grosse surprise pour surprise
on a dit parade un peu plus gagner
c'était vrai envoyer la position peut
depuis le début est-ce qu'il a réussi à
mettre un V5 un peu fourbe qu'est-ce
qu'il a réussi à faire il pouvait plus
il pouvait plus gagner ça c'est clair HK
G6 et même il souffre clairement il
souffrait tout à fait
de gagner souvent qu'on essaie de gagner
mais on peut se prendre les pieds dans
le tapis regardez
ça y est on les voit
très bien très belle attitude de la joie
indienne la joueuse indienne pardon
et malheureusement très belle attitude
mais en blitz ça peut mal tourner
et vous le voyez
bien sûr pour retour
pourquoi je pousse pas là F si ça en
plus
gagnant d'ailleurs non d'après la jauge
ça se finit en tofu contre tour parce
que on sait pas comme quelques jouets en
fait ici c'est quoi il y a sa caméra
j'ai j'ai un truc technique à
t'apprendre
ça me fait plaisir
ça m'étonnerait pas beaucoup qu'elle est
perdue autant sur une déconnexion
peut-être peut-être parce que là il va
falloir travailler la connexion
c'est ça travail ta connexion donc de
partout pour ce premier match de la
chance pour les pour les Russes
clairement avec paraviane j'ai jamais
gagné
qu'est-ce qu'on en pense de ce match on
pense que les Indiens vont gagner
oui moi c'est un défi parce que
paravient c'est très fort quand même en
termes de
Bliss double parasian nasafix très très
fort et gounina en Josse féminine c'est
une des meilleures du cirque une des
meilleures feeling des circuit donc je
suis pas si sûr en fait je trouve que
l'équipe indienne est très bonne mais je
trouve qu'en face c'est très fort aussi
donc ça va être indécis jusqu'au bout au
Laurent je trouve que là ils auraient
mérité deux admir et demi minimum les
joueurs indiens
voir trois parce que pranesh c'est quand
même bien mieux contre du bof donc c'est
vrai que si on regarde la qualité de jeu
déployée par les joueurs indiens ici
c'était plus fort mais en face c'est
plus expérimenté donc ça va s'équilibrer
ça va être chaud quand même ça va être
ça va être bouillant on rappelle quand
deuxième partie de soirée enfin deuxième
partie de soirée en tout cas à partir de
19h du coup je voulais recadrer les
joueurs mais je sais pas du tout qui est
qui avec leur chaise on a
le le got un des gosses un des trois
meilleurs joueurs de tous les temps
Magnus Carl scène voilà tout le monde
s'accorde sur ça en tout cas elle casse
pas off et Fisher
ils sont ils sont le top 3 clairement
après l'ordre c'est dimanche à chacun de
donner l'ordre
scène dans l'air moderne il y a quand
même une densité de
d'extrêmement fort joueur qui est plus
importantes que dans les années 80 et
encore plus Fisher donc pour moi c'est
vraiment
le numéro un de tous les temps ouais
d'accord à ce point là ouais bon après
tu vois casse pas je dis pas je dis pas
mais je pense qu'il est vraiment
exceptionnel puis bon j'adore le le
style de certaines parties mais ça c'est
encore différent quand on parle de style
des fois on dit que les joueurs de haut
niveau c'est incompréhensible ce qu'ils
font donc effectivement c'est pas
vraiment très difficile mais Carlson des
fois il a tendance à jouer des parties
avec
ultra simple et à faire très mal à des
joueurs très forts en jouant juste des
coups beaucoup simple c'est ce qui est
très agréable à regarder on peut s'en
servir pas mal pour les parties d'écoles
pour les joueurs et ça c'est super
ça s'appelait il pleut au coach Magnus
c'est vrai que c'est limpide c'est
logique tout est tout est bien c'est ça
je suis en train de regarder un petit
peu facile quand il joue ouais c'est ça
de regarder un petit peu toutes les
plateformes où on retransmet on le
rappelle on est en direct ah ils nous
ont pas mis sur chaise 24 il va falloir
que je vais mettre les Florent il est ok
on est d'accord tous les deux Florent
pour une fois pour une fois le grand
supporter Laurent Freyssinet de Magnus
et
secondanté
m'impressionne beaucoup et c'est pas
comme si il y avait pas de concurrence à
l'époque de castors après en plus
peut-être maintenant avec l'émergence
notamment de l'un de la Chine
effectivement mais casse-parents fait
rester quand même 20 ans numéro 1
mondial donc je mettrai en numéro 2
pour l'instant après pour l'instant on
en discute dans 5 ans
mais on a on a déjà vu l'histoire avec
Florent on la connaît l'histoire c'est
que il va pas être facile il va pas être
facile à détrôner le gars Magnus là il
va être détruire en avril quand même
mais en tout cas je comprends mais bon
en tant que numéro un mondial ou pour
l'instant il a une telle régularité que
c'est l'horreur
il a qu'à voir même son tata style ou ça
y est il a perdu deux parties dans le
même tournoi tout le monde a dit waouh
c'est la fin c'est la fin et dans le
tournoi il a montré quand même qu'il
était le boss sans finir premier c'est
vrai mais en revenant et en étant hyper
dangereux quoi c'est ça qui est dur
alors on t'entend un peu plus fort mon
cher
[Musique]
mon cher Kévin bon ben je vais je vais
là
il suffit de mettre les deux jaunes au
même niveau et vous allez voir
si si si
tu t'y connais rien ok d'accord si si
c'est pas grave tu mets
tu as un petit mais tu le vois pas je
pense le petit le petit indicateur
est-ce que tu le vois
tu viens de prouver alors la pause à la
pause à la pause je vous montrais une
petite un petit truc à Laurent je peux
vous dire que vous aurez plus de
problème là et pas du tout c'est pas
normal qu'on m'entende un peu plus haut
je suis un peu plus haut mon micro est
un peu plus performant que celui de
Laurent parce que je suis bon bref il
connaît rien oh là là
et qu'elle en fait c'est génial c'est ce
que j'adore c'est ce que je préfère en
fait c'est la combinaison de la
certitude plus l'incompétence
elle donne des catastrophes
alors ce que je voulais parler la blague
si vous voyez ce que je vois à l'écran
je pourrais donner le petit conseil clé
mais je vais pas le faire je vais
attendre la pause pour ça en tout cas ça
plaît beaucoup tu me coupes vas-y je
vais dire ou que vous soyez ou que vous
regardez sur chaise com la chaîne
Youtube en français abonnez-vous si vous
êtes sur chaise 24 en français
abonnez-vous à chaise score en français
parce que c'est là où tout va se passer
si vous êtes sur twitch allez-y
abonnez-vous aussi à la chaîne si vous
êtes sur chaise 24 c'est pas possible
parce qu'ils ont oublié de mettre le
chaud sur chaise 24 mais à partir de
demain il sera et voilà donc n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner parce que ça nous
fait plaisir et ça nous aide surtout
voilà à proposer encore plus de contenu
c'est Sam comme bonjour un petit pouce
un petit abonnement à la chaîne et ça
vous permet ensuite de recevoir les
notifs
tout en se disant est-ce que je regarde
est-ce que j'ai un truc à faire est-ce
qu'il faut que j'aille pêcher comme
comme Kevin ou alors est-ce que je
préfère regarder une partie d'échec et
d'ailleurs quand tu parles de pêche on a
bien compris Laurent que tu essayes de
noyer le poisson et évidemment de
l'incompétence technique avec une belle
petite sortie promo on a bien compris
Laurent il y en a plusieurs qui ont vu
clair dans ton jeu on les on les connaît
ils sont pas ouais ils sont pas du pain
dans le chat merci à vous pour le
soutien
alors
vaicaili qui joue contre
le super joueur Daniel touboff qui
d'ailleurs à mon goût on sent qu'il a
plus sous le tu vois il est 200708 là
merci
talent
mon vieux c'est le moment si d'avoir
plus quoi tu vois de faire mieux c'est
déjà pas mal c'est déjà très bien ce
qu'il fait mais il peut faire et oui oui
tu as tout à fait raison on est d'accord
sur sur le cas de Laurent c'est on
partage la même philosophie c'est
parfait ce que tu as écrit qui a dit oui
oui je sais qui c'est oui oui mais ça il
était avant
que j'écoute plus ce qui c'était
pourtant très très très pertinent
[Rires]
tu vas voir
il lui manque quoi de beauf pour pour
passer un cap question de chaise comme
fr ah c'est intéressant ouais ben à mon
avis un peu de Constance tout simplement
parce qu'il a des
parfois tu vois il en fait un peu trop
quoi le dribble de trop on le connaît
celui-là voilà il faut qu'il fasse qui
reviennent aux choses simples parfois
parce que malheureusement toutes les
positions sous des positions ne
permettent pas un jeu créatif et fantasy
c'est il le sait mais voilà c'est ça tu
vois un petit peu et donc il faut
arriver à se cadre un petit peu
voilà c'est un peu
moi par exemple je veux jamais
compliquer le truc tu vois je cherche
toujours à simplifier donc du coup ça
s'est agrand défaut aussi
et il faudra du bof un peu de Laurent
Frayssinet en fait
il y a quelques années
mais j'ai un très très bon score contre
contre danyl parce que justement
j'attends et puis ça il vient toujours
mais effectivement il était quand même à
l'époque où on jouait
ça il était plus jeune mais même on fait
pas mal de blisses dans la session
d'entraînement et vu que notre niveau tu
vois le score est pas normal c'est un
bon style conduit
tu bloques ces joueurs là très fort très
créatif
alors
intéressant pour faire dame français 5
et écoute c'est un grand bidame tout ce
qu'il y a de plus classique très très
honnête très très honnête on fait qui
c'est que tu as envie d'aller voir on a
pranesh contre-paraviane la zavik contre
le match clé ouais mais alors c'est une
italienne très très simple on va aller
voir pranes
paravient de pranes parce que ça aussi
ça pourrait être quand même une grosse
partie prend neige on le découvre un
petit peu
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même un
super joueur
apparemment en tout cas en tout cas très
jeune il a l'air de très très bien tenir
la route notre ami Pradesh face à
parviane et on a cette variante moi
c'est chaud donc ça je connais assez
bien ils ont joué avec cavalier E3 ce
qui est plus rare normalement c'est un
mauvaise réputation
et puis on voit trouver
en fait et voilà très très compliqué
et F5 et c'est compliqué
je vais très rapidement par prendre
neige donc c'est clairement une prépa
faut prendre un peu on peut se permettre
en rapide de jouer plus de choses
douteuses en général l'adversaire a pas
le temps de réfuter donc voilà ça peut
permettre de surprendre et de jouer des
choses plus
tout simplement
maintenant on va faire voir que c'est
c'est hyper chaud
et on prenait le fou à 6 ça n'allait pas
beaucoup de forts
il a pris le temps mais il a pris que 3
minutes pour trouver quasiment tous les
coups qu'il fallait après il y a
beaucoup de pions pour les Noirs donc
comment on finit le travail ici
quand même de ce que ça me semble
pour pouvoir mettre
le petit tour prendre des States en
place attention il y a tourbé en place
en prise donc est-ce qu'on joue petit
rock ici avec les Noirs comment on fait
avec les Blancs est-ce qu'il y a
trois peut-être trois on va garder
l'oeil sur la sur la tour forcément mais
la dame est assez mal placée
et c'est jouer un petit rock mais il se
prend un tour B7 alors peut-être fou F3
d'abord j'en sais rien mais par exemple
ça va être compliqué ces jouets en tout
cas rock étaient le coup normal et ne
Mollie pas à apprendre
c'est pas si mal si il y avait pas de
qu'on a vu la jauge je pensais qu'il y
avait quelque chose de concret mais non
honnêtement c'est hyper intéressant
comme pose exactement il est blanc
n'arrive pas à faire la différence ça
peut être chaud 4 pions mais trois trois
à venir mais c'est des pions centraux
écoute il joue F3 tout reste à faire
dans cette
partie
et on a Niels sur le papier entre
nyalsheim et Valentina gounina qui a les
blancs ça paraît bien déséquilibré
tout ça
mais c'est ton jamais l'ouverture un
petit peu atypique
de la part
de la part de Valentina qui
sait d'éviter tout débat théoriques
c'est toujours compliqué dans ces trucs
online mais c'est souvent de ah non
c'est pas c'est ça
aux échecs et voilà je fais un peu ce
que je veux dans le début pas très
ambitieux
et
ouais puis c'est il s'amuse un peu plus
aussi que si je joue des grandes lignes
en plus donc à tout niveau je pense que
c'est un choix intelligent
il va mettre la pression
donc là je sais pas trop à quoi elle
réfléchit elle a pris du pion
effectivement
si on laisse faire est-ce qu'on prend là
pour essayer d'affaiblir en fait quand
on peut en vacances
que je joue parce que il peut y avoir
des termes de D4 avec les noirs qui a
sS6 D4 donc c'est un peu énervant
peut-être quelque chose comme ça j'ai
pas envie de donner à me faire
ok bon c'est bizarre avec les Blancs
je pense que c'est pas une grande
réussite pour l'instant avec
tout simplement et
tout à fait tout à fait accorder bon il
va essayer de jouer une position simple
je pense exactement il serait très
content de la tirer dans un Tate va
falloir c'est ce qu'elle est c'est ce
qu'elle doit éviter en cette partie
elles notent mutuelle réciproque parce
que là il est complètement injouable
nialshine dans ces cadences archi
rapides il attend que ça il est très
très fort online et je l'ai vu même
d'ailleurs c'est pas comme line en vrai
aussi je l'ai vu notamment jouer un
match de départage en blitz
contre notre ami Jules Moussa
et il a joué 15 coups en une seconde
enfin c'était c'était pénible à regarder
à un moment tu as envie de
t'as envie de lui prendre sa main quoi
tu vois comme ça tu étais tomber une
seconde
on voit cela en équipe Niall Sarine au
gîte le soir quand il rentre avec un
Regis sont des ils sont des ils se font
ils se font des petites des petites
parties 10 secondes chacun des trucs tu
sais tu montes tu descends en terme de
temps enfin c'est n'importe quoi ils
adorent
d'accord ils adorent ils jouent dans ton
équipe
on a vraiment les plus forts à Mulhouse
il y a que pra qui manque à l'appel tu
sais il y avait même donc aussi qui a un
jeune espoir indien extrêmement fort et
en plus d'égaliser et de Niall il y aura
aussi Google prochainement
moi je te le dis histoire
avec leurs petits français derrière tu
vois alors Jean-Noël avait tout résumé
voir les Français on est là pour faire
des crêpes le matin aux Indiens et puis
après nous si on fait nul c'est pas mal
parce que sûrement qu'ils vont se correr
devant c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé
au dernier apéro
et éventuellement ça peut ça peut être
la stratégie de match ça peut être la
stratégie de match
j'ai bien vu ça l'année dernière
écoute
en fait on fait ce qu'on peut avec ce
qu'on a oui oui
donc
je trouve pas ça très cher plaît de
votre part mais bon
on devrait créer un cheese comme Alsace
nous dites chaises comme fr c'était pas
mal
après il y aurait une chasse comme BZH
j'ai l'impression que tu as fait des
Camerons c'est un nouveau truc que
Laurent
[Musique]
tous les gens me disant je pense que tu
as zoomé
en Inde pour fixer les caméras des
joueurs c'est à dire qu'ils sont réalise
pour mettre leur caméra
on aurait dit que tu avais zoomé ouais
Saint-Malo est d'accord il pense que tu
as zoomé aussi
on vote est-ce que est-ce que j'ai zoomé
ou pas
les idées de chaise comme chascom
régionaux ça commence à ça commence à
venir dans le chat ça va faire affaire
concurrence à France 3 ça
ils ont qu'à bien se tenir France 3 ils
sont inquiets là avec cette belle idée
de chasse comme fr alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe encore il faut que je
vois évidemment mais je l'avais vu le
petit pousseur j'attends que la pose
pour lui expliquer à Laurent que c'est
le petit poussin
je sais pas combien le mettre parce qu'à
chaque fois ça change en fonction de ta
voix
est-ce que tu fais exprès de changer ta
voix le son le niveau de ta voix
franchement je reste proche du micro je
bouge pas parce que c'est vrai que ça te
facilite pas la tâche j'en dis
l'histoire j'ai baissé dites-moi si ça
va ou pas je dois être un peu plus haut
que toi encore je le vois je le vois à
l’œil je suis un peu plus haut que
Laurent sans écouter évidemment alors
oui est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on en pense
donc une italienne une italienne un
petit peu débutant avec ce cas il s'est
trois qui qui est en train de devenir la
mode interviennent de bébé mais à la
mode parce que finalement faute de mieux
un petit peu ça donne des positions tout
à fait jouables c'est vrai qu'on a de
l'espace
très intéressant c'est c'est très chaud
très chaud pour tout le monde ici
parce que il y a un contre jeu qui a été
créé quand même à le roi bon maintenant
c'est quand même pénible l'histoire
simplement je serais bien de et
le petit B5 qui a été joué Laurent c'est
pénible quand même de le gérer je te
baise tellement que là on va plus
t'entendre je te le dis
c'est une course les blancs sont
quasiment gagnants entre guillemets à
eldam complètement
nous dit oui oui
je pense qu'il était un peu désespéré de
ta technique mais l'accès c'est bon
MG4 menace cavalier F4
attention
pour Laurent là il peut rien sur les
cames je vous confirme effectivement que
me semble un peu trop stable Laurent
et j'ai l'impression que tu as mis une
photo
c'est vrai que ce serait moins embêté
avec l'histoire des photos c'est pas mal
des photos
alors du coup comment on fait pour gérer
je mets plus fort
j'ai bien mis le bon le bon micro donc
normalement c'est bon
je me mets un peu plus fort
parce que c'est bon comme ça
on va voir on va voir
tu vas commencer à être un peu tout le
monde dit désolé désolé c'est bizarre ça
change une fois sur l'autre le son
c'était le truc le plus dur à régler
un jour il y a peut-être une mise à jour
automatique Obs qui permettra une sorte
de réglage automatique très quand même
très comme vraiment sympa j'ai installé
une mise à jour en plus ça doit être
pour ça que mon son à baisser
ça peut alors est-ce qu'on peut croquer
et après j'aimerais bien faire quelque
chose comme toi F2 fois et puis blindé
blindé la défense
les deux
donc possible
ouais peut-être que j'aurais pu mettre
l'autre en là c'est pas de chance je
mets ça sur le compte de la chance tu
vois j'aurais pu mettre
l'autre cavalier et qui prendrait deux
et ça devait marcher il a eu peur Prague
il joue tomber 3 coups latéral de
défense très logique
et d'ailleurs j'y pense sur cavalier F4
on pouvait pas faire un G3 de défense
aussi tout simplement
si je te prenais en assis selon
on n'aime pas toucher à ça non
c'est vrai mais comme j'ai le foot casse
blanche je me dis bon c'est quand même
docteur remis celui-là mais bon
je suis un peu perturbé là
tu joues dans ma H3 bon bah je crois
qu'en F4
ouais j'en sais rien en fait je montre
voilà ou cavalier H3 ou ce genre de
choses que tu es sur autre chose Laurent
parce que c'était pas les mêmes
variantes que d'habitude
ouais non mais je réfléchis à peu
près que c'était un peu plus light là
vous avez vu ça se voit quand Laurent
fait des réglages le niveau de qualité
de d'habitude les variantes alors on
voit toujours plus vite que moi mais là
je sentais que je marchais sur l'eau
avec ma variante qui était somme toute
assez modeste j'avais à peu près un coup
de profondeur et je crois que Laurent
est à un demi coup de profondeur donc du
coup bah j'étais assez content ça a bien
marché accordé il faut bien que tu
gagnes de temps en temps écoute
merci merci à toi Laurent merci pour la
bonne cause
j'espère que j'aurai les blancs dans ce
cas-là en venant hein
souvent tu aimes bien prendre les Noirs
qu'on est plus fort et j'ai vu ça tu vas
au front quand il faut je vais au front
mais les Indiens je suis toujours un peu
plus timide en général ah d'accord
il m'a envoyé contre
c'est vrai que
ça ça va
ça va je m'en suis sorti quoi enfin
j'étais content mais je suis pas hyper
enthousiaste tu vois j'essaye de
négocier il y a quand même
sérieux c'est quand même plus plus
comestible normalement et puis
normalement je m'en sors bien c'est négo
vu que les étrangers je switch en fait
c'est à dire que comme il y a des
étrangers dans nos équipes de Top 16 on
parle du Top 16 là il y a des étrangers
bon ben on suit quand on fait la compo
switch en français comme ça ils
comprennent pas et puis à la fin on
donne leur checker et donc en général
c'est bon c'est pas un truc qui les
arrange
donc
voilà
c'est négo pour le coup nos joueurs
indiens en fait la seule exigence qui
les ont c'est de jouer tout le temps le
maximum de matchs
même si je dois avoir les blancs j'ai
une fois de plus c'est noir normalement
le lendemain c'est les blancs quoi en
fait si j'ai pas les blancs je vais vous
dire
[Rires]
donc c'est ça le c'est ça l'exigence
alors cavalier FC c'est comment ça
marche cette histoire et bien écoute
c'est toujours pas clair est-ce que ça
va mieux au niveau du son dites-moi
dites-moi c'est pas possible c'est un
peu mieux je crois mais je sais pas non
plus
je crois que c'est vraiment mieux là tu
es vraiment mieux on s'est rapproché là
tel que je pouvais le voir
[Rires]
moi je relayais comme fr qui dit ça
passe voilà je vais être un peu plus
haut alors un peu plus haut que toi
si ça passe c'est pas bon
je veux que ça soit bon
je comprends pas
je vais encore plus fort
allez voilà ça va ça va être mieux
tu es proche de la vérité ouais ok
un peu un peu ta sortie sur discord
tiens Kevin débrouille avec ça allez on
va aller voir Daniel duboff au 1 pendant
que il nous fait un petit réglage
qu'est-ce qui se passe danil petite
forme chez Daniel du bof aujourd'hui
assez terrible là qui est moins bien qui
vient de perdre en option on va le voir
à l'image non il est pas là
de réduire un peu ma sortie sur discord
si je fais un moment il y a pas de Nil a
perdu un pion tout simplement il est en
mode défense contre un jeune indienne
qui a été
extraordinaire dans la partie d'avant
mais
c'est un peu effondré enfin un peu
effondré elle est tombée a priori les
problèmes de problèmes de connexion
et elle est très très statique
je sais pas si tu vois si tu remarques à
l'écran mais en fait elle est froze ils
sont froses les Indiens
ils sont plus du tout dans le col
ils sont il me paraissent un peu un peu
bloqué effectivement pendant que je suis
en train de regarder les paramètres les
paramètres audio on peut dire que c'est
il m'a dit
alors il y a un problème la terre - 5
sur pour les experts regarde ce que
discord m'a dit si l'indicateur est vert
cela signifie que discord transmettent à
magnifique voix non mais regarde non
mais écoute regarde c'est ce qu'on fait
voilà peut faire le volume de sortie
tu as moins 5 sur mon truc Obs et moi je
suis à 0
seconde pour Daniel Dubos face à 16 et
c'est très chaud aussi de bof perd cette
partie ça va être compliqué mais
attention
internet ça joue sur ça c'est un peu
malheureux quand ça se joue sur ça mais
c'est un peu la vérité là elle a perdu
déjà la première partie autant espérons
que sa connexion redevienne stable parce
que c'est quand même moche
ouais c'est pas mal chasse comme à faire
c'est peut-être comme fr c'est vrai que
là il y a vraiment une grosse paire de
techniciens
et normalement je vais être pas mal là
je pense
alors elle essaie d'échanger elle joue
la gagne évidemment mais elle a bien
raison de jouer à gagner elle a un pion
de plus il y a pas de raison de pas
jouer la gagne
en faire très très mauvaise du début de
journée en tout cas pour pour Duba
il avait déjà pas fait une partie
merveilleuse de la première partie et
c'est comme le buteur dans l'équipe
c'est modeste ouais c'est un bongood je
te comprends ah ben tu vois c'est bien
là
alors pas du tout si tu avais fait du
bon travail sur Obs on en serait pas là
et du coup après je peux récupérer le
tir effectivement mais j'avais pas envie
de mordre sur ton travail alors tu mens
tu mens c'est pas ton honneur je vais
dévoiler nos conversations privées
de prendre un peu le lead sur le réglage
du son voilà je vais je l'ai fait avec
une certaine aisance une certaine
aisance tu mens et c'est pas beau c'est
des enfants écoute ne faites pas comme
Kevin ne mentez pas comme ça
c'est pas beau gratuitement
c'est pas beau du tout et voilà on
pousse ses pions tout simplement on va
pousser encore et ça va être terminé
pour Daniel du bof quelle surprise
quelle surprise de voir avec Shelly
enfin quelle surprise moi petite
surprise parce que
tellement forte
en rapide c'est pas donné à tout le
monde
bon là c'est quand même de ce qu'on fait
enfin le pion donné enfin c'est pas mal
faut quand même aller chercher bien sûr
mais bon la fin là il a pas montré la
même résistance que
tu aurais pu faire actuellement
alors 5 jouer mais Foubert menace à deux
on a envie de voir un fou caler contre
quand même pour qu'elle nous montre ce
qu'on va le voir
pas impossible
quoique
ça reste complètement gagnant évidemment
on a
on a une série de coups mais là comment
on fait pour pas perdre ce cavalier on
peut pas on peut aller nulle part
il a bien raison on sait jamais
de battre un joueur comme ça
alors là il est assez clairement il veut
sacrifier son cavalier qu'on ne pions et
tester sa technique
là maintenant le pion est ok il y a
vraiment aucune chance
il va essayer clairement d'échanger
contre ce pion ça va être marrant
est-ce qu'elle connaît le double V
je pense que oui
je pense que elle va la gagner après on
a vu avec peu de temps comme ça il faut
quand même bien très très bien maîtriser
cette technique de maths faut cavalier
on sait jamais complètement trivial
moi j'ai deux H3 mais je crois qu'elle
arrive même pas
sacrifier
et on va pousser
et c'est gagner
pour viceylie
énorme surprise ah il y a plus de
cavaliers à fond on fait dames et c'est
gagné tandis que sur les échiquier et
bien on a eu on a vu par Aviane qu'il a
emporté on avait bien sa position
face à Pradesh
et
programme
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
et bien en fait il a pas réussi à créer
d'attaque laser
et donc du coup quand on crée pas
d'attaque il était quand même moins bien
pour l'instant ce qui plombe un peu
l'équipe des Wizard c'est quand même un
double pas très en forme ah ouais et
voilà il a perdu au final ça faiblesse
le pur raciste donc je suppose que
ensuite ça a poussé ça a poussé
gentiment
et Valentina gounina qui a perdu face à
Niall Sarine pas une surprise elle
continue malheureusement ça mauvaise
process League pour l'instant mais bon
le contexte est quand même très relevé
ça fait 5 3 pour pour
mais en plus avec une déco de en plus
ils ont un internet quand même assez
instable apparemment donc il domine très
largement ce début de match exactement
c'est assez facile pour eux ils font
bien le taf donc évidemment on rappelle
c'est le premier la première équipe à
atteindre 8 et demi on va faire si tu le
veux bien mon cher mon cher Kevin une
légère pause il y a la deuxième partie
de match qui arrive et puis ensuite on a
le deuxième match à partir de 19h avec
avec qui
avec Magnus est stouf qui seront pas
dans la même équipe chacun son équipe
à lui tout seul quasiment pour les
chaises bras à l'équipe je me souviens
plus mais je l'ai là je vais montrer
quelle équipe c'était c'est les
passeurs
séviansov voilà des très très bons
joueurs mais
normalement face au chaise
qui sera titulaire mais en tout cas
Magnus Carlson est titulaire pardon donc
vous le verrez ça c'est c'est une
évidence on rappelle qu'il a cette série
depuis le début encore il a perdu une
partie il a été m'attendre donc ça va
être
ça va être quand même pas mal tu poses
en musique allez c'est la petite pause
la musique tu vas enflammer le
dancefloor du chat cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour pour cette
deuxième partie de match entre les
lévitors chess Wizards qui sont en
souffrance avec Daniel duboff à l'image
face aux Indiens qui voyez sont en
galère de d'Internet mais ça n'aimait
pas du tout en galère de de points ils
sont ils sont devant 5.3 vous voyez qui
en galère d'Internet ici c'est
il en manque que dans le ça doit être
NiAl
un peu rude par contre c'est vrai que
sur l'échiquier double qui est si fort
voilà le numéro 1 de l'équipe bah il est
en difficulté et il plombe un peu pour
l'instant sa team alors clairement
clairement on attendait on attendait
évidemment tout bof
beaucoup mieux admis sur deux en jouant
les deux joueurs les plus faibles sur le
papier bon c'est quand même c'est pas
tout à fait le genre de score auquel il
nous est habitué mais voilà c'est un jeu
aussi de forme ce jeu
ce jeu rapide ce jeu de partir rapide
c'est que ça se joue quand même sur sur
la forme donc voilà apparemment petite
forme aujourd'hui est-ce qu'elle va
durer général ça dure ce genre de choses
c'est c'est compliqué de se réveiller en
milieu de journée comme ça ça n'existe
pas trop c'était pas en forme tu perds
la confiance en fait tu vois c'est
compliqué
si on pense aussi à la partie perdue par
Voice avis justement
compa ravial ou elle avait quand même
dominé les débats de bout en bout elle a
continué pour jouer pour gagner comme
quasiment tous les joueurs indiens qui
sont vraiment des jusqu'aux-boutis dans
le fait d'essayer de gagner
ça lui a
pas souri mais sur le long terme alors
c'est important d'avoir cette mentalité
aux échecs de toujours jouer pour gagner
chez les jeunes c'est vraiment ce qu'il
faut apprendre sans faire n'importe quoi
non plus mais en tout cas dès qu'on a
des chances toujours joué toujours jouer
c'est une belle mentalité pour
progresser ça si je reconnais l'école
bretonne dans ton propos
on va devoir se passer de lui dans un
premier temps mais on a Dany Dubos
salut Fatou
et donc bon danyl bon et B5 alors ça
peut être un tilt mais ça c'est quelque
chose qui était donc j'ai déjà discuté
c'est pas idiot B5 parce que ça on va
faire foudre d'espace on empêche C4
aussi et finalement le pion il est pas
si facile à attaquer ici
dans certaines lignes
mais même bien jouer pour des trois
quatre aussi des fois là le purin déjà
en D4 et donc ça ça va ça ça va pour les
pour les noirs on va jouer comme ça des
6 kb7 c'est 5 en cavalière 3 ouais
clairement tout de suite on touche ce
pion alors si on fait B4 on donne la
belle case C4 attention à priori du jeu
par là et si on fait à 6 en général on
va faire C4 avec les Blancs et on pose
encore la question si on fait B4
maintenant on a plus cette case mais on
a créé
une nouvelle case qui est C200 encore
gagné un temps sur le pion qui s'est
quand même affaibli donc avalé à trois
il faut savoir comment réagir ici pas
évident d'ailleurs
bien sûr le coup c'est 4 proposé par
Laurent choc un petit peu en échange un
pion presque central contre un pion de
l'aile mais c'est pour l'activité vous
le voyez les pièces blanches vont très
bien dans cette situation et le coup
c'est ça qui est pas encore si facile à
jouer donc c'est c'est quand même les
blancs qui font la loi dans la position
tout à fait tout à fait donc on va voir
c'est la seule partie à avoir commencé
non il y en a une autre entre David
paraviane et pragalanda là c'est le
c'est les chocs des Titans clairement
aux deux premières tables
il faut qu'il se remette c'est pas
facile quoi
ouais ça c'est sûr
voilà donc on va mettre on va mettre
quelqu'un de
il y avait la cam front maintenant il y
a la cam de mes visages voilà
donc voilà pour pas qu'il y ait de
confusion
donc c'est par avion avec les Noirs mais
il est pas dans le col malheureusement
et on voit une rétine bon voilà les
joueurs qui continuent à pas jouer leurs
ouvertures finalement
il y a pas trop montrer de choses dans
les ouvertures bon voilà une petite
ligne
mais ça permet de garder les pièces
d'avoir une partie
pas franchement un avantage d'ouverture
clairement
pour les pour les blancs mais voilà il
veut juste il veut juste jouer aux
échecs
et ma foi espérer
qui pointera peut-être à 5 à 6 tous les
plans tous les pièces sont en liaison il
y a une certaine harmonie pour
travailler sur le sur la dame tout à
fait
donc classique des anglaises des
bureetti voilà on est vraiment dans le
grand classique position facile à jouer
il faut pas faire d'erreur tu vois je
l'ai vu et je me suis dit tiens bounida
et par là maintenant donc on a Valentina
qu'elle est blanc donc avec partout là
Valentina
contre weissli
qui est qui va apparaître sous vos yeux
ébahis
et non donc elle a les Noirs donc c'est
le duel entre les deux joueuses
exactement et on a une Feld tout ce qui
est de plus classique donc là on fait
c'est ça là on a le choix entre les
Indiens avec fougères 7 et on laisse
jouer au 4 ou la Grenelle en
contre-attaque tout de suite au centre
elle choisit c'est important de dernière
ronde avec les matchs équilibré
maintenant et gros avantage pour
l'Indian yogis quand même je pense alors
c'était plus équilibré sur le papier
donc c'est ça quand même très solide
pour les blancs bon elle a pas décidé
peut-être de stopper un petit peu
l'hémorragie parce que ça commence à
faire beaucoup de défaites
mais voilà bon ça c'est archi théorique
on joue dans les Blancs jouent 3 on va
se développer gentiment faut deux tout
le monde est à peu près content genre de
début parce que en fait ça donne une
vraie qualité à tout le monde
je pense pas qu'il va enfin on verra
peut se passer dans la même chose
évidemment c'est prendre les quatre
c'est prendre des quatre on peut changer
les dames si on a envie non elle fait
petit rock ou deux qui est C6 va arriver
on joue rock en général je vais montrer
tiens et ces six petit rock quand je
fais 5 conscience ces pièces d'un mac4
on veut faire tourner les tours C5 en
général avec les noirs on joue d'un
Massac
on peut dire que la majorité centrale
est beaucoup moins forte quand il n'y a
plus les dames sur l'échiquier quoi
ouais et aussi on a plus de mal
maintenant avec ce fond F5 qui est très
fort qui empêche le 4 et voilà on va
faire tourcer un les Noirs vont faire
tourner vite et en général ça donne des
finales très très légèrement avantageuse
pour les blancs parce qu'on a beau
centre quand même se fout je pas trop
mais
très ok aussi pour les noirs et elle
joue elle joue dans ma 5 échec qui va
certainement d'amener ces 6 revenir dans
le même genre de position on peut
imaginer un dame prank cavalier prend
petit rock et fou F5 qui serait une
transposition pure et dure
il y a encore du temps en tout cas
on va voir peut-être ouais ça c'est
clair n'importe quoi les caméras oui
d'ailleurs
du calme on fait ce qu'on peut parce
qu'il y a des joueurs qui ont pas
internet les pauvres c'est la demi-came
déjà pas mal
mieux que rien c'est mieux que rien il
va falloir s'en contenter
et donc c'est bien c'est vos camarade
quand même je vois à côté
il est pas là derrière ça qu'est-ce que
je vous dise moi
on a bien compris Laurent
pour t'embêter Laurent il est pas là il
est pas là
endom on dit que c'est Niels voilà
signal ça arrive alors
alors
qui essaie de A5 on a en fait ils ont
fait ce qu'on avait dit B4 qui essaie de
A5 et la qualité
pour faire certainement revenir par là
et mettre la pression ensuite sur ce
pion en V4 sans que les Noirs parce que
si on faisait tout de suite ça à ce
moment-là on pouvait pousser encore
cavalier et A4 et on avait bon une
structure
bien avancée en tout cas et pas
forcément faible avec ce pion à 4 qui
protège bien B3 et ce pion à 4 qui est
pas facile à attaquer
donc
assis jouer C4 B4 qui essaie de la 5 et
c'est 1
qui est des trois V6 et maintenant le
fameux A3 et cavalier à 6 ok qu'est-ce
qu'on en pense de cette position Kevin
on pense que les blancs sont un peu
mieux parce qu'ils ont mettre de
l'attention sur la dame du coup c'est un
petit peu désagréable
on peut échanger c'est un une sorte de
statue court mais les Noirs ne peuvent
jamais échanger normalement à cause de
la faiblesse sont A5 qui en découlerait
donc ce serait très très désagréable
donc c'est quand même plus facile de
jouer cette position avec les Blancs
est-ce que avec les noirs on doit jouer
à un moment pour C5 pour essayer de
[Musique]
renforcer un petit peu tout ça c'est une
question c'est intéressant alors tu
laisserais des cinq effectivement ton
fou j'aurais pas des masses il a décidé
de prendre l'autoroute par les cornes
nielsheim il a pris en B4 et du coup
danil a pas voulu garder son cavalier
ici il a dit bon tant pis je me fais une
faiblesse mais au moins je fais jouer ce
cavalier c'est une décision
et voilà cavalier prend et maintenant on
a cette faiblesse donc a priori on va
pas prendre ici à moins qu'on ait une
manière forcée de ensuite ramasser le
pion que je vois pas
que dame B3 mais il y aura toujours ce
C5 qui vient défendre quelque chose
comme ça peut-être du Fou d'un mp3 c'est
vrai qu'on aura on aura C5 ici et on
arrive quand même à protéger tout ça
gentiment
Sarine il joue dame B3
alors est-ce qu'on peut on peut il y a
la petite tactique bon c'est vrai que ce
fouet en prise mais derrière il reste
fou donc on peut prendre
est-ce qu'on prend de la dame du pion
c'est un peu alors là ça donne vraiment
un truc très très étrange
mais c'est vrai que puis on prend tout
est jouable en fait dans cette position
comment il fait si je veux pas prendre
pour moi il y a pas trop le choix
je vais essayer d'accord après on peut
imaginer un truc comme ça pour faire la
pression là-dessus tu prends je prends
ta tour en prise donc tu prends je
prends du fou je prends je prends je
prends j'ai perdu la paire de fou mais
bon contrôle des cases noires au centre
donc très intéressant stratégiquement de
grosses décisions à prendre et de
joueurs qui ont pas peur d'investir
d'investir beaucoup de temps dans les
positions désagréables si on se plante
sur le long terme alors c'est cela
l'histoire et comme les joueurs sont
quand même très habiles avec peu de
temps
et bien
[Musique]
ils ont peur de concéder une
une position inférieure donc tomber 8
jouer
par Daniel Dubeau j'allais le dire
tomber vite mais j'ai pas vu ce qui se
passe
en plus c'est assez
Laurent
bravo bravo le bol
bravo le bol tu vois je t'ai dit
ça joue sur ça
et joue gentiment il s'est évidemment
tourner c'est contre ces 5 on prend la
colonne pas du tout ouverte pour
empêcher un coup de C5 avec cette tour à
plus de chance de jouer en D quand F et
déjà on voit qu'elle empêche la poussée
c'est cette C5 donc intéressant tout ça
la tension est à son comble en tout cas
dans cette partie
dans ce champ de position
foot 4 ouais par exemple ouais
complètement jouable on reviendra pour
le zenote on va aller voir un petit tour
des stades on voit pranesh contre
la zavik avec la paire de fou pour pour
la zavik mais je crois que ça se tient
ce genre de choses
je sais pas ce que tu en penses on avait
une discussion avec Mathieu Cornat qui
donnait une règle très rigolote bon il
parlait de fou cavalier fou contre
cavalier et il disait que globalement
s'il y avait trois colonnes d'ouvertes
au centre le foie vraiment de fortes
chances de gagner
voilà ce qui est donc si on se réfère à
cette règle comme il y avait que deux
colonnes d'ouvertes bon même les changes
de fou ici il serait pas si favorable
donc c'est pour ça que les Blancs
essaient de faire quelque chose sans
doute d'essayer d'ouvrir la position et
de la paire de fou ça fait sens
que tu dis ah salut notre ami Mathieu
qu'il est dans le chat donc une bonne
règle
ouais non mais c'est pas mal écoute si
on veut ouais non c'est pas après c'est
toujours compliqué c'est un point de
repère
on n'a pas
on disait pas de mal pour l'instant
ouais ça va venir mais en tout cas quand
tout des règles ça a toujours ses
exceptions c'est ça le problème des
règles mais
ouais ça paraît de toute façon oui plus
la
position ouverte plus ça favorise
évidemment la paire de fou mais le truc
des trois colonnes peut-être
[Musique]
mais c'était un bon esprit de synthèse
cours à l'autre à apprécié la règle j'ai
l'impression
alors H5 et évidemment on fixe et
éventuellement c'est vrai que ce pion G7
plus tard alors on peut imaginer des
scénarios on espère le roi rentre ouais
mais c'est vraiment un scénario très
positif
[Rires]
effectivement pour l'instant on voit pas
trop le passage d'ailleurs il a été
fermé le passage et regarde je peux te
faire un truc comme ça tu fais ouais F2
roi G3 je te fais qui est C4
tu mets ton fou ici parce que tu as
envie de protéger ton pion je te connais
par cœur et maintenant je te fais ça et
bonne chance tu me fixes
on n'a pas ouvert ces fameuses trois
colonnes on a rien ouvert du tout
ouais elle est passive bon ça va faire
nul assez facilement pour notre jeune
ami pranesh surtout qu'il est bien
entendre il y a pas de raison qu'il se
fasse carotter exactement qui est-ce que
tu vas aller voir
la petite fille
[Musique]
c'est que paradisiane
bon je vais pas changer les caméras pour
ça
finale dont je parlais
elle avait pas une super version
je suis pas très très fan
de ce truc là
[Musique]
donc tu disais pardon parce que j'étais
occupé on n'arrive pas en fait ce serait
super de mettre le rond en 3 mais on a
du mal à l'accrocher à la case à cause
des foubet de fou B4 et Tours C3 quoi
c'est
mathématique ça peut gagner aussi un
scénario encore très optimiste c'est de
mettre le cavalier FC c'est
effectivement là on voit tout l'intérêt
de H6
donc c'est pour plus tard mais c'est
vrai que c'est normalement utile ce
cavalier à la bande le fameux cavalier
mvl
qui est pas très bien placé mais les
Noirs en gros un gros point positif dans
leur position c'est le contrôle de la
colonne C et ça c'est quand même très
important parce que c'est quand même
c'est dans des plaises à Mathieu
cornette qui nous regardent c'est la
seule colonne verte de la position le
mec qui a rien compris à la règle
et que cette paire de fou et tout donc
voilà il y a qu'une seule conne ouverte
Mathieu enfin qu'est-ce que tu racontes
donc voilà il y a pas de règle de la
seule colonne ouverte la seule qui est
ouverte si tu as une tour dessus bah tu
es plutôt mieux que celui qui a pas la
tour dessus voilà c'est une nouvelle
règle ça y est par contre c'est là il
est intéressant à appliquer parce
qu'elle est assez simple à appliquée du
coup elle est top ça va plaire à le
premier à en parler je pense ah c'est
vrai
que je vois pas le premier mais on sait
ce que tu avais un bon exemple à Laurent
un exemple assez concret
structure symétrique plus il y a des
colonnes ouvertes au centre plus le fou
a des chances de guerre pas mal oui
mais c'est sous-entendu donc donc ça
marche Mathieu normalement moi à mon
avis son pseudo c'est 33 pour agironde
et 3 pour les trois colonnes ouvertes
c'est ça c'est ça l'explication de tous
les trois
je vois pas d'autres trucs peut-être
alors F5 alors ça c'est ouais c'est
thématique de jouer F5 on veut essayer
de se libérer une casse par là en
général les blancs répondent F3 mais du
coup on a on a quand même libéré un
petit peu le roi de sa cage de sa prison
dorée en G8
exactement et donc ça fait sens par
rapport à ce que tu avais expliqué
l'histoire de cavalier 4 cavaliers F6
qui maintenant un lointain souvenir
alors il y a une île entre pranesh et
lasavik en s'y attendait donc ce que tu
m'as suggéré à la pause c'est que
maintenant on fasse on enlève le on
enlève les résultats regardez la
technique on arrive les résultats comme
ça on a pas de spoiler quand on regarde
les parties en direct mais on obtient au
courant évidemment s'il y a des
résultats moi je propose qu'on aille
voir
et bien notre ami cette partie qui est
quand même la plus endiablée de très
très loin entre danil douboff et une
trente contre une 40 on va se mettre les
caméras on va être bien on va être bien
on va faire croire que c'est hyper
important comme match en plus ouais
tout à fait tout à fait ça peut plier le
mal dans un sens dans l'autre c'est la
définition de plier le match alors on va
mettre notre ami danyle en caméra et on
va mettre notre ami Sarine je crois
qu'il est revenu idéal si il est pas
revenu je le fais passer pour un autre
indien je vous le dis tout de suite avec
une mauvaise foi incroyable et dans
c'est lui c'est bien lui on manque plus
Florange je suis d'accord avec toi par
rapport à cette jauge mais c'est une
obligation qu'on a de mettre de la jauge
ouais en rapide non c'est pas du tout
obligatoire on fait comme on veut
donner cette consigne d'art de mettre la
jauge
et avec avec stouf on est même pas trop
parce que bon ça perdure un peu le
jugement honnêtement je suis pas fan à
partir de je suis pas fan en partie
rapide je suis fan ça va trop vite
ça nous permet de suivre
un peu
alors
dame F5 contre jeu pour danyl doubove
qui essaie de faire en sorte que quelque
chose se passe et on va voir maintenant
les deux super blitzer avec Niels
peut-être avec Nakamura le meilleur
monde
clairement
donc il a pas peur de se laisser 30
secondes ne faites pas ça surtout si
vous avez deux secondes d'incrément 30
secondes c'est pas raisonnable
malheureusement cavalier enragé qui est
un F de Sciences Po et qui voudrait
remplir un petit questionnaire
assez pas trop le sujet échiquier quoi
donc ton questionnaire ça va être un peu
compliqué
pour le coup parce que tu en penses
Laurent au moins ça a été demandé
gentiment en plus et très poliment mais
le sujet est un peu
alors fous des quatre jouets par
[Musique]
ni halseine OK et H4 Daniel qui va
essayer de planter un pion H3 on sait
jamais ça peut passer des maths du
couloir un matin G2 venu de nulle part
bon on n'y croit pas trop mais
coup de quelqu'un qui joue dans une
équipe qui est en tête et oui j'ai la
peur un petit peu et oui il a bien
raison
parce qu'ils sont en tête donc nul
chaque demi point les rapproche des 8 et
demi on va voir danyl alors discontin
qui échange pas les dames je te le
garantis
4 danine mais la pression sur ce pion il
reste autour et la foule prend le 5
vas-y je te joue hyper solide il faut
prendre il va jouer cavalier F3 on veut
tout échanger en monastère
est-ce qu'il y a pas du pion projet 3
fous prends G3 là
il croit pas à ça ouais on a pas les
tours qui arrivent assez rapidement
attention B3 petit coup de
surprise
c'est très bien joué fixation sur sur
case noire du fion B2
maintenant c'est une petite souffrance
attention autour des 8 à tour des 8
tours 17 bien vu est-ce que je peux tout
échanger croquer croquer eux deux
ça va vite envoyer là les joueurs n'ont
plus de temps clairement on fera un
petit point sur le classement vous
inquiétez pas on fait un petit point sur
le classement après après la troisième
partie
on voit on va regarder ça évidemment que
Blitz c'est toujours et plus que jamais
dans la compète et ça va faire prendre
mes deux qui prend B3 mais ce n'est pas
de limitation directe les illuminations
vont pas tarder à arriver quand même
mais ça sera toujours pas élimination
directe c'est un format hybride et il y
aura huit équipes à la fin qualifiées et
là ça sera vraiment l'élimination
directe
salut
il nous reste
il nous reste cette finale peut-être
qu'il y a de la plus intéressante entre
21h gounina et vice et il va-t-elle
enfin débloquer son compteur
ça paraît pas être une superposition et
puis on des et contre reichli qui est
très impressionnante depuis le début
en difficulté
en difficulté une fois de plus et
attention on est à
entre farine
Siska ça peut faire un 4
alors que B4 échec et on va prendre le
pion à deux
on va encaisser pourquoi pas
complètement perdu
éventuellement pour prendre dans des
conditions différentes mais elle n'a pas
tant que ça de temps
après tout ces trois par exemple ça
c'est facile
alors c'est facile non mais tours
ça a l'air de créer une ambiance assez
purement et puis bon il suffit d'amener
le roi en dessin qu'après ce sera
peut-être pas si facile quand même mais
bon
elle va le faire elle va le faire
tourner salut à toi chaise 525
on est inquiet pour pour gounina et
c'est juste que vice Ali elle vérifie
quoi comme elle sait qu'elle a gagné
normalement en déconnant pas
surtout aussi aussi les deux
ça serait moche mais ça pourrait jouer
un tour exactement elle bouge encore sur
la caméra ça c'est plutôt bon c'est
trois jouets
c'est le coup pragmatique
on a un pion de plus on fait pas
n'importe quoi
il est sur noir en plus même celui-là
n'est plus si bon il est faible on peut
le dire est-ce qu'on encaisse on peut
aussi il y a technique blocale
les meilleurs sont là les meilleurs sont
venus moi je vous le dis
et tu as vu Florian qui dit envie de
Twin mais bon après c'est Laurent qui
décide quand je regarde tu vois et je
les ai bien élevé quand même et non je
décide plus de rien mon cher Florent
c'est fini ce temps là cette dictature
éclairée évidemment sur chaise 24 est
terminé maintenant je subis je subis les
je subis la loi même Kévin et
a plus de pouvoir que moi rendez-vous
compte
c'est incroyable
j'aurais sauté depuis longtemps vous le
savez nous avec stouffe on est quand
même de l'ancien école on n'ose pas des
modules comme ça
à tire larigo comme dirait certains
Laurent j'essaie de trouver une
expression de ton temps
c'est possible que j'ai déjà j'ai déjà
employé ces expressions ça c'est sûr
de plus et attention il reste quand même
du monde
s'en sortir on va on va vite revenir
avec le roi ah elle a peut-être un petit
peu pas jouer au top là rob5
et ensuite c'est le petit frère qui a
passé par là j'ai quatre d'abord c'est
ambitieux OK
mais pourquoi pas ouais c'est
intéressant j'ai pas pensé
et à 5 quand même bien joué
3 ça va normalement terminer le travail
bien joué quelle technique tu as vu ça
et ça a gagné ça va gagner
[Musique]
en fait je me suis fait réfuter un petit
peu l'idée de d'enlever le tableau des
scores alors avec la petite ligne en bas
du terminé de toute façon
avoir du mal à une pièce de moins et
elle s'est barrée elle s'est barrée donc
on va avoir du mal à faire croire que
c'est tendu quoi tu vois même si ça joue
toujours
mais là c'était un peu plus tendu que
d'habitude ouais c'est bon écoute
[Musique]
on voit que les Indiens sont très très
dominants ils ont été ils ont été bon ce
soir et en face de toute façon tu as du
Booba qui coûte cher il fait moins et
demi plus plus un et demi ça change
complètement les choses avec un meilleur
Daniel louboff voilà après on va pas
c'est un super joueur mais il est moins
en forme que d'habitude donc alors
regardez ce que je vous ai préparé
mais bon c'est le classement et oui
c'est le classement et donc on voit ce
système suisse alors ce système suisse
qui est évolutif c'est-à-dire que il y a
des équipes c'est pas huit équipes qui
soient évidemment c'est d'abord 3 et
puis deux et puis 3 alors je sais pas en
quel ordre exactement au fil des
semaines les premières éliminations vont
commencer et voyez les trois dernières
équipes il y a des équipes qui sont en
danger
comme les Charlotte Cobra mais
d'ailleurs je crois que ils sont en
rouge là donc je crois que c'est mort
pour eux voilà on voit les premières
éliminations donc les Charlotte Cobra
qui sont éliminés il ne faut surtout pas
se faire éliminer et on voit
qui sont en train de perdre contre il
joue contre qui là les Indiens c'est
c'est eux non c'est les indianes dans
les années très sérieuse enfin en tout
cas option pour être dans les dans les
derniers 8 les arts sont toujours très
bien on voit qu'ils vont ils vont rester
quand même bien Tiger ça va jouer aussi
Gotham Knights
qui ont battu la semaine dernière
l'équipe de Blitz donc l'équipe de Blitz
stream nos amis français
[Musique]
qui vont jouer qui vont jouer demain ils
vont jouer demain alors demain on
commencera un match à 16h30 je sais plus
lequel c'est
mais ça sera un beau match de toute
évidence on a que ça des beaux matchs je
vais regarder ça tout de suite Nathan
m'a évidemment envoyé le top nail mais
je me rappelle plus je me suis surtout
préparé pour aujourd'hui et pour la
grande venue évidemment de Magnus
Carlsen
donc je pense que demain ça sera les
Shanghai Tiger contre l'équipe de VI
contre l'équipe de derey bon bah du beau
spectacle en perspective non non demain
c'est Nakamura pardon 16h30 Nakamura
face à l'équipe de Vailly donc l'équipe
chinoise qui qui gagne tout pour
l'instant Nakamura et Gotham Knights
je suis allé voir j'avais l'info donc on
a ça on a Nakamura d'abord en première
partie de soirée et en deuxième partie
de soirée on vous envoie vers stream et
vous pourrez suivre encourager
évidemment
nos amis de Blist stream on verra la
compo on découvrira la compo demain mais
je peux aller je vous la donne je la
connais à composer Kevin il faut donner
il faut donner il faut donner il faut
donner on voit donc ils ont ils ont un
sur deux donc c'est le match suivant
fait que soit ils sont
soit ils sont en danger de d'être
éliminé c'est hyper demain soit ils sont
très très bien pour se qualifier donc le
match de demain est capital donc la
compo de demain ça sera Alexander
grichuk
au premier au deuxième
Maxime va chier Lagrave le champion du
monde de bus 2022 ensuite King of the
need Maël Boyer très joueur très
souplassé on le sait en 2004 mais en
rapide et Blitz online beaucoup beaucoup
plus fort même en classique d'ailleurs
plus fort que 2004 et avec Sacha
gritchou qui est Maxime bah ils sont
obligés aussi d'équilibrer la moyenne au
fond il faut le rappeler et donc c'est
pas mal hein d'équilibrer avec Maëlle
c'est quand même très très sympa et
ensuite au dernier on aura démanté
démenté
dolipt donc
sache Corvette
exactement voilà très très connu
évidemment de la Communauté française
donc très belle équipe
ça sera face il faut que je rebosse du
coup je sais pas qui c'est mais en tout
cas ça sera
ça sera sur sur Blitz stream à suivre en
direct voilà avec le capitaine qui vibre
c'est normal c'est bien sûr de faire
cette compète moi j'ai peut-être lancé
on va peut-être faire j'ai peut-être
fait une équipe avec mes collègues du
chicken cheese club
il faut être il faut être faut être il
faut être antiquique pour pour jouer on
gagne pas de partie il faut jouer que
pour faire nul voilà sinon on n'est pas
on n'est pas on n'est pas inclus alors
on va voir cette dernière cette dernière
onde mais en tout cas exploit là je sais
pas ce que tu en penses
mais exploit demandé
[Musique]
mais elle est en souffrance donc du coup
il faudrait qu'elle gagne sa partie
et pour l'instant je lui porte pas
pas chance à Valentina gounina non c'est
sûr c'est la défaite et pendant ce temps
j'ai mis par hasard je me suis trompé de
scène mais par hasard hasard fait
parfois bien les choses j'ai mis la
compo du match de 19h donc avec ces
chaises bras qui joueront face au Garden
State
passeuse donc on voit Samse très très
connu online très dangereux michera qui
est le détenteur du record du plus jeune
grand maître au monde et caressaie je
crois qu'elle était championne des
États-Unis déjà elle est très très jeune
face au chessbra Maëlys aidé jade oui
alors j'ai pas la rêve je suis vraiment
désolé c'est une jeune femme très
certainement talentueuse ensuite on a
ils sont une super équipe et
le King le kingsen donc très très belle
équipe on va regarder donc on a le
format ici mais en fait j'ai pas les
résultats individuels
j'essaierai d'aller les
en tout cas ce qu'on sait puisqu'on suit
c'est que Daniel Dubois fait des devants
avec un sur trois et Valentina pas mieux
0 sur 3 il les met dedans ça c'est sûr
quand on a deux joueurs qui font qui
font 1/6 c'est assez catastrophique on
va pas se mentir mais pour Duba il doit
vraiment être au-dessus parce que
normalement c'est le c'est le buteur de
l'équipe il est attendu comme ça à ce
niveau là et c'est pas du tout le cas et
puis Nina c'est légitimement plus
difficile mais c'est vrai qu'elle a
perdu un match très important qu'on doit
échalia à l'instant et ça ça
va donc on a danil qui va jouer contre
ce qui le dernier qui lui reste à jouer
c'est pas malandage je crois il vient de
jouer ça il doit être tout à fait
exactement je te remercie de m'aider
c'est toujours
je t'attendais un petit peu pour voir si
tu avais parce que tu me parles souvent
de tes notes donc du coup les voir un
peu si
on arrive heureusement il va arriver il
est de ils mettent plus je te le dis il
peut-être plus il est plus dans
l'empathique toi
non je plaisante pas oh non
de très bonnes compositions tout le
temps ça on est d'accord il a l'air
mais bon
ouais tu fais peut-être plus de bêtises
aussi dans un certain sens avec moi tu
fais des bêtises techniques donc du coup
je suis obligé de les souligner
donc
Daniel qui n'a appris pas commencé
dites-moi si vous voyez une partie mais
je la vois pas en tout cas
et là il aura les blancs face à face à
Prague donc il doit
il faut que quelque chose se passe
clairement bon une défaite de
des levitov Wizard les condamne une
défaite individuelle
salut Andy
salut à vous n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions allez-y on rappelle sur
n'importe quelle chaîne 600 secondes
pour Kevin j'adore ce duo de choc merci
ça c'est sur quoi c'est sur cheesecom en
français sur Youtube n'hésitez pas à
nous faire un petit coucou ou que vous
soyez je viens lié de temps en temps
tandis que le pauvre Kévin n'a aucune
idée de là où se trouve le show donc il
peut pas il peut pas vraiment lire
m'occuper de tous les chats alors
j'ai pas envie de te voler la vedette au
niveau technique alors
je te remercie donc voilà n'hésitez pas
à poser vos questions à faire vos
remarques je crois que le son va mieux
vu que personne n'a fait de remarques
depuis pas mal de temps c'est toujours
comme ça avec la technique que des
remarques quand quand ça ne fonctionne
pas en alors que là maintenant tu as
réussi à trouver un son de qualité et
personne va souligner
six semaines se pue du chômage technique
je sais pas
en tout cas très bien accueilli très
heureux d'être ici très bien accueilli
par
[Musique]
cheesecom
en français en particulier jescom en
général et je dirais cheesecom en
français
en particulier est très heureux qu'une
synergie puisse se créer entre
entre anciennement
en français de chaise 4 d'ailleurs le
site reste voilà
et les vidéos on a essayé justement
d'avoir de mettre ça sur toutes les
chaînes pour que tout le monde puisse en
profiter
il y a beaucoup de compètes aussi qui
arrivent donc ça c'est agréable je pense
beaucoup de choses online
il y aura des tournois il y aura
beaucoup de tournois à suivre de plus en
plus il les échecs il y a un boom donc
voilà on est on n'est pas voilà c'est de
plus en plus donc on suivra de plus en
plus d'événements c'est aussi ça l'idée
c'est de pas au lieu de suivre au lieu
de suivre sur deux chaînes différentes
des événements les mêmes événements mais
on suit plus d'événements plus
d'événements sur une seule chaîne donc
en fait vous y gagnez quoi c'est un peu
moins de choix ça c'est vrai que niveau
concurrent ça n'a pas fait du bien tu
vois
en général on va pas se mentir vous
voyez niveau concurrence ça a pas donc
ça pas fait émerger de nouveaux
concurrents effectivement mais niveau
contenu
c'est mieux voilà et on a qui arrive qui
arrive avec
de beauf donc avec les Blancs contre
paga et on a une une ça avait déjà
commencé ouais j'ai raté le début comme
d'habitude en comptant des histoires
pourquoi pas ça garde les pièces
regardez ce qu'il veut Daniel c'est une
position complexe
et à double tranche et on va faire F3 et
ensuite certainement E4 on va essayer de
préparer ça en tout cas c'est les plans
normaux exactement sur F3 on voit
souvent le coup C5 thématiques c'est
vraiment le les clés dans ces structures
F3 C5 tout à fait souvent une réaction
légitime dès qu'on joue
et dès que F3 est joué il y a E3 en
l'air donc on peut jouer ces 5 ça c'est
les petits
petit thème structurel on va dire
important dans les positions tout à fait
non j'ai pas de chaîne Youtube c'est la
chaîne Youtube chaise 24 en français
allez voir il y a plus de il y a
beaucoup plus que 1000 heures de contenu
donc vous pouvez vous amuser allez voir
ça par contre toi tu as un site enchères
j'ai suffisamment parlé de cette
plateforme en ligne tu m'as tu m'as
relancé gentiment à chaque fois pour que
j'en parle Laurent et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai pas fait la promo
mais vous pouvez aller voir la
plateforme en ligne la chaîne Youtube et
je peux même vous mettre ça dans le chat
si je suis sympa vas-y est-ce que moi je
vais faire de la pub mais alors
complètement mais alors complètement
désintéressé je n'ai aucune pour ersing
nos amis
complètement désintéresser à part qu'ils
étaient sponsors quand même du premier
tournoi sur du premier toit du champion
de chasseur donc sur cheescom donc ça a
tout à fait tout à fait ici voilà c'est
encore on remercie nos amis dersings et
oui parce que quand le l'air est mauvais
pour respirer et bien on joue moins bien
aux échecs
et puis si tu as du radon chez toi tu es
pas tu es pas bien
je te dis tout de suite Kevin fais
attention si tu t'achètes de boîtier R6
qui est quand même assez utile je dois
je veux pas faire le télé achat mais
c'est assez utile alors ça durera donc
chez toi tu tu prends femme et enfant et
tu pars
très très beau ici c'est tu vas direct
aux urgences voilà je te le dis d'accord
et je m'y connais mais normalement c'est
bon ça va pas
et regarde ce qu'il fait pousser un B5
et cavalier B1 ça
je vous ai mis le lien pour ceux qui
veulent découvrir la plateforme ah non
j'ai failli mettre le lien mais bon tu
sais que techniquement ça peut peut y
avoir des blagues
ouais donc on voit ok bien qui attaque
ce pion ou pas vraiment apparemment il
considère que non sur dame processus je
suppose qu'il veut faire fois 6 c'est se
créer du jeu c'est vrai que c'est un peu
bizarre là les pièces on a pas trop
envie d'ouvrir le jeu peut-être qu'il y
a eu des deux d'abord pour essayer de
venir un F3 et en E5 ou en B3 et en C5
quelque chose comme ça
mais en tout cas
poussez on pouvait s'y attendre parce
que la tour est passée donc ça va le fou
le fou est pas mal ici mais c'est vrai
que kays c'est quand même c'est quand
même assez spécial
de la part de
on voit qui joue un peu bizarrement
aujourd'hui
sur cette partie aux deux on a aussi
Valentina gounina on a 26,9 donc on sait
elle est noire contre pranesh pranesh il
rigole pas ça pourrait aussi venir de là
la décision
enfin en gros on a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de mal
avoir les joueurs de
lévitofu witherd revenir clairement
tellement ils ont des joueurs peu en
forme et tellement ils sont derrière au
score mais c'est ton jamais une carreau
canne jouer fous des quatre on essaie de
garder ce pion on va jouer F3 on essaie
de garder les deux pions et c'est pas
impossible
qu'on ait du mal à récupérer
si tu avais vu ce que j'ai fait orange
était déconnecté de twitch et ça a été
tout un truc incroyable incroyable
pendant que je perdais mon oreillette et
c'est pénible j'ai mes nouvelles
oreillettes sont pas terribles sacrée
team sacrée team c'est un truc tu sais
c'est pas comme toi avec les filles là
moi c'est moderne c'est le bluetooth
mais honnêtement c'est hyper bien tu
vois ces petits écouteurs tu vois
des fois en filaire tu es pas malheureux
comme ça Laurent et c'est ils sont très
bonne qualité c'est important
et en fait je suis tranquille avec ça
j'ai tout essayé j'avais le casque avant
tout ça c'est mieux les petits écouteurs
avec le fil je trouve
plus sympa d'accord alors tu as tout mes
secrets techniques alors je suis ravi
vraiment
sur la plateforme sur mes petits
conseils techniques Laurent pour toi un
pack dédié ouais ça serait bien vas-y
alors ces trois on protège ce regarde il
s'accroche à son purin clairement il a
joué pour garder son pion
un des deux pions et quand pas le donner
comme ça il a 10 minutes à la pendule
contre 650 contre pour Valentina au bout
du huit coups ça sort déjà un mauvais
dur pour
pour Valentina et puis trois bulles ça
fait toujours beaucoup hein moralement
Laurent on peut le dire c'est toujours
difficile à supporter surtout qu'elle
est pas au dessus de ses joueurs là donc
c'est qu'elle va avoir forte à faire à
la quatrième partie alors qu'elle Enja
elle a déjà pris trois bulles tout à
fait et on a Niall Sarine qui a les
noirs
contre eux
contre qui a-t-il les noirs
contre paraviane
ils ont bougé ils ont bougé ils font des
blagues
c'est pas sympa
cadre pas par avion
et donc on a une Espagnole écoute ma foi
tout à fait classique un peu H4 un peu
bizarre
c'est comment qu'on va faire c'est dans
cette position c'est dur après avoir les
B3 c'était vraiment
une bonne question là j'ai l'impression
qu'à poser parviane ani alsarine avec le
dernier coup cavalier B3
donc on voit les joueurs se développent
à peu près normalement mais qui est B3
pour venir à 5
l'idéal 4 toujours bien sûr qu'on a dans
ces positions avec la pointe B5 noir
comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure il y aura
pas B4 cette fois un peu travaillé dans
ces positions là sur le pion B5
là on a passé 6 à temps peut-être c'est
si il y a pu comprendre et me prendre 6
ouais c'est ça c'est ça donc
je prends
tu aimes pas faire des pions faibles
comme ça
non bah je préfère éviter effectivement
Laurent
pas t'expliquer tes élèves toute la
journée qu'il faut pas faire les pions
isolés comme ça et là tu es assez dur là
tu parles crédibilités
c'est pas terrible c'est pas terrible
donc à 4 mais je peux laisser à 4 mais
on remarques tu vas tu vas me laisser te
prendre et je vais foudre c'est ça mon
pion en V5 peut être une faiblesse et
une cible pour les blancs on va voir ce
qu'il va faire je suis curieux
d'ailleurs KF3 il a fait cavalier 8
ça j'aime pas le travail ça j'aime pas
du tout mais non on va faire 4 ton coup
ouais A4 est-ce que est-ce qu'on croque
en baisser à ton a pas besoin de gros
Québec
c'est le cauchemar il va jamais jouer ce
fou et en C8 on peut jamais parce que
c'est la méga fourchette
je crains le pire avec avec stouf qui
met Kevin je vais t'envoyer un WhatsApp
important regarde stp c'est urgent ça tu
tu penses que c'est vraiment important
ou pas je sais pas après il a l'air
bienveillant mais et non mais il peut
être bienveillant mais il peut être
je pense que il est un peu tout dans son
sac ouais à mon avis non
et quelle idée de il revient il en remet
un coup par il nous a pas du tout écouté
sur la prise du Fou B7 c'est je trouve
ça très étonnant de prendre comme ça
mais bon ça reste mieux pour les blancs
et la paire de fou et surtout on voit
ces deux petits pions qui sont sur casse
blanche et qui sont là merci finalement
de ce fou de casse blanche une fois
qu'on aura joué c'était c'était
assez important mais ça c'est pas mal
c'est important vraiment ouais ouais
ouais ouais c'est un truc c'est un truc
je peux pas gérer en direct live mais
c'est un peu ça c'est un peu ça
je me suis fait Pia pirater un compte je
sais pas trop comment c'est possible
mais voilà
tu connais la double authentification
par je l'ai sur twitch bravo
mais sur Facebook je sais pas trop
ah tu as posté un truc sur facebook
d'accord bon donc
joué par NiAl qui j'aime pas du tout sa
position pour être très honnête on fait
à 400 on peut aussi commencer par bécane
pour être sûr de pas avoir d'histoire
sur A4 comme ça il y a plus de B4 et
ensuite on va faire à 4 et on est sûr en
plus on prend la case du cavalier j'aime
bien le coup B4 très honnêtement on va
voir ce qu'il va faire il m'écoute pas
du tout il fait qu'il y avait trois pour
en remettre une couche par là et surtout
B6 il va faire 4 je vous le donne en
mille
c'est chiant
on va voir attention je peux dire qu'il
a du bol que je sois pas attends mais je
vais passer je vais être modo t'inquiète
bientôt on va reprendre les bonnes
vieilles habitudes tu vas voir tu es
obligé de modérer ce genre de personnage
alors ça je le connais aussi de toute
façon 125
très sympathique un mais il faut savoir
lui-même des limites oui c'est ça moi
j'ai entendu qu'il était très
incompétent d'après certains de ces
employeurs de ces employeurs précédents
qui était pas mécontent qui partent
terrible mais bon je vais pas faire de
la mauvaise pub non plus mais c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit
devoir donner
me force à le dire dame G5 on attaque le
four G3
oh là là moi je jouerai ça
je changerai les dames pour focaliser
sur l'aile sur l'aile sur l'aile dame il
y a un petit problème là c'est qu'il y a
ça et ça je peux pas protéger mon pion
quoique en fait si je peux protéger mon
pion
c'est quoi mon compte twitch en fait
j'utilise pas trop twitch je sais pas je
sais plus non j'ai un compte mais en
fait sur différents ordis il y en a un
moment où j'ai Chase 24 en français donc
là c'est ça peut-être je vais prendre ça
en fait en vrai comme ça ça permet
quelque chose 56
je sais plus je sais plus le deuxième
chiffre en fait bon mais j'y vais en
général là par exemple je suis connecté
sur twitch pour lire le chat je suis pas
connecté quoi je suis pas je suis en
mode
c'est pas facile il faut que je retrouve
le mot de passe de chaise 24 en français
voilà comme ça on va connaître
et puis te modérer modérer des gens
comme chaise 525 avec le compte chaise
24 en français sur cheesecov FR et bien
ça me fera plaisir c'est moi qui vend
c'est moi c'est motivant
525 c'est motivant en plus
on prend il est très mal alors ça c'est
bon pour les lévitof Wizard dans leur
remontée fantastique
quand on y croit pas trop est-ce que
Daniel du bof
enfin fait une bonne partie qu'est-ce
qu'on en pense et non il est très mal
Daniel de bof on va aller le voir à la
caméra
il est pour Prague ouais ouais il est un
peu plus d'ailleurs
pardon grosse souffrance voilà puis on
sait 5 et encaisser
voilà
il y a combien de colonnes ouvertes là
pour la théorie de Mathieu de Mathieu
donc c'est pas terrible du coup
on peut pas trop
de moi c'est encore moins bien on peut
même jouer toi deux j'ai envie de en
fait à cause de tout reprendre
tu t'amuses aujourd'hui avec moi
ah non mais en fait j'y ai pensé j'avais
envie pour le principe de la colonne
quoi
de là je me suis dit merde mais
apparemment ça marche peut-être mais
et c'est chaud et quand tu m'as parlé de
la colonne j'avais envie de montrer ça
tour à deux donc j'ai pensé à la bêtise
avant normalement ça marche après la
jauge
mais on sait pas pourquoi c'est assez
terrible
peut-être quelque chose comme ça ah
ouais j'ai trouvé tiens je pensais mais
on contrôlait toujours mais
de moins en moins quand même exactement
donc ça c'est possible mais il a pas
besoin de faire ça il fait tout à fait
la même idée on garde cette colonne bon
il y a peu de jeu pour danil mais ça va
être très très compliqué oh là là les
Wizards à mon avis ils vont prendre on
prend une sacrée à clé en fait pour
parce que j'ai l'impression que double
va perdre
ça fait déjà 9 et demi ça va faire un
score à deux chiffres tu vois ce que je
veux dire
ça va être ça va être lourd et dur et
donc ces Indiens comme les Chinois qui
se positionnent comme des gros gros
favoris de la compète
après tout est possible évidemment
H3 bon pourquoi pas on fait une petite
case
toute façon on a rien d'actif à faire
c'est pas la forme comme nous dit
portish on est bien d'accord on est tous
d'accord c'est une journée assez triste
doit être un peu fumasse
on en avait dit beaucoup de bien de
Daniel louboff et du coup il a fait une
mauvaise série après on reste des
parties ultra rapide indice plus 2
c'était pas très représentatif de la
qualité du joueur je pense aujourd'hui
ça arrive oh ça c'est une évidence
que c'est pas représentatif de son de
son niveau de jeu
évidemment mal dormi
des problèmes
toi par exemple tu vois tu connais tu te
fais engueuler par ta femme le matin bah
tu vas jouer moins bien tu joues moins
bien l'après-midi c'est pour ça que
depuis des années tu galères
parce que c'est compliqué ça arrive tous
les jours en fait sauf Kevin mais je lui
répéterai alors j'ai bien compris
j'y manquerai pas je vais répéter ça bam
tranquille au fait le rend a dit que
tu m'as envoyé tous les jours
parle la même occasion tu brisé ma
carrière
[Rires]
alors F3 bon il empêche cavalier 4 là il
se bat pour pour rester dans la partie
Daniel de bœuf et pour une petite
chanson on va rester sur cette partie
parce que ça peut terminer le match tout
simplement même ces 4 OH l'épicerie
il a bien raison il a bien raison de
d'assurer le coup là
il fait mal on rappelle que même quand
ce match est terminé à 19h il y a un
Magnus Carcen qui arrive et oui le
triple champion du monde qui va mener
cette cette équipe des chaises voilà
peut-être vers une victoire
ça va être beau
top
tel qu'il a 7 sur 8 et qu'il a raté ma
tendu dans la partie qui l'a perdu
Magnus Carlson
4 et les échecs là avec son
poids de tour de pions
il fait foie fin d'année et en
souffrance bon il va essayer de
contre-attaquer sur ce pion mais toute
façon déjà il peut quasiment plus gagner
c'est ça et donc ça fait déjà 8 points
peut-être quand même intéressant on a
tous le thème tour C3 qui attaque les
deux pions
c'est vrai qu'on a l'air de repeindre le
pion ici parce que sur surtout aussi se
protège le pion sur ces trois
attaque ici
comme quoi le puissance 4 même aux
échecs ça sert
donc comment on peut faire ton
4 je sais pas ok intéressant peut-être
non
et j'espère que ça m'arrange tout ça
mais je vois pas comment
ok peut-être c'est un moyen de s'en
sortir
il a réussi à trouver une petite
ressource il faut aller le chercher
maintenant c'est pas si facile une 07
pour programmerda une 30 pour danil de
beauf attention à pas avoir
la tour C8
je vois bien Antoine tout liquider
Prague et assurer la nul
il sait bien oui potentiellement
effectivement pour ces trois c'est 5 il
prend en B3 de bof
alors peut-être ça serait le début de la
remontée si double a gagné
il y a tellement de tellement de
conditions à réaliser tous les collègues
gagnent ouais c'est ça
on peut lâcher nul mais
bon
on va faire des 4 il est quand même
toujours ce pression peut-être
tu vois j'avais trop vite
trop vite enterrer notre ami Prague
est-ce que je peux faire pousser trois
là peut-être mais ces trois c'est assez
pour faire mieux
et bon final de tour très très équilibré
tous ces trois semble être pas mal pour
faire nul mais bon F4 seul coup pour
l'équipe mais il y a des quatre tu te
cahiers des 5
il y a pas de points lourd il y a rien
en jeu là donc
pourquoi pas faire F4 non
les deux les deux veulent jouer je pense
Prague il veut tout le temps jouer du
bof il a pas le choix vu les
circonstances de match
salut Hector 40 secondes salut à toi
Hector
40 secondes pour se décider et essayer
de faire en sorte qu'il se passe quelque
chose aux quatre fouet 3 on va enlever
le petit score là parce que ça te ça te
spoile t'aime pas ça toi
mais maintenant je prends en bas aussi
donc c'est pas facile et c'est bien
d'avoir les noms d'équipe
le score du match ouais bon on va pas
tout enlever quand même
et regarde il joue à fond hein Prague
puis on prend
et surpuis on prend ces trois je suppose
qu'il veut faire cavalier E4 et
attention aux fourchettes attention on
va récupérer le pion est toujours des
difficultés là pour Dany là la jauge je
vais pas d'accord
il veut gagner avec les Noirs mais il
prend des risques et peut-être c'est
capable de contrer ouais attention ah ça
sur ça il y a ça c'est ça ok attention
il y a un truc pour les blancs ici qui
donne un avantage qu'est-ce que c'est
cette tour B4 ça m'étonnerait quoi que
quoi que le pion avec le roi F2 aussi
c'est complètement ouais mais il a
complètement Prague là il a perdu le
sens du danger attention
ça peut jouer des tours ces choses là
ensuite on a les pions passées liés
encore mais il faut faire gaffe avec les
Noirs
F3 le roi arrive jusqu'en DK dans bonne
condition alors peut-être
tomber 3 et 2
et C4 salut chess 525 au plaisir de te
revoir sur un stream je serai modérateur
et c'est nul
et ton premier F3 jouer ton français 4
ça va faire nul et c'est le point qui
assure le départage mais le demi point
on va aller voir est-ce que Valentina
gounina nous fait un exploit là
peut-être peut-être en train de vous
faire un exploit
enfin tellement critiquer face à Pradesh
qui doit être là on va le mettre tout de
suite et manque de temps ça joue
et
peut-être enfin un point
mais il y a encore
corps du une conclusion à mettre en
place
comment on fait ici parce que la jauge
dit que ça c'est équilibre alors qu'on a
l'impression qu'on est au bord du
gouffre
j'ai pas fou prendre
6 Scipion prend il y avait F5 c'est tout
reprend il y avait dame prend tour et
surpuis on prend un F5
et sur intermédiaire en revenant fuite
c'était terminé
ça gagnait ah là là attention à pas
rater trop de chance ouh là là qu'est-ce
qu'elle a fait là elle s'est auto cloué
ou ça va pas du tout est Tour Eiffel
apparemment une énorme gaffe qui laisse
ce fou oh là là c'est pas sa journée à 4
tours F4 jouer qu'est-ce qui se passe
Katia fougères la petite combine
on a connu des meilleurs on va voir mais
apparemment c'est gaffe sur gaffe là
dans cette fin de fin de tournoi et on
voit les joueurs qui quittent le col
mais c'est pas bien de faire ça c'est
pas bien ne faites pas ça s'il vous
plaît non mais non non
mais c'est terminé on le voit on va
remettre les résultats yogis
et le roi blanc c'est un peu régulier on
va dire et il y a une huile de Sarine
aussi comme paraviane donc voilà le
match est plié 8 et demi si c'est demi
c'est la dernière partie en cours
j'enlève donc le live résultat
et le joueur indien comme d'hab il joue
pour jouer
là ça pourrait se terminer 8 et demi 7
et demi si Valentina venait à gagner
ce qu'on peut jouer ah oui la dame va
ressortir bientôt
Valentina va gagner je vois bien gagner
le gros plan est très faible maintenant
tu avances pas trop mon avis
c'est sûr ça va bien gagner tout à
l'heure j'aurais pas dit ça quand il
avait merdouillé et laisser la combine
sur son fou des 8 alors attends
[Musique]
nul
et là quoi F6 oh là c'est la pagaille oh
là là regarde dame
c'est terminé oh là là là là
en même temps
tu commences à pas être très sympa du
coup tu vois tu me disais des choses
mais finalement tu l'as lâché
donc ouais mais on le sentait venir
il y avait pas assez de contrôle elle
laissait trop de chance mais j'ai cru
j'ai cru un moment quand même elle aussi
je pense et c'est terrible
ça adversaire aussi certainement mais
bon
toutes les caméras avant la fin du match
vraiment là
c'est la désertion intégrale elle a
perdu un alors on regarde la fin de la
partie mais elle a perdu Valentina goina
on le sait mais bon avec une tour de moi
le roi dans les courants d'air ça se
termine normalement assez mal ce genre
d'histoire
c'est bon là
on peut tout primov pour ces deux et
d'un E2 bravo
donc c'était globalement très très
maîtrisé
ce premier match est terminé je fais un
petit rappel sur
pas les résultats mais le match qui nous
attend
quel est le match qui nous attend et
bien c'est le match des chessbra avec
Magnus Carlsen
champion du monde dans toutes les
disciplines rapid Blitz et classique
encore pour deux mois
face aux Gordon state Garden State
passers alors attention c'est du sérieux
des deux côtés des équipes qui ont
beaucoup de points on va faire peut-être
un petit rappel du classement avant que
tu t'en ailles à mon cher
mon cher Kevin on va regarder le si je
l'ai là et regardons voir donc ça y est
c'est pas c'est pas mis à jour là encore
mais ils ont trois victoires tandis que
le cheese wither donc simplement deux et
attention au chaise brun contre les
gants ça marche très important en fait
parce qu'ils ont une c'est comme pour
Blist stream demain Blitz demain
c'est un match décisif parce que ça te
met soit dans le bon côté du classement
soit dans le mauvais donc faut
absolument gagner
donc en tout cas ouais on voit que
l'équipe l'équipe des Indiens si les
Indian yugiz c'est du costaud vraiment
très complémentaire cette équipe avec
une jeune féminine qui peut battre
n'importe quel quel joueur de l'équipe
adverse donc c'est une grande chance de
l'avoir la sœur de Prague plus praxarine
voilà bon c'est clairement une super le
jeune là qu'on connaît pas il va falloir
pranach c'est c'est moi de toute façon
on sait bien qu'ils ont fait des équipes
pour gagner potentiellement
mais il se trouve que ça sort et quand
même assez extraordinaire donc il a pas
été hyper imaginatif notre ami Prague
mais bon ça suffit il peut faire jouer
bientôt il va faire équipe avec toute sa
famille bon
même son cousin doit pas mal jouer à
[Rires]
ben écoute mon cher Kevin c'était un
plaisir comme d'habitude on se retrouve
quand vendredi
et oui
à vendredi moi je vais faire une petite
pause petite pause musicale j'accueille
tout et c'est reparti c'est parti pour
pour le match de manus scarsen dans 5
minutes
tu fais un gros bisou virtuel à stouffe
de ma part parce qu'il m'a donné un
petit tuyau et c'était gentil à lui
comme d'habitude toujours bienveillant
toujours bienveillant d'accord mais on
se retrouve on se retrouve tout de suite
ok bah des bisous à tous et salut à très
bientôt Laurent avant vendredi et bon
match avec Magnus parce qu'on sent que
tu es comme un enfant là tu attends ça
avec impatience
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou non ouh là je suis revenu salut salut
à tous et rebonjour pour ce match désolé
j'étais surprise Stéphane pas de souci
désolé j'ai pas fait exprès j'ai voulu
faire en ligne et là j'ai fait j'ai fait
une petite
erreur de manip mais en tout cas on est
bien là salut comment tu vas ça va très
bien et toi je vais te changer je vais
te changer ton petit nom quand même
parce que
ça m'a plu
et tu étais breton surtout et ça c'est
pas si tu gagnes au changement
alors du coup aujourd'hui on a un petit
match très très sympathique
ouais un petit match avec un petit
champion du monde
donc on aura bien sûr les les Américains
Garden State pasters contre l'équipe du
champion du monde en titre plus pour
longtemps d'ailleurs
Canada Canada chessbra arrête de me
coeur mon cœur mon cœur saigne alors
stouf avec combien de de haut de U il y
a un seul O2
et un seul F c'est ça
ok donc on a ça on va avoir les joueurs
on va les avoir il faut que je me on va
voir les parties est-ce qu'ils ont
commencé parce que toi tu sais que tu es
beaucoup plus
tu m'aides beaucoup plus que en général
que notre ami
ok je regardais je pense pas qu'ils
aient commencé par contre je vais aller
récupérer le
fichier et le mettre
à jour
moi j'ai rien encore
c'est un truc que je sais normalement
que je fais depuis des années mais en
fait
quand j'estime pour la première fois
quand j'ai host pour la première fois
cet événement et ben je savais pas que
je devais faire moi-même le changement
de résultat
parce que c'est généralement en fait sur
técom et ben il y a plein de trucs qui
font eux-mêmes tu vois par exemple et du
coup je pensais que c'était de leur
faute donc pendant une ronde je me suis
plaint et que bah quand je suis allé
voir le stream des Américains j'ai vu
qu'ils avaient tout changé j'ai dit mais
attends pourquoi je suis mort ça marche
pas et en fait il faut avouer leur truc
leur fichiers
bon après mais c'est la première fois en
fait que c'est comme ça
et donc du coup ben je savais pas donc
j'étais un peu un peu à la ramasse la
première mais bon au final c'était bien
quoi
j'étais avec Fabien
et là on est voilà on voit la
composition donc tu dis comme tu disais
un petit match avec d'un côté l'équipe
emmené par Magnus évidemment i25 qui est
pas manchot non plus on se rappelle
qu'il est battu Magnus Carsen notamment
à olympiade en 2016 14 2014
c'était 2014 2014 et
ericansen évidemment très connu le
streamer canadien mais très bon joueur
aussi à plus de 2006
et sur Internet aussi vraiment
d'habitude des cadences rapides tout ça
donc c'est vraiment une équipe très
solide avec bien sûr en féminine une
joueuse à 2200 hello donc
mélijade Wallet que je connais pas moi
très honnêtement non plus je la connais
pas du tout 2200 hello j'ai vu et chez
américain bah ils ont donc ça c'est un
match intéressant parce que la féminine
elle est censée qu'elle est plus forte
des Américains que chez les Canadiens
mais au milieu ben ok on a quand même
carton et puis après quand même bah il
faut voir en fait si le petit GM michera
bah tiens la route parce que je vous
rappelle que c'est le plus jeune
grand-mère de tous les temps il a
maintenant 13 ans
2560 à peu près donc c'est une machine
mais il est encore jeune donc qu'est-ce
qui donne sur internet ça c'est encore
une fois autre chose contre un ça risque
enfin 45 ça va être le test
dur donc on voit car il saillie à
l'écran et Magnus Carlson et donc ça
c'est la magie aussi de cette projet de
ligue c'est que caressaie va avoir le
l'honneur le privilège d'affronter une
partie de 10 minutes alors c'est
toujours très vite contre Goliath bon
ben dans la vraie vie en général Goliat
gagne mais
mais on a vu Joséphine a une nomade on
était tous les deux d'ailleurs je crois
c'est ça battre Nakamura donc pourquoi
pas attention Magnus qui rigole sur son
téléphone car ouais un petit snap là
avant de avoir de commencer bon ben il
faut qu'il se méfie quand même peut-être
que peut-être qu'il va mourir dans une
vingtaine de minutes a priori il va
toujours rire il sera toujours de bonne
humeur mais il faut pas vendre la peau
de l'ours
voilà c'est jamais ce qui peut passer
une partie d'échec à côté pas énorme
mais bon c'est une partie les sur une
partie parce que quand même plein de
choses online online toujours pareil
avec ce truc là on voit derrière il est
chez lui Magnus voilà bon c'est pas trop
comment sa journée s'est passée
donc voilà il peut il peut évidemment
lâcher on rappelle quand même que il
assure dans cette prochaine cycle il y a
7 sur 8 il a raté un matin 3 contre
vidite c'était assez incroyable un fou
projet 7 8 damage 7 vous pouvez si vous
êtes sur Twitter vous pouvez le
retrouver assez facilement sur les
réseaux sociaux mais quand même 7 sur 8
donc il mène cette équipe mais attention
c'est ce que je disais à Kévin
match de la peur pourquoi match de la
peur parce que ils ont une victoire une
défaite et donc en fait tu bascules
c'est une bascule où on sait que les 8
premiers sur les 16 vont se qualifier
et donc si tu gagnes tu bascules dans le
camp des vainqueurs un petit peu et si
tu perds tu es dans le camp de la peur
c'est à dire que tu peux te faire sortir
au prochain match donc faut faire faut
faire très attention comme d'ailleurs
demain Blist stream sera dans la même
situation avec cette une victoire une
défaite et là le troisième match est
capital mais en fait un petit sur deux
là dans la configuration de de du coup
de Carlsen c'est lequel je suis
quasiment automatiquement non du coup
comment ça pour les
si il gagne un match aujourd'hui quoi
ouais ouais c'est ça ouais ouais après
il reste je crois je crois qu'il y a
cinq semaines de calife
non là il y a déjà des illuminations je
vais faire descendre le classement et
Charlotte Cobra 0 sur 3 tu es éliminé
voilà donc ceux qui vont peut-être qu'il
y a une autre équipe qui va avoir je
pense que berline billard ce qu'on va
jouer contre Saint Louis
encore à zéro sur 3 et voilà donc les
illuminations se font petit à petit à
les équipes du bas de classement je
trouve que la formule est quand même pas
mal parce que ça évite
ouvert le bas donc voilà ça évite que ça
soit un calvaire et que tu joues
finalement en étant sûr de pas être dans
les 8 premiers au final donc c'est assez
sympa comme alors je sais pas exactement
le détail je crois qu'après 3 semaines
est-ce qu'on a mis deux ou trois
peut-être deux peut-être simplement deux
ce que les deux équipes qui ont perdu
leurs trois matchs en tout cas c'est
assez bien vu là pour le coup que ça
soit un truc un peu un peu dynamique
parce que c'est vrai que si les équipes
n'en finissent plus de perdre bon ben au
bout d'un moment c'est la 100 pour pour
ceux qui perdent et pour ceux qui
regardent donc
[Musique]
effectivement tu vois pas de partie tu
me tu me le confirmes on est d'accord
après lui ça veut rien dire parce que
lui il est capable de jouer comme ça
ouais mais normalement il a pas droit au
téléphone il a pas au téléphone quand
même
au dessus de tout soupçon bon là le
téléphone c'est quand même c'est quand
même un peu tout moche
donc on va voir il a fait regarde il est
clairement chargé enfin bon bref c'est
la c'est toujours pareil on est chez soi
il y a les caméras il y a un système
anti-triche qui est très très au point
donc ne vous inquiétez pas les parties
sont sont très faibles ça se voit ça se
voit
ne vous fais ça se voit il se il se
repère facilement
ceux qui triche donc là il y a vraiment
pas c'est une compétition très fair-play
etche.com a pas de
ils ont pas de pitié entre guillemets
pour pour les gens ils sont bannes comme
un peu toutes les plateformes parce que
de toute façon il faut faire quelque
chose donc il faut bannir les gens pour
après
justement par rapport à ça je crois
qu'ils sont assez assez cool ça veut
dire que quand tu es ban il te laisse
une chance de revenir si tu admets
je sais pas comment ça se passe
ok c'est ça voilà bon
tu n'as pas de deuxième chance donc
voilà bon après c'est la politique
chacun
est libre il faut quand même
une entreprise privée donc à partir de
ce moment-là faut comprendre c'est comme
dans un restaurant si votre tête revient
pas à au restaurateurs et bien il vous
met dehors il a c'est son droit parce
qu'il est chez lui donc ça il faut le ça
il faut l'intégrer quand même
après bien sûr normalement tu vois avec
tout ce qu'ils ont
enfin tous les les
je sais pas comment ça s'appelle c'est
[Musique]
ok moi j'ai vu beaucoup de gens sont mes
streams aussi me disent tiens je m'étais
banal je sais pas pourquoi bah en fait
ok
ils vont je pense pas que tu vas te
faire ban pour rien tu vois normalement
j'avais même vu un truc je crois que
c'était quoi c'était j'avais bon je
crois que c'était le moment de de la
faire Limane tu vois donc on va pas
reparler mais juste ça et il disait en
fait que
IBAN que si vraiment ils sont mes 1000%
sur tu vois j'ai eu alors j'ai eu la
chance avec chaise 24 d'avoir accès à ce
à ce logiciel anti triche pour vérifier
quelques cas il me demandait de aussi
parce que quand les gens comme tu l'as
dit la personne qui vient se plaindre
qui écrit bon ben on a envie quand même
de regarder et de voir comment ça marche
et c'est quand même c'est quand même
très très bien fait hein ça tient compte
de tout donc évidemment le grand public
n'y a pas accès mais je vous garantis
que
c'est pas c'est une chance sur 100 000
d'être quand on se fait ban de d'être de
pas avoir triché quoi donc effectivement
même plus que 100000 d'ailleurs oui
peut-être parce qu'en fait après ça
dépend même du niveau parce que bon à la
limite tu vois encore une fois sur une
partie tu peux passer une préparation et
tu as d'ouverture que tu connais et puis
bah moi ça m'a déjà arrivé ça m'est déjà
arrivé de faire
99,9% sur 30 coups parce que je
connaissais la prépa jusqu'au bout et
voilà mais mais bon c'est une partie
donc en fait c'est une partie
mais tu es pas Gasparo enfin niveau des
prépas excuse-moi mais tu peux pas faire
ça c'est impossible
à l'instant
sur les caméras comme ça il m'aime pas
là donc en fait du coup
[Musique]
il est pas là donc non mais ça va
marcher léger retard à l'allumage mais
en même temps c'est pas on prend la
température du truc ouais c'est un chêne
avec le match d'avant donc du coup bon
ça permet de faire une petite pause
reparaisser le joueur là mais tout ça
d'ailleurs tu tu as changé les noms des
joueurs là je vois qu'il marque un
crocooning peut-être que parce que c'est
la partie
c'est comme ça que tu faisais ah
d'accord en fait ok toi tu passes par
le lien tu suis les joueurs en ligne en
direct
je comprends ok parce que moi quand je
osté j'allais dans l'événement si tu
veux et du coup il fallait toujours que
je mette à la main dedans en fait j'ai
remarqué que c'était pas c'était pas
c'est un peu moins visible que le truc
en blanc la belle écriture blanche mais
c'est quand même pas mal ça envoie on
reconnaît
en fait moi je me fais chier
après tu fais trop de
ouais tu fais trop de ouais non ça fait
trop de choses à gérer en fait moi c'est
ce que j'ai j'ai considéré tu sais c'est
la technique du feignant
le plus simple et le mieux en fait donc
ça évite
on va regarder parce qu'on a qu'à
essayer donc tu vois j'ai les noms des
on va évidemment remettre sur Magnus
Carlson on espère moins de j'ai beaucoup
de problèmes de de déconnexion au
premier match je me l'envoie Maxus ouais
ouais parce que les joueurs ils avaient
une connexion pas stable du tout
donc là je mets et comme ça en fait on
voit on va faire un petit tour donc ça
c'est michera
et on voit on voit tous les joueurs là
il est passé à 12 ans en grand maître
pendant le covid en fait il a fait
tournoi
en Hongrie il s'est fait un peu tombé
dessus c'est vrai mais bon en fait ok tu
vois le débat est intéressant ouais tu
as commencé ça a commencé ou depuis un
moment déjà non ouais
il y a un petit débat du fait que oui il
est passé grand maître en achetant plein
de tournoi fait un mec etc il manquait
une norme ou deux je crois et du coup
les pommiers il a fait un gros en gros
[Musique]
tweet comme quoi ouais ben il faut faire
elle était fin en fait nulle part et des
cris qu'il faut faire des des normes de
tu vois etc de bref mais bon il faut
dire quand même que michera il a fait
quasiment un an sans jouer pendant le
covid et du coup en fait tu vois tu peux
te plaindre du fait que leur chaîne est
de l'État fermé pour faire ce norme pour
gagner en fait ce titre quoi le titre de
le mettre du remettre le plus jeune mais
dans l'autre côté c'est pendant un an il
a pas joué à cause des covid bah il a
perdu aussi du temps tu vois donc en
fait au final c'est pas ce qui serait
passé s'il avait pu jouer
donc c'est vrai que c'est compliqué donc
on va tous les cas
bon il joue bien il a montré il a joué
le droit avec un score très honorable
donc il mérite largement son titre de
grand-mère après
donc on a une installienne sur une
partie qui est très déséquilibrée en
tout cas sur le papier ouh là là j'ai 4
ouh ça disons on arrive à juger 4 c'est
osé c'est osé j'aurais plutôt favoriser
un truc comme les trois PC
doit connaître c'est c'est avec les
Blancs
donc une est indienne avec F3
say mich ou en fait il a balancé qu'il
voyage 5 F4 pour donner il a donné un
pion pour ouvrir les cases noires
même si le pion vous voyez même si le
pion F4 on le perd un jour
et c'est c'est très très dur voilà donc
en fait c'est pas jouer G4 là c'est pas
une bonne idée parce que de toute façon
j'allais venir en F4
donc là j'ai l'impression déjà les noirs
sont très très bien
[Musique]
jade toutes nos excuses si on
si on prononce mal mais là ça sent déjà
bon pour Sam c'est bien
mais allons voir allons voir Magnus
Carson donc avec les Blancs
le triple champion du monde qui joue
avec les Blancs face
à Carissa
pendant pendant bah il va paraître ici
il est partout
et les Noirs
arrive et donc il a les Noirs contre
kaarisa alors il y a un petit problème
de temps là c'est pas possible qu'elle
est 8 minutes il s'est passé un truc
ouais ça c'est bizarre ou alors qu'elle
a réfléchi au noir je sais pas parce que
là réfléchir
d'être là en plus donc toujours manuelle
normalement tu fais soyez un gros bug
je sais pas ce que je ferais quoi ça
serait pas en première réflexe n'a
jamais été
je suis arrivé jamais en retard
un tournoi Arena avec des prix là sur
les pièces
[Musique]
[Rires]
il fait n'importe quoi à droite à gauche
en fait son truc maintenant le truc
c'est vraiment faire n'importe quoi dans
les et en fait il fait quasiment c'est
la muse plus d'être perdant pour voir ma
tête à la fin
je me fais arnaquer et qui m'a placé il
va placer un truc et c'est presque alors
je sais pas si c'est complètement
conscient ou pas mais souvent il fait
n'importe quoi dans début milieu de jeu
et je suis souvent complètement gagnant
et c'est là où la partie commence pour
lui et donc du coup de me planter comme
ça ça me fait toujours un peu mal quand
même
bon
quand même de pouvoir faire toujours
avec toi comme ça
encore il y a quelques années je m'en
sortais plus ouf plus ou moins on est là
là je me fais voir enrouler dessus de A
à Z donc il y a plus trop de parties
comme ça
donc
H3 rockfo 3 bon écoute elle sort ses
pièces il va prendre la paire de fou
Magnus mais ça paraît tout à fait
raisonnable tout ça pour tout le monde
je trouve que c'est intéressant en tout
cas elle a une position où elle a son
petit schéma d'attaque ouais c'est ça et
un truc comme ça peut-être un coup de
attention B4 Magnus le capteur beef
on va être obligé d'aller là cavaler A4
la chose qui fait un peu peur
je suppose quoi d'autre
et c'est jouer et puis on prend en fait
son idée c'est de jouer avec des seins
que je suppose et de stabiliser ce
centre
elle a joué cavalier prend et il va
jouer
des seins
et je vais faire cavalier 8 5 jouer qui
avait le 8 joué par Magnus on va revenir
par là qui a été cette donnée trop de
jeux à mon avis qui a eu des 7 attention
hein attention pas sûr parce qu'on peut
revenir encore mais
on va pas trop où il va donc 8 au moins
on a un plan assez clair soit qui essaie
cette cavalue aussi soit G6 et G7 qui
est aussi possible peut-être avec
l'option de venir F5 on sait pas
on se garde on se garde les options
intéressantes en tout cas peut-être là
peut-être du coup on peut imaginer il y
a aussi un petit pion à cette emprise
faut il faut il faut en parler ça serait
masquant
je pense que ça marchera pas du tout
fait par la police
par la police aussi
D4 c'était quand même c'est un truc à
envisager parce qu'après tout c'est pas
le plus beau des pions mais ça reste un
pion
[Musique]
trop de respect pour Magnus F6 c'est sûr
je pense que c'est un bon coup pratique
de rapidement décider de pas prendre de
pion parce que oui
il y a des faiblesses quand même sur
case noir alors effectivement il y a un
foodcesse blanche qui peut rayonner par
là mais ça reste tout à fait acceptable
fois 6 dans le clouage on va jouer KF3
je suppose avec les Blancs c'est quand
même et là tu vois du cavalier
c'est un jeu de bouffe tout alors
en fait
et on gagne si on faisait ça je sais pas
bon parce qu'en fait on reprend et on
reprend et on a fait de plus mais là on
s'arrête en chemin
donc elle est pas tombée dans ce piège
et elle a joué dame G4
j'aime beaucoup ce qu'elle fait car il
ça
[Musique]
tu as quand même une très très belle
blocade
tu as pas très envie de prendre F6 parce
que ça va remettre un fou par là et ça
va faire que tu as faiblesse en D4 elle
va se voir beaucoup plus
donc grosse décision là pour ça la Tour
Eiffel que le
F5 ça fait mal F50
qui arrive peut-être il aurait fallu
essayer de
pas c'était pas évident mais elle joue
un peu vite mais remarques mais la
pression autant aussi il met pas que là
il joue pas il joue des bons coups vite
cavalier F3
voilà
petit problème tactique quoi que c'est
pas sûr
et on va voir et chaque intermédiaire et
on ramasse une pièce et sur on doit
garder le contact évidemment avec ce fou
on a deux cases pour le faire soit c'est
la sauce là ici on fait l'autre hop
et hop
ok donc sur le papier ouais faut
toujours faire attention aux idées
stratégiques il faut un plan mais même
même un truc comme ça il me semblait que
les Noirs étaient mieux quand même mais
changer les deux pièces mineures
on va voir ce qui se passe en tout cas
il fait G5 sans complexes bon
c'est vrai qu'il est bien il est bien
sur le roi alors peut-être un petit coup
droit ensuite
des fois tu peux arriver on a un petit
problème sur A5 pour l'instant mais
on sent que ça va pas être si gros
problème ça à gérer je crois qu'ici il
faut quand même essayer de créer du
contre-jour rapidement et je vous donne
ces deux heures ouais pour essayer au
moins d'occuper la dame et la tour à la
protection du pion C6
on reste sur celle-là non c'est comme
sympa de voir
un petit peu comment comment Carson bat
les joueurs on va dire de mon niveau
thoraciste Tour Eiffel et H5 c'est parce
que tu vois
champion du monde et puis 2370 c'est
quand même encore amateur
et c'est intéressant de voir un peu
comment tu vois c'est un peu du speedrun
quoi là c'est c'est pédagogique ouais
bien sûr bien sûr de voir effectivement
et ouais c'est très sympa de voir ce
genre de partie surtout quand c'est des
jeunes joueuses prometteuses comme comme
kaaris Saïd qui a été je crois que je
sais pas il faut me corriger mais j'ai
été champion des États-Unis il me semble
[Musique]
joueur joueur joueuse pardon joyeuse
amatrice peut-être mais elle a peut-être
gagné
même chez les chez les joueuses c'est du
vin en 30000 dollars donc c'est possible
qu'elle a gagné
c'est sympa quoi c'est possible qu'elle
a gagné 30000 dollars en 10 jours tu
vois donc
ça donne des idées d'ailleurs de pas
rester complètement amateur
donc dame 2 jouer par Carissa mais c'est
dur 3 8
et on va commencer à avoir peut-être une
tour G7
canards attention cavalier H2 il va
jauger G4S
ou pas est-ce qu'elle marche ou pas
c'est toujours il faut toujours vérifier
tout ça je crois que ça va ou pas
elle veut elle propose un manuel de
s'affaiblir un petit peu sur G4 on va on
va venir là et maintenant finalement on
a quand même une belle case pour le fou
c'est un peu embêtant
c'est un truc que Magnus qui qu'il dit
souvent dans les interviews d'ailleurs
il n'aime pas donner du contre-jeu à son
adversaire c'est quelque chose qui
vraiment il est content quand son
adversaire a pas de contre jeu donc
c'est un truc qui va il va même pas
regarder en fait ce G4 parce que le fou
qui peut arriver là-bas en partie rapide
je suis à peu près certain qu'il
envisagent deux secondes et pas plus
prise
c'est jouer prises
j'ai
trois caractéristiques
tu triches là
à la maison mais là ça prend pas là
F3 et tout ça
a pris pendant deux secondes mais le
truc c'est que quand j'aurais été obligé
de quand j'aurais voulu bouger la pièce
j'aurais eu un problème c'est l'avantage
des ordinateurs alors elle fait pas du
tout ça sur pion prend G4 elle joue elle
se laisse pas faire car il fait aussi
intermédiaire surpuis on prend un F3 est
terminé il y a plus on prend F7
intermédiaire donc
elle veut une belle case
mais pas sûr parce qu'il y a peut-être
G3 ah j'ai trois fous prends G3 regarde
moi ça attend des pièges attention
ça pose quelques petits soucis
un peu regarde ce qui a été joué très
rapidement rend la petite finale par
Magnus dame G4
et le cavalier bloqueur qui va être
magnifique et cette majorité de pions
qui devrait faire le reste des quatre
d'abord et regarder ce fou il met les
pions sur la couleur du fou pour le
restreindre c'est aussi une stratégie
bien connue il va jouer C5 là
il va peut-être même peut-être faire
tour à 7 à 4 il y a plein de plans ici
pour les Noirs peut-être améliorer AA
améliorer le roi d'abord
quand j'ai 4 peut-être
un coup droit G6 puis après il va voir
fuite
reviens là-bas
il y a pas ça
tu sais quoi il y a plus beaucoup de
pions quand même faut faire attention
peut-être en dans alors en danger pas de
perles mais en danger de pas convertir
pour prendre le 5 jouets j'aime pas du
tout faut prendre des 4
la partie
alors attends on va scruter comme la
ration de Magnus qui pour l'instant
il a l'air d'être OK
mais
[Musique]
qui peut être une idée
trop baby trop B3
mais bon
faut prendre F4 je
commence à manger tous les pions
c'est très c'est équilibré donc on fait
quoi la tour B8 F4
et en fait
tout et il y a plus beaucoup de pièces
sur cavalier prend F4 ah mais ça
marchera pas non je le montre un truc
qui marche pas je peux pas je peux pas
si j'ai envie de gagner il faut que je
sais même plus loin des 4 encore une
fois parce que montrer qu'il y a des
cloches partout mais il y a toujours
trouvé en fait
oui mais de toute façon je pensais
prendre ce pion en fait pour me créer et
c'est vrai que oui je vois ce que tu
veux dire pour ton principe mais là il y
a le petit coin intermédiaire mais c'est
vrai que tu as raison en fait il y a des
thèmes tactiques de partout et
d'ailleurs ils sont pris une tactique et
tomber 8 jouer par manus Carlson en même
temps quoi d'autre fout des deux je vais
par Carrie ça et tu reprends mes trois
arrivent
et maintenant et elle joue pas mal moi
je trouve qu'elle joue bien franchement
net elle fait très très grosse partie là
car ici c'est très impressionnant ce
qu'elle nous montre
ici ouais F4 il faut se débarrasser des
pions alors mon avis on est obligé de
garder le déséquilibre matériel mais du
coup je vais où parce que tu as tout F5
moi j'aime bien
contre-attaquer toujours pensez-y avec
quoi intermédiaire très très important
et sur wave 7 déjà on peut coller encore
un échec et dire Magnus tu vas où là
maintenant tu fais quoi maintenant
et tu fais quoi Magnus il sait pas ce
qu'il fait Magnus là à mon avis
sur quoi
elle est mal au temps ouais mais c'est
vrai que regarder Sam c'est bien abattu
la joueuse du Canada
ericansa a perdu contre nick qui est
aussi un expert online on n'a pas parlé
mais très très fort donc attention
victoire de manuscrit impérative parce
que là il pourrait prendre un gros coup
de massue non seulement ils perdent le
match mais leur héros leur champion
gagne pas c'est comme être mené et
Mbappé Mbappé qui est sur le banc là
c'est c'est à peu près ça donc faut
absolument que Magnus gagne pour le
moral des troupes
après
le pion lié les pions liés et puis on
des sont assez dangereux
j'ai peur qu'avec les blancs contre
Magnus je me dis aïe aïe
le gros problème
erreur tu fais c'est je pense que tu
dois faire ces quatre non je fais tout
au 5 j'ai pas tout reprendre je
m'asstoure F6 bon là je n'aime pas du
tout ce que j'ai fait tu vois j'ai la
perdre avec moi
non mais sur C4 peut-être je peux
m'activer aussi je peux faire ça et être
plus menaçant attention attention
c'est chaud maintenant
c'est chaud pour tout le monde et ce roi
finalement a l'air il a pas il a aucune
case aucune case légale mais c'est dur
de le mettre échec il faudrait imaginer
un cavalier là mais ça paraît
difficilement imaginable ces quatre
jouets par manus scarsen qui d'après la
joue était une gaffe tout F5 a l'air
très normal et menace au minimum
perpétuel
voilà est-ce que tout ça va être trouvé
une ambiance autour de toi en fait tu
peux te faire mater rapidement
comment est-ce qu'on peut jouer du coup
là à toi 5 toujours moi je milite pour
ton F5 à fond tu mets à ses perpète en
plus Magnus risque de faire des folies
pour pas faire nul donc c'est très très
bien de menacer à perpète
de faire un perfect je suis pratiquant
dès que je peux menacer de faire un
perpète je te garantis que je fais parce
que je sais qu'il va me faire un truc
incroyable pour pas faire nul donc
et toi si joué
bon écoute mais tu vois un scénario
comme ça c'est là où on voit que il
manque des pions même admettons je joue
le coup le plus bête de la terre mais
voilà ça ça doit être nul c'est pas sûr
en fait
personne
reprend et il a transformé dans cette
finale ouh là là
le roi qui avance
c'est bien joué ce qu'il a fait encore
alors à tes tours
j'ai quatre jouets le bas et je
craquement sa chance 5 mais là
maintenant ça ça
va sur échec prise tu manges ces quatre
à la fin
[Musique]
ça va pas tenir
on sent un truc comme ça
on sent que bon
il rigole
et D3 menaces des deux il rigolez-moi et
surtout des six il y a tout reprend je
pense
et je prends D6 avec avec le roi
donc là il fait son petit sourire du bah
ouais j'ai gagné mais j'étais pas très
brillant
je pense que oui oui ça arrive trop vite
pour prendre mes deux va être joué par
Magnus Carsen qui va l'emporter mais
alors sur froide cahier des 4 ok
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal c'est précis il est précis ce jeune
homme
voilà c'est fini du coup on va avoir on
va avoir une victoire du coup de Carlsen
et on voit qu'il va s'arridge qui a fait
nul contre contre michera
du coup on a deux et demi à 1 et demi
pour les passeurs donc l'équipe
américaine avec du coup les victoires
des deux premiers chéquiers donc ça me
sévient et portnic
et du coup ça risque qu'il y a pas à
gagner la partie donc du coup ça les met
un petit peu dedans pour le stand dans
ce match avec deux et demi 1 et demi
mais bon c'est pas encore du tout
terminé ça commence et ils ont quand
même Magnus qui
ah frôlé frôlé la nul contre kaarisae ce
qui aurait ça ça aurait fait ça aurait
été alors sur le plan comptable si
jamais une bonne affaire c'est mieux de
gagner que de faire nul mais pour le
moral aussi ça aurait été dur
donc c'est quand même très très
important qu'il est qu'il ait gagné on
va faire un petit
un petit rappel du format si tu le veux
bien
Stéphane avec non on va pas passer au
taie on va passer au format d'abord 10 +
2 les compositions d'équipe ne peuvent
pas dépasser une moyenne et l'eau à 2550
ça sachant que les joueurs sont capés à
2350 c'est-à-dire que une joueuse a
comme Wii fan 2680 contré comme une
joueuse à 230050 la moyenneo donc ça
favorise la participation des meilleurs
hello et sachant que les
d'un compétition enfin dans les
chez les hommes le Lohé capé à 2700
c'est à dire qu'avoir un 2702 ou Magnus
Carlsen ça revient au même ça compte à
2700 donc c'est pour encore une fois
favoriser la participation des meilleurs
joueurs
chaque joueur à fond tous les joueurs
d'équipe adverse pour total de 4 ans la
première équipe a 8 et demi remporte le
match en cas d'égalité des partages
détermine l'équipe gagnante et en fait
on a déjà vu ici
bah du coup on rejoue la même ronde
couleur inversée en 3 + 2
et 6 matchs nul et ben on passe en 1 + 2
et on change les couleurs à chaque fois
et dès que il y a un match qui a gagné
du coup pour une équipe et Ben qui prend
portera du coup le match et ça se
termine quand sinon
si personne ne gagne
qui va gagner
jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à épuisement
épuisement des forces
elle a perdu sur sur le coup qu'elle a
raté car il ça surtout F5 elle a raté on
va regarder
jusque là on va on va regarder je vais
mettre un petit coup de jauge elle a
très très bien joué d'après la jauge en
tout cas des deux tours en V3 là je mets
égale courage de tour reprend des trois
et là vous décis un coup parmi les
autres la foule 5 avantages blanche
avantage blanc sur faux 5 menaces en
tour F6 est avaient raison c'était la
bonne idée
sur ça sur moi j'ai 5 à fou prendre des
quatre échecs il était à -1 il est le
meilleur coup étant roi G5 le deuxième
meilleur coup le troisième meilleur coup
est un tour en 5 et le deuxième meilleur
coup étant kg7 alors je raconte pas
c'est moins 3 tours F7 on est dans le
clouage on est dans le pétrin donc
Magnus Carlson était perdant dans cette
partie en tout cas en grosse difficulté
après il a ce qu'il aurait probablement
trouvé roi G5 mais après ça bon il y a
plus aucune chance de gagner ça c'est
sûr faut cinq étages très fort le coup
que je conseiller était pas bon était
pas bon donner un petit légère avantage
noir en fait ok
après tout recadre 60
et donc ce qu'elle a fait fou B4
et la foubecca thoraciste très mauvaise
très mauvaise combinaison à cause de ce
truc et en fait c'est vrai que le roi
maintenant est éloigné c'est gagné en
maintenant pour minuscarsen oh
ça n'a rien fait du coup elle a laissé
vraiment ma nulle revenir dans la partie
et améliorer les pièces
c'est vraiment pas loin et en tout cas
très très belle partie
donc je suppose ça va être comment ça va
être Magnus qui va jouer contre micherin
contre michera et voilà on aura tout de
suite je pense qu'on va commencer par
cette partie clairement parce que
c'est le choc entre le plus jeune grand
maître au monde et bah le l'homme qui
domine les échecs depuis 10 ans
maintenant
en fait il a fait quand même
mondial depuis alors je sais pas j'ai
regardé ça il y a pas longtemps depuis
2011 je crois sans interruption il a
même fait une incursion en 2008
déjà déjà il a été numéro un mondial
pendant une partie entre entre deux
rondes quoi voilà un soir disons en 2008
et après c'est revenu en 2010 je crois
mais c'était plus intermittent un 2011
il a plu haché donc je crois que ça fait
12 ans sans interruption et il a quand
même pas mal d'avance faut avouer que
c'est je crois le seul joueur en ce
moment avoir plus de 2008 et il a 2850
je crois hein chose comme ça ça a été
quasiment à 60 je pense il a perdu un
petit peu mais en tout cas c'est ce
qu'il dit tant que je suis à plus de
parce que parfois il est marrant il fait
des trucs comme ça il te dit des trucs
tant que tant que je suis à plus de 2850
ça va
de moins de 2850 ça lui plaît moins
ouais 2852 et il y a des poméchi mais
785 qui est d'orf contre Ding Irène qui
a 2788 et numéro 4 mondial notre ami
notre frère le fashionista allez Reza
2785 allez hasard revient s'il te plaît
on veut voir tu es parti
arrête
il est là il est là
pas de problème et donc
à ce niveau-là
un joueur à 2750 je sais pas tu bois tu
vas numéro 10 quoi ben tu gagnes quoi
c'est ça
et donc en fait quand tu perds donc je
te raconte pas mais
enfin pour monter les points enfin c'est
juste c'est une torture qu'en fait si il
fait il fait un gain et de nulle ben il
perdait pas quoi
ouais bien sûr
non non il gagne encore
[Musique]
oui non c'est un gros problème
évidemment évidemment que surtout quand
il joue des joueurs qui avec les blancs
sont pas très ambitieux bon faut essayer
de faire en sorte ce qui se passe
quelque chose mais pas trop non plus
parce que quand même le mec est pas
moins chaud
c'est toujours hyper compliqué ouais
donc et c'est incroyable de rester à ce
niveau là pendant aussi longtemps avec
une incurs il y a 2881 je crois bon et
de 1900 je crois que même lui il croit
plus
il a même eu 89 virtuel
mais c'est compliqué de garder
c'est trop dur aussi infernal on
rappelle demain tu seras avec moi
là je suis avec toi
on a d'abord 16h30
on prend l'antenne évidemment avant les
Gotham Knights avec
Ikao Nakamura évidemment qui seront
favoris de leur match face au face au
chinois
qui sont bons qui ont battu l'équipe
c'est les Chinois ou pas
tu m'arrêtes si je raconte n'importe
quoi
évidemment donc pas ça sera pas diffusé
sur cheesecco FR mais ce sera diffusé
sur la chaîne Blist stream
avec Kevin Bordy qui commencera tout ça
Sacha greatchouk Maxime va chez Lagrave
mais elle Boyer et d'alimenter delté
tandis que nous on aura le bonheur de
voir peut-être le meilleur joueur online
de tous les temps
yes
un petit match Gotham night contre les
contre les bras ça pourrait avoir
c'est le gros derby le gros derby
alors ça va commencer Viane
les deux sont
ouais mes cheveux 4 en fait j'ai déjà
joué ouais
mais bon
ça joue quoi enfin bon kb6 c'est tout à
fait oui justement pour empêcher cette
poussée cette poussée des quatre et donc
on va mais ça donne B3 effectivement ça
donne B3 je vais essayer d'aller
récupérer notre ami
à l'époque où je travaillais les échecs
j'avais je sens un petit peu avec les
Blancs
exactement ce que je joue ici
[Musique]
c'est viande et l'idée en fait il y
avait une idée intéressante c'était que
là il joue par exemple
B2 petit rock ah bah attends il y a le
pion
D3
rock et des deux
[Musique]
attends excuse-moi ça a été coupé parce
que non seulement j'ai des j'ai des
nouveaux écouteurs mais qui se
déchargent rapidement donc je remets
l'autre
est-ce qu'on t'entend vas-y
merci je t'entends plus
ça c'est beau
c'est bon normalement tu as dû revenir
ok ouais c'est bon c'est bon vas-y
pardon je suis désolé pas de souci
et du coup
A3 à 5 d'un C2
et là sur Dame des 7 il y avait une
ligne marrante c'était E3
et surtout des 8
qui doit être logique et ben tu fais tes
cartes
et champion
et j'avais vu des parties comme ça et
c'était hyper intéressant en fait pour
les cases en fait tu peux pas trop pas
ouais tu joues pour les cases blanches
d'accord c'était très intéressant cette
ligne bon ça je l'avais réussi à le
jouer d'ailleurs aux filles à la peine
de Cannes j'avais joué un grand maître à
quasiment 2006 et j'avais fait nul je
l'avais changé mes deux fous contre ces
deux cavaliers
et j'avais obtenu une excellente
position j'avais fait nul
très très brillamment avec deux plus
c'est la technique légendaire mais
mais c'est intéressant c'était des meufs
je connais pas du tout bon mais ça
annonce une partie
[Musique]
où ça va chauffer
allez on va voir on nous dit dans le
chat que ça a commencé entre Magnus
Carlsen et le plus jeune grand maître au
monde celui qui a battu le record on va
tout de suite évidemment récupérer la
caméra de Magnus qu'on va voir à l'écran
face à michera alors j'ai peur je vais
te laisser prononcer son nom
habits
je l'ai lu comme ça je me trompe
peut-être en tout cas si c'est pas comme
ça je suis désolé donc c'est une ça
c'est c'est très étonnant
normalement joue ça et on retourne à
panoff
tu peux jouer comme ça ouais
tu peux manger deux fois non on peut
même manger de fois effectivement
tu penses qu'il a mis ce clic
bizarre et là ça donne un peu une
variante d'échange de la français sans
les pions c'est
est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça change
ça a l'air complètement ok en plus
françaises pas vraiment parce qu'on va
exactement c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs
sur le foot rapidement
des quatre six
et 3 OK
en échange ce fou et c'est vrai qu'en
général on va plutôt on va essayer de
créer une attaque quelque chose à le roi
en juin F4 assez rapidement
petit rock F4 quelque chose comme ça on
a l'avantage d'espace intéressant en
tout cas il joue une petite liste
pour les Noirs d'avoir changé ce mauvais
fou aussitôt dans sa structure
donc c'est le française avec le foot
sorti normalement oui normalement c'est
Amandine mais c'est vrai qu'en contrôle
moins la case F5 il y a pas que des bons
il y a pas que des avantages
mais normalement c'est plutôt un bon
digne quand même
raisonnable pour les Noirs ils vont
jouer qui est ici je suppose
Magnus va faire cavalier 2 tel que je le
connais
une prise et un cavalier quelque part
c'est ça on est obligé de prendre avant
de pouvoir se développer
pas évident pour Michelin parce qu'elle
est pas facile à jouer du tout cette
position je trouve
pas simple c'est pas trop mettre tes
pièces tu as pas envie de prendre mais
d'un autre côté comment tu fais pour
sortir le cavalier
donc il joue qu'add 7 ça j'aime pas du
tout je vois pas il faudra qu'il nous
explique à quoi sert pour jouer F6 mais
si ok non
non monsieur
ouais
c'est structures on voit c'est ça il
fait pas pression sur le pion des 4
attention
je te conseille quand même de bouger le
cavalier
il faut le bouger ce cavalier
d'une manière un peu gênante pour tout
le monde
un petit matelas
donc puis on prend on va être joué je
suppose à moins qu'il intercal un petit
coup de Massac non et là c'est vrai
qu'on aurait pu imaginer quelque chose
comme fouf 4 et pour faire le 6 mais il
y a dans un sac échecs qui sauve la
partie il fait cavaluer maintenant et
c'est vrai qu'il y aura toujours des
idées avec aussi des très mal placé ce
pur en des cinq peut devenir faible
j'aime pas du tout alors je suppose que
la jauge voulait faire cavalier 3 rock
et aussi c'est un truc comme ça et c'est
vrai que ce cavalier a du mal à toucher
la case aussi
assez normal aussi pour jouer avec toi
qui avait les F4 6
je comprends très bien ce qu'il a ce
qu'il fait bon là je c'est la jauge mais
ça a l'air quand même hyper humain de
jouer cavaluer
et ça a l'air bon et ça ça pose des gros
problèmes à mi-chra qui a déjà 4 minutes
de moins rendez-vous compte fou B4 échec
là je n'aime pas du tout fout des deux
et bon on peut prendre toute façon il va
ok soit il va prendre ok soit il va ok
direct
je sais pas mais en tout cas un des deux
parce que on peut pas se permettre
quand même et c'est vrai tu vois il est
encore 9 minutes 40 et je pense qu'il
profite aussi de son statut de champion
du monde parce que
tu vois il est bon je prends du monde il
sait que c'est le meilleur joueur de
tous les temps etc nanana
michera il a à peine 13 ans il est grand
maître il sort de l’œuf tu vois ce que
veut dire et aussi il prend michera
quand même beaucoup réfléchi dans le
début je pense que on le voit il est
concentré Magnus donc il prend beaucoup
de temps ce qui est très important à
partir rapidement il prend beaucoup de
temps sur le temps de son adversaire
pour réfléchir aux différentes options
et je trouve que il sera donne ce temps
un petit peu en fait Magnus utilise
alors effectivement il y a aussi ce côté
pour michera qui est un peu impressionné
de jouer Magnus Carson 5 minutes de
moins c'est pas raisonnable ça c'est sûr
on est d'accord mais aussi ça ça n'est
fait une sorte d'effet boule de neige ou
finalement Magnus bah il réfléchit sur
le temps de son adversaire il fait comme
tout le monde et ça lui fait ça fait
coup double petit rock et B6 et en plus
il a une très très belle position
avec ce coup de cahier des 7 qui était
quand même un coup très très second
choix très
pauvre je trouve bon là-dames des deux
ok D6 je sais pas ok si on peut pas
peut-être qu'il va faire d'abord il faut
protéger ici voilà je sais pas c'est
vraiment une poubelle une poubelle pour
pour michera très très dur très très dur
enfin on reste on reste sur Magnus bah
si on peut faire un petit tour rapide
allez un petit tour rapide
on va essayer de découvrir quand même
botnik la tête qu'il a pour ceux qui
nous qui connaissent pas parce qu'en
fait tout est c'est pas mal ça marche
mieux qu'avant regarde tu vas voir
ébahis vous allez voir votre nick
apparaît ah ben voilà à quoi il
ressemble le menton de botanique c'est
bien on est content et on va voir la
jeune la jeune joueuse
qui est donc jade on va l'appeler jade
voilà
c'est pas mal
bien
c'est 5 alors faut faire
c'est simple
forcément une bonne idée ça il y a la
fourchette ça ne va pas
et donc je crois que
[Musique]
à moins que tu fasses un coup
intermédiaire voilà j'allais le dire
pour eux
mais si tu prends je fais ça alors je
gagne plus la qualité certes mais je
vais récupérer mon pion et tu as quand
même appuyant isoler ça a l'air quand
même pas mal du tout pour les noirs
donc intéressant
et peut-être il va ne s'arridge contre
la quasi
héroïne alors je sais pas ce qui va bon
on fait confiance dans l'emporter contre
je crois contre la quasi héroïne de la
première ronde face à
alors on voit il parle là il y a pas le
droit de parler normalement il doit y
avoir un truc qui se passe il peut
stream il peut stream aussi
je suis pas sa chaîne mais je crois
qu'il y a une tolérance quand même ça
fait plaisir à tout le monde quand les
joueurs stream
bah ouais ça fait de la pub aussi c'est
cool bien sûr
après les streamers doivent mettre leur
chat en émoticônes seulement
pour éviter les
communication tu vois avec avec
l'extérieur
ouais mais évidemment évidemment non
n'importe quel n'importe quel clivit qui
aura un ordinateur sous la main par
exemple à peu près tout le monde qui est
surtout twitch c'est ça donc oui ça pose
un problème et là on voit elle a un
problème car il ça comment elle fait
pour se dépêrer de ce clouage là en fait
de ce vis-à-vis là qui va donner une
découverte peut-être désagréable il y a
aussi cavalier prend une dame prend de
cette kimonase ah ça va pas être facile
là cette partie
parce que c'est pas déjà perdu
c'est pas ça pas étonnant
l'emporte
rapide tour vers peut-être la partie
qu'on avait découvertes au tout début
entre Samse Vian et ricamson et il a
sacrifié la qualité ça
intéressant
alors il sait pas c'est quoi cette
partie la tour contrôle ouais peut-être
qu'il a il a mangé quand il a ça il fait
la qualité comment s'est passé on va
regarder vite fait
il y a quand même du jeu on voit que le
pion c'est 5 est faible c'est passé en
fait
protège pour faire grand rock
et Tours
5 donc ça ne va pas on est obligé de
prendre du pion et c'est un peu
sacrifice typique de sicilienne ou en
fait finalement l'anglais ce n'est
jamais qu'une sicilienne avec les Blancs
quand il est assez 4 5
donc c'est logique qu'on trouve les
mêmes thèmes et A4 à 5 ouais on est
quand même dans ce genre de
sport dans ce genre de tour prend C3
donc avec les Noirs c'est pas une
question de calcul c'est une question de
culture échecienne
route partout
comme ça ça peut être sympa aussi tu vas
rentrer de partout après bon ça offre
ses cavaliers des 5
ça ne va pas du tout pour
Eric Hansen
on était d'accord on a on fait sans
transition sans transition pour aller
voir Magnus Carlson qui a 7 minutes
compte de qu'on va voir à l'écran d'ici
peu on le voit Magnus
face à son jeune adversaire le jeune
Grand Maître
michera je sais pas si je pourrai équipe
américaine alors est-ce qu'il est
américain
bon d'origine je crois que c'est indien
quand même
mais non il est il est où pour les
États-Unis depuis
en tout cas
ok le drapeau et donc Magnus
on en parlait de skyr6 qui est très beau
alors qu'il donne pas à chaque et mat
mais qui très beau
et c'est juste scolaire
tu joues quoi là Stéphane du coup
je vois pas d'autres idées honnêtement
c'est sur ça j'ai au minimum des 5
ou après les escargots je tactiques je
vais avoir besoin de plus quoi
après faut toujours faire attention
ouais quand le roi est un peu ouvert en
plus on a joué H4 on gratte un peu
d'avoir joué H4 mais alors comment on
fait sur sur tour des 8 à part ça
c'est clair ça c'est tout à fait clair
ça on est d'accord
mais j'y croyais pas trop je pense être
prise même prise T4 je sais pas et ouais
mais attends je fais un coup comme ça tu
es quand même tu es toujours en défense
hein il est pas magnifique magnifique
mais il est quand même là
est-ce que c'est gagnant ou pas j'en
sais rien mais en tout cas c'est il y a
des chances on va voir ce qu'on va faire
manuscrit dame B5 il a peut-être pas
jouer au mieux peut-être que ton coup de
je préférais aussi ton coup de dames
prends
ok bon là c'est
34 contre 39 secondes à cette région
avec si peu de temps quand même
mais bon là il est il est dans une
situation où il a plus le choix en fait
il sera donc du coup
oui bien sûr
non mais il hésite entre ces deux coups
alors
j'arrive pas à y croire
non mais il est visite entre des cinq et
dames mais des cinq et c'est 5 il se
passe quoi
des cinq jours j'aime pas du tout c'est
pas le bon coup
dame B7 ça peut pas être remarque
protège indirectement le pire des 4 en
vrai
il y a pas de couleur donc en fait je
garde mes deux pions
et dame B3 a été joué grosse faute
d'après la jauge à manus qui laisse
échappé là
s'échapper apparemment d'après la jauge
il fallait jouer dame B7 et il fait non
de la tête il est pas content il est pas
content
c'est une gaffe quand il prend des
quatre là il y a c'est très très mal
joué il fallait jouer je vais vous le
dire tout de suite en mettant le la
petite jauge il fallait jouer dame prend
AB et tout reprend des 4 et d'après la
jauge c'est un avantage ou pardon pas ça
parce que là elle tournedit
et là c'est un avantage entre gain est
nul voilà c'est 0,80 on sait jamais ça
on sait jamais si c'est un module bon en
tout cas c'était pas une grosse gaffe il
rigole Magnus et pourquoi il rigole
ouais enfin juste et c'est qu'il a gagné
parce qu'il aime gagner à manus hein
et ça le fait rien il est content plus
le roi bouge plus et
même
le cavalier reste en prison derrière je
préfère jouer la finale garder les
cavaliers parce que les la finale de
Tours c'est à ta seule chance en fait
échec est aussi va arriver évidemment
que 6 va arriver puis on prend la tour
plan G7 on ramasse tout le monde tout
qui tombe menace la tour
G8 mon jeune ami
non non non non non non
abandon et victoire de manuscrit
quand même bon la finie
[Musique]
je crois que la partie la plus
intéressante je crois que c'est bien et
complètement gagnant il y a une pièce de
plus donc on va pas aller voir ça par
contre la partie de botnik
la partie de botanique écoute ouh là là
à botnik qui est complètement gagnant
aussi
[Musique]
le joueur
istrime beaucoup il joue beaucoup de
Blitz online alors il est peut-être un
peu moins fort en partie classique ça
c'est il a quand même un élo à 2600 donc
c'est pas du tout qui est tout ce qui
est il a joué tout reprend G7 tours
hyper joli hein
on sent que c'est je vois pas là mais
c'était maintenant un coup en fait je
vois pas parce que là je te fais
j'allais dire ça mais là bon tu pars un
petit peu même ça ça doit être gagnant
encore
avant non mais ça c'est bien ça c'est
mat joli mat en plus
avant de faire
pas mal aussi mais bon tu repars un
petit peu on sait jamais
minimum mais maintenant j'ai encore plus
dame 5 ah moi qui ramasse le roi 7
et d'un point de 6 bon il ramasse tous
les pions il y a trois pions et à ce
cavalier qui est toujours en l'air
puis à la saison elle a pendule
4 il va faire un dames 8 échecs alors
ces cavaliers ah ça y est ça y est ça va
être un abandon là de la jeune Jade
et il reste encore la partie de Sam
seviane ou pas du tout non non c'est
fini il a gagné aussi et de deux donc
avec des résultats
bon c'est bien Hansen
c'est pas si clair à mes yeux mais ça
reste quand même pour l'instant dans la
logique tu vois les les tous les
et du coup les Américains Caravan state
passion garde l'avantage d'un point à
quatre et demi 3 et demi donc là on est
à la moitié du match il doit être encore
deux matchs
avec nous évidemment 4,5
2 sur 2 qui est quand même qui met
l'équipe sur qui tient l'équipe encore
une fois ils ont 3 et demi Manu ça deux
donc il a plus de points que le tous les
trois autres réunis mais voilà les deux
prochaines parties c'est là où c'est le
plus intéressant parce qu'en fait tous
les autres les temples se resserre et
les joueurs du même niveau se jouent et
du coup c'est là que que va être je
pense le plus intéressant donc restez
parmi nous en tout cas on fait une
petite pause de 3 minutes et en revient
à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour pour cette
deuxième partie de match et non
pour cette deuxième partie de match
entre les chaises bras de
manuscriteurs je sais pas quelle ville
c'est
Garden State pas ça
j'en ai aucune idée donc des États-Unis
évidemment enfin bon ça vient un peu de
tous les pays est-ce que ça a repris ou
pas je crois pas et comme tu l'as dit
comme tu l'as dit on a les matchs
intéressants maintenant les matchs où on
va jouer contre deux va jouer contre un
et trois va jouer contre 4 va jouer
contre 3 donc tout reste à faire 4 et
demi trois et demi là ça va être très
très chaud on va vraiment avoir les il y
a toujours un petit match qui est qui
est un peu déséquilibré c'est le mal
quand même contre féminine parce que les
deux féministes quand même plus fortes
que tous les hommes dans cette
compétition enfin dans ce dans ce match
en tout cas plus faible mais bon tu vois
quand il s'agit
elle peut aller embêter en 2006 quoi
ouais mais elle est embêté elle est
embêté 2850 même
elle était gagnante à elle était
gagnante il restait pas beaucoup de
matériel c'était égal c'était il
représente de New Jersey
tout à fait
oui je sais je sais que je me suis fait
je me suis fait avoir là enfin je me
suis fait avoir non mais déjà je veux je
galère si elle bleu qui dit qui est
toujours là chez sébble ouh là là si
nous regarde j'ai envoyé j'ai envoyé un
petit mail ce matin tiens pour envoyer
j'ai envoyé des petits fichiers mais on
y est pas on y est pas on a on a
quasiment terminé toutes les
toutes les parce que le problème de la
chose je suis toujours pas là je suis
coffre en fait c'est la Sicilienne
ouverte est quasiment j'y suis quasiment
parce qu'il y a Rosso limo il y a deux
qui essaient trois il y a trois qui est
C3 il y a toutes les déviations j'en
suis mon compte chez sebul
s'il sort en avril ça sera beau
à mon avis ça sera plutôt mes juin tu
fais quoi du coup comme comme cours
lifetime répertoire
je vous montre
c'est quand je dis E4 c'est 5 c'est la
lapine c'est B3 c'est à 3 CBK toutes les
antidotes c'est assez sienne fermée bien
évidemment c'est F4 en fait tout ce que
tu veux à peu près au premier coup on
fait au deuxième et sur cavalier F3 KSI
donc là évidemment
ça ça retombe dans la pine vu que je
vais conseiller le système avec cavalier
6 et évidemment après les grandes lignes
de la cheville schnikov qui de qui
bizarrement on va être le plus simple
pour moi parce que j'ai passé tellement
de temps et que les petites antis
sicilienne j'ai pas
ce que je joue beaucoup en fait au
niveau quoi ouais je dois repartir de
zéro quoi quasiment je dois partir de
zéro donc c'est un peu
c'est un peu plus compliqué pour moi et
je suis pas je suis pas très discipliné
moi je sais pas je sais pas comment tu
fais avec les
deadlines tu vois mais moi en général je
m'y mets la veille tu vois là tu me dis
faut que ça soit pour samedi vendredi
soir je m'énerve quoi tu vois et je suis
bien meilleur je suis bon le vendredi
soir attention mais le reste de la
semaine c'est pas terrible quoi tu vois
c'est plutôt
pourquoi
pourquoi faire aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut
remettre à demain
et du coup c'est intéressant est-ce que
tu vas nous révéler un peu quelques
secrets du coup de Magnus évidemment
parce qu'il y a eu il y a eu pendant le
match champion notamment il y a eu
le répertoire de Magnus notamment alors
là j'ai même une nouveauté un truc qui a
pas été joué
qui a pas été joué d'ailleurs je vais
pas le montrer je laisserai
qui est mieux un nouvel ordre de coût
dans cette ligne avec vous prend ces 6
notamment qui a joué contre karwana
j'améliore sur le concept du championnat
du monde
je rigole pas en plus je crois très
sérieusement je pense que c'est beaucoup
mieux ok
pas je ferai de la pub donc ne t'en fais
pas sur ça je ferai de la pub et
évidemment qu'on suivra évidemment je
vais avais l'aider des choses de
de de la mais alors le truc en fait le
truc qui est d'un côté et donc ça sera
un bon résumé tu vois mais la théorie
officielle est très très dur à battre
non c'est dans ses cheveux schnikov
d'ailleurs plus personne ne rentre dans
les rosaux limo en ce moment la grosse
mode donc ça sera vraiment le gros pavé
alors évidemment et je suis snikov c'est
aussi très intéressant mais en général
d'un point de vue théorique c'est vrai
que ça fait de nombreuses années que les
noirs sont ok donc à la limite c'est
plutôt blanc d'essayer de chercher une
nouvelle idée que moi donc évidemment je
fais aussi ce travail de recherche de
nouvelles idées intéressantes en tout
cas intéressant
voilà donc on verra vous serez au
courant quand ça sortira
un mois de mai on sait pas quelle année
mais ça fait longtemps que j'y suis
c'est terrible là ça devait sortir à
Noël donc
après c'est bien de prendre son temps et
de faire un truc bien quoi non mais
honnêtement je traîne alors j'essaie de
faire un truc bien j'y prends ce qui met
beaucoup de temps je m'attendais pas à
ça d'ailleurs c'est très ça demande
beaucoup de temps mais aussi je traîne
faut être faut être honnête je traîne
c'est pas évident tu sais d'expliquer tu
sais qu'à chaque coup il faut mettre des
une phrase
et tout ça c'est comme écrire un bouquin
tu vois donc c'est quand même
c'est quelque chose de d'assez nouveau
en fait pour moi et
je me rends compte que c'est pas un
exercice évident d'écrire un bouquin
fidèle je pensais pas que ça allait être
spécialement évident mais je me rends
compte à quel point c'est très dur en
fait
je te conseille de réfléchir à deux fois
enfin en tout cas faut aimer faut aimer
écrire et expliquer son truc c'est pas
comment tu fais par rapport à ça on va
dire tu vois
tout ce qui est la nouvelle technologie
tu vois tout ce qui est internet je
pense que c'est quand même le futur et
c'est vrai que Chessy bol avec toutes
les vidéos
par rapport au livre maintenant tu vois
c'est la nouvelle génération quoi
expliquer est à la vidéo donc attends il
faut que je vais tourner 30 heures de
vidéo
il faut aussi que tu fasses par écrit
il faut que je fasse beaucoup pareil en
fait je fais je passe plus de temps à
faire par écrit que par vidéo
et tu le fais le truc avec la vidéo où
tu expliques et quand même beaucoup plus
cher
non non c'est pas le double c'est en
général c'est 30 40 euros le le truc et
le PGN avec les avec les explications et
c'est plus de 200 la vidéo
mais c'est vrai que c'est plus sympa
c'est ça rend le truc plus vivant quand
même pour le pour la personne qui
regarde
donc moi j'en ai acheté quelques-uns sur
obligé parce que anis Grey qui fait un
âge d'orve quand tu prépares Magnus pour
jouer contre guéri bah tu es obligé de
prendre son cours
et donc bon j'ai fait mon radin j'ai pas
payé la vidéo
veillez pour voir guéri en vidéo merci
ça les a pas fait rire d'ailleurs je
suis tombé sur riert
de ce qui doit être si haut de chez bol
je lui dis bah vous devrez faire
l'inverse c'est à 200 sans la vidéo tu
vois parce que la vidéo je vois pas
pourquoi on paierait ils font il faut se
faire payer pour regarder la vidéo de
guerre enfin bon ça a pas fait rire du
tout
j'ai arrêté mes blagues après mais voilà
ouais donc
[Musique]
ça va être
c'est un gros projet
je réfléchirai à deux fois avant de
faire le deuxième on verra on verra
après on dit toujours ça mais finalement
une fois que c'est fait c'est fait en
fait mais c'est un boulot un gros boulot
de base quoi et
c'est pas mal quand j'ai rien à faire en
fait ça me fait un fil rouge pour un
joueur d'échec alors tu connais ça aussi
tu vois il y a parfois il y a des
parties de la journée qui sont assez
inoccupés et donc moi j'ai connu ça
pendant tu vois les 20 dernières années
et donc là c'est pas mal quoi parce
qu'en fait parfois je me dis je
travaille je travaille plus trop pour
moi en fait et donc en fait ça me permet
de d'avoir toujours un truc à faire quoi
donc c'est assez sympa en fait pour ça
ça permet d'occuper le temps et quand
j'ai envie de travailler en fait je peux
je peux travailler
voilà on suivra on suivra tout ça
l'évolution de ton cours
[Rires]
pas chaque semaine s'il te plaît ça
m'angoisse suffisamment comme ça enfin
pour moi max
à chaque fois tous les jours
c'est une grosse ouais ce truc
donc qu'est-ce que ça donne au niveau du
début et bien écoute il y a eu un truc
avec G3 bon ben ça clairement pour
éviter les une théorique mais le
problème c'est que ça donne des
positions de ce genre qui sont assez
fermés et c'est quand même pas
extraordinaire
pour les blancs
je pense que
on va voir du coup on va voir Magnus et
au revoir
génial
donc voilà on va voir botnique Magnus
Carlson à l'écran
face à son champion online qui joue tout
qui Stream qui doit être très bon en
partie rapide et envoie une à liquide
alors ça c'est quand même c'est quand
même étonnant
il a gagné plein d'ailleurs
je crois B4 était joué il a joué dame B6
bref et il a
beaucoup de théories pour ceux que ça
amuse mais c'est quasiment maintenant
c'est une ligne considérée comme moi
futé si vous avez encore vous ça fait
penser à une ligne tu sais la ligne du
c'est tout bête mais E4 5 cavaliers F3
F6
D5 non non
il y a un coup important qu'il faut
connaître c'est des sept je crois
que tu manges pas B7 je crois que
franchement
c'est pas mal pour les Noirs parce que
sur ça on va faire ça et on va faire ça
c'est ça
un truc comme H4
mais tu vois et en fait ça c'est
tranquille mais si tu veux pas vous
baisser c'est pas si visible en fait
mais si tu le dis pas
je crois que tu peux être aide très vite
avec les avec les Blancs ce qui est un
peu ouf quoi on sait au bout de trois
mois d'échecs on te dit bah si c'est pas
bon qui a trouvé ça qui est le mec
Maître Philippe
même si je joue des 4 je dois pas être
trop mal hein bien sûr
je pense pas qu'il le joue en vrai mais
mais bon voilà bon c'est des trucs donc
[Musique]
fous des trois et pas le coup le plus
joué hein faut de ces quatre mais bon
pourquoi pas et il prend et joue Kebe 4
x 4 une petite finale pour minuscarsen
qui va normalement faire parler sa
technique ou pas c'est pas si c'est un
peu mieux pour les blancs les avantages
d'espace bon à 4 ouais et surtout aussi
il y aura toujours cavalier à 5 qui est
très très embêtant
parce que si on fait tomber 8e à 7 tout
le temps on a pas trop envie de mettre
cette tour pour des raisons
pratiques esthétique et tout ce que vous
voulez
donc un peu dessus
indéterminée
et cahier des cinq ouais c'est ce que je
c'était la prochaine
ma prochaine pointe je dirais c'est que
finalement qui est des 5 avec et
espèrent en tirer comme ça c'est vrai
que là tu as l'air plus ou moins de
temps tirer et que vous pensez qu'à vous
prendre cinq ou quoi que tu serais
peut-être encore un tartiner moins bien
ici peut-être que tous ces 8 tu me diras
mais peut-être quelque chose comme ça
ouais on sentir plus ou moins on est
encore moins bien à cause de la majorité
mais bon
peut-être que ça laisse des chances et
Magnus il veut pas du tout ça il joue
fout des quatre
ok donc il protège ici évidemment menacé
de prendre mais du coup faut aussi il y
a toujours cavalier à 5 c'est ça le
problème
dès que le fou bouge la B7 C6
comment on fait ici avec les noirs
et bien Stéphane
une énorme poubelle à l'écran qu'est-ce
que tu joues
ça te fait plaisir
de ça non mais il faut jouer après tu
fais quoi c'est ça c'est ça le problème
en fait
on verra ce que tu joues
bien moins bon d'après la jauge en tout
cas que ton tour des vitres
donc
pas mal cavalier
6 maintenant donc là c'est là c'est
quand même la méga galère
plus manger je veux cavalier
à la place de jouer à B6
à la place où je vais essayer je pense
c'est ça
par exemple
et là il a joué un coup ouais c'est
quasiment avec ce fou là qui est très
mauvais
ça sent mauvais ce fou en fait et très
largement supérieur à l'autre parce
qu'il tape sur un 7 il protège bien le 5
et se fout fourrage quasiment jamais on
peut organiser un g3f4 et ce fou ça très
très compliqué en plus il y a le petit
truc tactique cavalier à 5 qu'on avait
donné avant et là il a joué quelque
chose de très instructif manuscrit 5
cavalier 3 évidemment si on prend on se
fait bien et puis on sait si on le
perdrait très probablement au prochain
coup par exemple et prend le 3 fous
prends le 3 c'est un défendable faut
baisser il y a 6 ou 17 c'est interdit
parce qu'elle il y a la tour et donc il
joue faut aussi c'est la coupe très
instructive de manus scarsen on fixe la
faiblesse c'est tout lui ça il joue à 5
à 6 on fixe ce pion à 7 pour toujours et
il y a le fou qui rayonne vous voyez la
différence entre les deux fous ce fou
qui tape sur rien et se fout qui tape
sur le pion à 7 cette tour qui va être
obligé de rester ici parce que si on
perd ce pion à 7 attention c'est pas un
pion en fait c'est pas c'est quasiment
une dame
c'est une semi-dames donc là c'est la
situation pour votre nick il est pas
bien alors on voit on voit pas sa tête
il parle encore il bouge encore mais la
position il bouge pas trop
qui prend des seins comment on fait là
je sais pas il faut prendre parce que
puis on prend je crois qu'elle est fou
des trois et c'est déjà une galère pour
protéger spion tour à 5 qui peut arriver
il a joué fou prend un pion prend
mais là vous voyez hein on peut on
pourrait l'appeler le mauvais fou
celui-là c'est pour ça que j'aime pas ce
truc de mauvais fou parce que
ouais il est bon ce fou alors on peut
même je peux même en rajouter si je veux
j'ai trois F4 il va être très très bon
sauf et en fait ce sont complètement
musulman donc en fait c'est le problème
de de considérer qu'un mauvais fou c'est
parce qu'on a les pions sur la même
couleur c'est toujours plus compliqué
que ça et après il y a plus de trucs ce
que en fait même un mauvais fou tu vois
dans une qui est qui a les mêmes pions
enfin un mauvais coup en fait c'est un
faux de la même couleur que c'est pion
tu sens mais des fois en fait quand on
fouille passe à l'extérieur de la de la
de la structure il peut être très fort
en fait française
tu as plein des fois tu sais alors la
française avec C4 noir là tu sais quand
tu joues
en fait il est monstrueux et ça dépend
vraiment de des postes donc ça dépend
surtout
de l'espace et là on voit que les Blancs
belle avantage d'espace donc en général
tous les fous sont bons quand on
l'avantage des personnes c'est rare ce
qui fait c'est qu'ils bloque toutes les
colonnes ouvertes qui font tout le monde
en fait et
puis tu as 7 contre plein de cases le
fouet
il va faire tourner
et comment on fait pour botnique et bien
les carottes sont cuites
je vous le dis
quoi que peut-être si c'est encore
attendre 35 et encore B4 peut-être et
profitant mais bon je peux faire j'ai
trois tu me diras pas
tes affaires peut-être tous ces cinq
aussi ton C5 pour avoir ce pour avoir ce
pion là et ensuite on va manger
c'est moi qui clou donc tu auras comment
on fait là avec les noirs
et viens le tout salut super baguette 33
tu as le clé tu as lance fatigue à
mettre le score là on a le score en bas
en bas on a le score quand même Canada
chaise bras 3 et demi Garden State
passion 4,5 encore deux parties de deux
matchs de quatre parties donc tout reste
à faire 8 points à gagner on voit en ce
moment on espère que on espère pour toi
que tu le reconnais Magnus Carlsen
qui a les blancs contre eux botnik et il
est dans le dur
mais ça semble déjà un peu tard à cause
de ce pion à cause de ce pion cette tour
qui va venir là très très compliqué
que je vais te dire un petit peu ce que
je pense juste rapidement je fais un
petit tour moi de mon côté et je vois
que c'est bien abattu non pardon non
séviant il est il est très très mal
contre ça
c'est pas encore perdu mais il est il
est en souffrance
tandis que
il a une bonne partie aussi contre
contre jade on revient après évidemment
et
Carissa
c'est très compliqué mais elle est là
votre gagnante elle a des blancs oulala
de jouer c'est très très bizarre mais la
Cavaillon en H5 il a le droit en F8
je vois rapidement ce qui s'est passé de
mon côté il aurait pas pris de bulles en
scène pour commencer quand même
0 sur 3 et voilà
j'aimerais pas être à sa place quand
Magnus va lui demander
pourquoi il a joué il a joué ça et ça il
va être il va être assez vite à court
argument notre ami Eric mais en fait
regarde c'est très joli ce qu'elle a
fait en fait dans la partie si tu
reviens vite sur carrissa il y a eu en
fait regarde les deux derniers
prise
donc sur la prise de y avoir cette
emprun aussi et assez sans l'air il y a
tout qui en l'air et du coup ça attaque
le cavalier ça avait plein de menaces
de partout et donc là elle a mangé de
pièces elle a une pièce de plus en fait
une pièce de plus on va voir on va voir
est-ce qu'elle tient la cadence mais on
reste évidemment chez chamag news pour
la technique
du triple champion du monde et bien
voilà c'est le président oulala oulala
alerte c'est perdu je pense les gens
tomber vite D4 B5 il a fait il a essayé
de faire ça mais il a fait j'ai trois je
vous avais parlé de ce coup G3 et voilà
tout ça il se casse pas la tête il va
gagner il va gagner on va voir Karissa
parce que là ça va plus aucun intérêt
cette partie c'est où franchement que
facilité
il bat de monstre du top niveau Magnus
il a une technique en finale qui est
juste incroyable quoi on va voir pour ce
qui pourrait être un tournant du match
parce que si caressait
bras même si Magnus continue de
de marquer beaucoup de points et Carissa
elle est où mais bon elle a raté déjà
une occasion contre évidemment c'est pas
Magnus Carlson son adversaire ouais puis
c'est pas tactique c'était pas c'était
pas là c'est plus concret quand même
c'est une pièce
c'est pas fini quand même
j'avais pas vu ton idée très très jolie
attention
et le tournant de ce match
on va voir donc il est hyper concentré
hyper focus
ça marche jamais et que quand j'estime
là partout tu peux pas tu récupères la
pièce mais bon ça en fait
c'est ton roi c'est quand même
purification
on ne peut absolument pas faire
et d'ailleurs il y a aussi il faut
prendre F7 qui peut être aussi un jour
une idée bon là il y a la dame qui
défend aussi mais la dame noire venait à
partir il y a du front ici ça reste un
thème
mais là c'est 5 là échec avec dames
ok ok elle est venue à la même
conclusion que nous
et du coup la gamme du F3 qui peut
arriver mon F3
enfin si c'est possible ou pas mais
peut-être que je peux en prendre
victoire qui égalise le match mais
quatre et demi partout
Eric Hansen qui particulait forcément
forcément très très important ça c'est
une évidence
pour la suite parce que
tout simplement c'est quand même ils
sont très très favoris
le roi bon finalement il est pas si mal
ici enfin en tout cas il dépense super
sécurité mais
si voilà c'est pire et s'il va là c'est
pire donc on le garde là la tour
finalement elle va faire grand chose non
plus donc il faut jouer un coup et il a
du mal à jouer un coup aussi
Eric Hansen et c'est pas étonnant
il avait trois minutes là il lui reste
plus que 22 secondes et je sais pas quoi
jouer
c'est pas quoi jouer
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer ici
il y a tout en prison
il faut prendre ces trois
donc là il faut il faut trouver quelque
chose à la 2 minutes à la pendule
pas simplement son son cou il est il est
intéressant parce que là il faut trouver
quelque chose clairement
est-ce qu'il y a pas du
alors je regarde du cavalier
dessiner
c'est une pagaille indescriptible en
fait je pensais à pion prend il faut
prendre M6 il faut prendre cette
barrière mais j'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu
d'en prendre les deux qui ouais
mais du coup elle apprend B2 ça dépend
F6 je l'ai raté du coup non c'est la
partie ok alors ça on avait tous vu
enfin c'était l'idée dont on voulait
faire depuis un moment gratuitement
alors d'après la jauge ça marche pas ça
donne ça fait que nul mais alors
attention ça met une pression
une seconde ouh là là trois secondes il
jouait que pas dedans c'est trop dur il
y a une pièce de moins après
bon joueur de Blitz Bullet donc il peut
trou il peut jouer vite et je voulais
gagne il veut pas revenir ici et il joue
à gunna bref 4 il va faire fouger 5 je
suppose pas sûr non il joue plus à
gagner je pense pas que
ok
je préfère
on va on va regarder est-ce qu'elle elle
va chercher un gars ça c'est sûr parce
qu'elle a au moins la nul là elle a et
sur ça encore mais bon effectivement ça
sent mauvais quand même et qu'est-ce qui
était joué dans la partie d'un meuf
synchroach system F4 fougez 5 et joue la
gagne avec un centaure aussi jouer j'ai
il joue sur les nerfs
ça va pas il faut trouver plus concret
encore
attendez
assez extraordinaire
et qui et qui rend lui rentrer dedans
mais sans est un disque Saric a gagné
comme tu le disais contre Celiane il
avait une très très belle position qui
prennent l'avantage à moins que michra
ne batte
il sera qui a donc les blancs et mes
choix qui est pas bien regarde le Renoir
qui avance ça pourrait être qui a le
blanc contre contre jade jade j'ai hâte
c'était le roi des cinq le purge 3 qui
tombe c'est terminé terminé Laurent
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe le plus
jeune grand maître au monde qui me taire
d'abord et ensuite elle va pousser
évidemment qu'elle va pousser
c'est complètement terminé tu as raison
on voit que c'est gagné de toute façon
de droits
et du coup trois et demi pour les
chaises bras qui repasse du coup deux
points devant les américains ils étaient
menés pendant deux set et là au
troisième set 3 et demi 0,5 bon c'est
pas fini encore mais archi surprenante
ou ericansen finalement arrive pas à
battre le maillon faible de l'équipe
adverse et les trois autres qui gagnent
en plus
incroyable et c'est surtout c'est
surtout Jade qui fait la différence
parce que normalement si la logique
avait été respectée avec michera qui
gagnait ça faisait 6 partout et ça nous
laissait une dernière ronde de folie ça
sera quand même une dernière honte de
folie avec Magnus Carson qui va défier
sévi avec les Noirs cette fois donc il
faut un et demi sur quatre pour les
pièces bras pour gagner le match 1 et
demi sur 4
8 et demi je vous rappelle 8 et demi le
match gagné donc il peut encore avoir
une égalité s'il y a un petit trois
donc mais bon il a perdu la dernière
fois contre visite donc pourquoi pas
contre c'est bien c'est toujours
possible surtout qu'il veut toujours
apporter le point pour son équipe et
parfois ça
joue des tours quand sur son objectif
vu que là il vient d'avoir les blancs
va avoir les Noirs tout à fait contre
Sam seviane on va voir si il est
toujours là ou à quelqu'un est parti ah
que je les aime pas cela oh que je les
aime pas
oh que je les aime pas moi je vous le
dis qui est parti quel mauvais élève
qui m'a décalé tout ça
alors là on va faire un truc
ah non mais c'est pas cool ça
parce que quand il va revenir ça va se
mettre je pense
quoique la dernière fois que j'avais
stream il y avait un joueur qui avait
pas été là pendant le ronde qui a séché
la première ronde ouais non ça arrive
tout le temps
au premier match au premier match
c'était vraiment à l'enfer là ça mur
donc si j'ai bien compris tu vas tu vas
tu vas streamer ensuite c'est ça sur ta
chaîne c'est ça c'est ça en fait bon
j'ai là j'ai passé quasiment plus d'un
mois sans stream
lundi déjà d'accord mais du coup je
reviens vite à petit et donc j'avais
décidé de stream sur ma chaîne les gars
juste après cet événement tu fais quoi
du coup quand tu stream
ça dépend aujourd'hui je vais faire je
vais faire un petit robe tout 2016
j'ai fait un plus d'un mois et demi je
pense sans stream et même sans Blitz
j'ai même pas jouer une seule partie
c'est très occupé et du coup je suis
revenu c'était
les pièces en un coup dans toutes les
parties
donc là il faut que je me refasse un
petit peu et après je fais souvent aussi
des petites speedrun en live que je fais
que je mets après sur Youtube et je vais
aussi contre les vieux Worlds donc ça
dépend un peu
abonnez
aussi à la chaîne
cheeseccobanks sur YouTube partout et
alors il m'est arrivé un truc incroyable
hier j'ai fait mon premier title twoody
depuis 6 ans
le Light alors j'étais crevé j'avais pas
envie de le faire je me suis c'est
marrant il y a Magnus cramenic compagnie
donc je fais la première partie je suis
à la ramasse je vais perdre contre 2100
bon je gagne par miracle et puis par
Inès verdance je suis tellement content
je ferme la fenêtre ça va désinscrit du
tournoi
j'ai fait un Quick sans faire exprès à
la après à un sur donc je suis écouté je
suis invaincu en title Thiais depuis 6
ans
c'est vrai c'est factuel
donc c'était pas fait exprès j'avais
envie de jouer en fait non du coup non
en fait je j'avais fait parce que je me
suis dit j'avais décidé en fait je
voulais faire celui de 17h et puis j'ai
pas pu ça va un peu contrarié du coup
même crever je voulais le faire et donc
non j'ai pas pu le faire non plus
j'ai plus de chargeur sur mon ah ça
c'est terrible ça c'est j'ai ma batterie
du coup je vois plus le je vais l'ouvrir
là je vais aller sur twitch
si je peux donc voilà donc c'était un
peu ballot tout ça
de 56
même pas ce que c'est mon truc
attends mais ouais c'est ça mon truc tu
veux me mettre
[Musique]
bonjour tiens c'est ça mais en fait
peut-être je vais faire avec mes deux
zlatanes 56 17
[Musique]
j'ai pris pas mal de du coup j'ai un élo
correct pour le coup mais
je voulais tenter être soudés comme ça
pour rigoler mais enfin bon c'est
tellement fort que c'est très très fort
Nathan si tu es là
Nathan est-ce que tu peux tu pourrais
nous mettre un petit un petit Zlatan en
modo
pour qu'il puisse Banner les gens
là non Florence ça va depuis Paul qui se
comporte la majorité du temps assez bien
fatoumodo bon on va pas se voir entre
modo super baguette 33 bon mais
baguettes qui s'appelle baguettes on
peut pas on peut pas lui faire ça
c'est tellement de bon goût
mais on sait jamais moi j'ai un truc
mais en fait c'est juste la
bienveillance et le respect et pas et
pas me faire de Vannes
et pas se moquer de moi voilà c'est les
trois c'est trois conditions il y en a
une qui est un peu plus discutable que
les deux autres
[Rires]
c'est comme ça
donc en fait c'est le truc où tu sais
pas ce qui se passe mais les étoiles
s'alignent dans un tournoi
j'ai gagné le Tour à rapide où j'ai à la
première onde je vais te dire
premièrement il y a eu cette ronde
premier rang j'ai battu ma média en
deuxième rang j'ai battu guéri troisième
rang j'ai fait une avec un ski quatrième
round j'ai fait nul avec
[Musique]
avec Ding cinquième rang j'ai battu
Nakamura
6e ronde j'ai fait un greatchouk et 7e
range j'ai battu Carrey Kid donc tu vois
un tournoi qui est quand même qui
ressemble pas à mes tournois habituels
si tu vois ce que je veux dire
[Musique]
avec 5 et demi sur 7 donc quatre
victoires et 3 nuls contre le gratin
mondial premier execo enfin premier du
coup première des partages devant
Nakamura
donc voilà donc j'en parle assez souvent
parce que je suis un peu nostalgique du
coup j'attends que maintenant j'y crois
plus trop que ça va se ça va se
reproduire un truc pareil
après après
c'est cool ouais non bien sûr
clairement 2012-2013 j'ai battu avec
Rami à Paris mais effectivement c'est un
truc en fait tu te rends pas compte
quand tu le fais parce que c'est
toujours pareil avec le recul que tu
sais quel a été ton meilleur tournoi ou
ta meilleure partie tu vois donc sur le
coup je me rendais pas trop compte
mais c'est plus tard et donc j'ai
tendance à
mais ça va là je crois que j'avais pas
parlé depuis le début mais c'est un
sujet qui peut revenir effectivement
les anecdotes les belles pertes comme ça
c'est clair que c'est toujours plaisir
quoi il faut en parler de ce truc là
parce qu'apparemment j'en parlais
beaucoup pendant les stages on parle que
de ça
[Rires]
premier médaille d'or gold medalys ils
ont joué à Marseille en Chine
alors moi j'ai pas de mangame comme ça
malheureusement
[Musique]
non il y a un tournoi qui reste au
dessus des autres ou pas
évident que ça arrive en vrai parce que
c'est un peu une un alignement des
planètes qui à mon avis se produit pas
dans tous les cas clairement bon j'ai 45
dans un des tournages j'ai failli gagner
d'ailleurs c'était ouais j'étais
hyper loin dans le classement
enfin je devais être je sais pas 25e
vélo 2003 et en fait j'avais j'étais en
tête tout en dragon et j'ai perdu la
renduite
parce que moi le truc que je te raconte
là c'est complètement irréel en fait
quand il y a quand même
très au dessus ouais mais peut-être ça
va venir à mon avis ça va venir moi pour
moi ça arrive ça arrive pour tout le
monde c'est faire ouais bon après c'est
moi j'ai quand même assez régulier ça
veut dire l'année où j'ai battu mon
premier grand maître
et ben j'ai fait trois bulles de suite
il est juste derrière qu'on pardon de
mais tu vois je suis assez je suis pas
très très
moi non plus je suis assez régulier
après faut que je joue des gros tournois
aussi parce que moi je suis plus grand
chose là et
voilà quoi mais ouais bon en tout cas on
va voir mais
mais sinon après là c'est il y a pas mal
de rapides ici au Canaries que je joue
et en fait j'ai je pense que mon score
de moyenne en rapide c'est 8 sur 9
en 1 an à peu près le niveau est très
faible d'accord c'est pas mal
le dernier que j'ai fait j'ai fait 8 sur
9 c'était il y a 10 jours il y avait 15
titres avec 15 titres il y avait pas de
de il y avait deux grands maîtres mais
bon c'était pas c'était pas toi de ouf
mais bon ok j'étais dixième élo sur la
grille de départ je vais vite sur neuf
mais sinon il y a généralement deux
trois titrés quoi tu vois et à chaque
fois je fais 8,5
passe pas mal mais en partie lentement
en fait quand on peut flag déjà c'est
plus intéressant quoi et Magnus Carlsen
a repris tandis que je suis modérateur
ça y est ça y est merci beaucoup
soyez polir une Française jouée
pardon
la française de Magnus de Magnus c'est
effectivement donc bon ça peut random
tout ça mais de fou mais cette fois-ci a
fait pas mal online ces derniers temps
petit rock et attention c'est vrai qu'il
y a des F5 qui peuvent arriver ils
jouent un peu surprenant G6 ça ressemble
un petit coup de panique tout ça G6
bon alors peut-être pas
Erwan joué par Sam c'est bien toujours
très logique on s'enlève des
grandes diagonale aussi on peut se voilà
ici il y avait quand même une option
pour les noirs qui existent toujours
c'est de jouer la petite finale
qui est voilà c'est un thème connu c'est
pas du tout quelque chose
en général très désagréables c'est final
on peut faire B4 à 5 il y a des gens qui
aiment bien tenir ce genre de finale
mais bon c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
le plus ambitieux et Magnus et plus
ambitieux et donc croissant est toujours
un coup utile on s'enlève de tout ça
pour ces 8 à 3 parce que c'est vrai que
c'est on envoie un coup de F5 puis on
prend et qu'on essaie d'attaquer c'est
vrai qu'après la finale devient une
menace du coup ouais puis en plus une
fois que le pion F disparaît ben le pion
de 5 devait faire avec ses prends des 4
et donc c'est un petit peu tombé donc
pas trop trop
poussé à 5 quand je veux A3 OK
et à trois de jouer
donc comment on fait là avec les Noirs
c'est pas terrible tout ça parce que tu
en penses
voilà français
je veux plus l'avoir cette position
donc je fous ces cinq maintenant il joue
un peu la même sauf qu'il a les dames
encore sur les chéquier
ça me sévit en bas il a 2700 hello donc
ça va je crois qu'il joue quand même pas
mal aux échecs
et pour répondre à Fatou ouais on peut
pas passer amis en rapide mais tu sais
que quand tu passes 2400 hello en blitz
et rapide maintenant tu passes cuir 10
[Musique]
j'ai un pote qui est qui est mis mais il
a pas eu de 2400 mais il a eu donc
toujours mais
en fait lui il a déjà eu 2400 en blitz
ou rapide je sais plus donc il est coave
10 seulement rapide double X
mais par contre en langue il est quoi 20
enfin voilà tout normal quoi
[Musique]
et donc souvent tu peux gagner 0 point
sur une partie quoi
j'ai perdu un point
je sais pas c'est compliqué ces trucs
on va on regarde avec Manu il est pas
bien non
là-bas
je bouge pas parce que regarde même si
je joue ça allez c'est quoi
je suis pas content là avec mon fou qui
va maintenant
je ne veux pas le manger spi en fait
est ouvert franchement
j'ai peur mais bon tu fais quoi là je
prends d'abord
et après je vais faire tourner du jeu
donc c'est pas si clair cette histoire
et il a joué damascade d'abord ok à mon
avis mieux dans cette ordre de coup
cavalier 4 joué par Magnus Carlsen
attaque ce pion ce cavalier en D4 pardon
F3 il a prévu quoi
qu'il y a pas qui avait les deux
mais je crois que
mais bon ça non mais regarde il fait
comme moi
c'est Viane il a dit
je préfère mourir que de bouger ce
cahier de Descartes on a envie de le
garder non il est tellement beau puis je
t'emmène la tour si tu veux mater on va
mater t'inquiète pas besoin d'ouvrir la
pause A5
qu'on a pas trop envie de manger ça va
tout ouvrir
peut-être qu'on peut penser à ton F3
mais bon ça laisse du F6
c'est intéressant aussi pour fermer le
cercueil
ton F3 tu auras 3 mais F6 attention ça
ça donne tout en l'air quand même pour
l'instant ça va
et ça a l'air bon quand même non
envisager de prendre et venir là
j'aime pas les noirs pour être honnête à
5 c'est vrai que c'est en pratique alors
je sais pas si c'est un bon coup
objectivement mais en fait finalement
peu importe l'idée c'est quand même de
en pratique d'avoir du jeu et du contre
jeu et de poser une question à
samséviane
parce que là pour l'instant si si fait
rien de concret avec les Noirs si c'est
passé s'il essaie pas de se créer du
contre jeu
bien ça va être du sens unique cette
partie donc évidemment
j'aime trop la position des blancs
[Rires]
capable de parier sur la couleur de
voiture qui sur la voiture qui va passer
là
absolument tout tu paries ou tu paries
toujours
je parier mais bon là c'est plus de
clients ma copine elle est pas trop
comme ça
les joueurs d'échec qui a joué donc on
est souvent
j'adore on fait un petit tour un petit
tour
est possible avec botnik
donc qui joue contre
saritch avec les Blancs est-ce qu'on met
sa caméra allez on va mettre sa caméra
quand même notre ami botnique on va le
voir notre ami streamer le streamer
ukrainien
contre
Ivan saids alors la Française a au
niveau ouais c'est on le voit on voit
beaucoup on l'a vu un peu avec avec un
épaule contre mvl aussi et c'est vrai
qu'on la voit plus trop la France
pourquoi pourquoi s'infliger des choses
comme ça quand on peut mettre un pion un
pion sur la 5e rangée d'entrée regardez
c'est pas beau c'est 5 ou 5 qu'est-ce
qui se passe là alors
qui sont habitués à jouer à faire des
bullets et compagnie
[Musique]
c'est clair que c'est pas si important
que ça pour lui
mais bon
mais bon c'est vrai que ça allait slice
tu peux nous faire la partie depuis le
début on accéléré c'est une
piquant à lapin
normalement c'est un truc pas mal pour
les Noirs aussi
[Musique]
bizarre un petit peu bon c'est vrai
qu'on peut sortir un tour par là mais il
y a d'avoir du jeu quoi que puis moi on
reste toujours pareil très très risqué
pour les pour les deux non là ça a pas
été joué ça il réfléchit bonne technique
mais c'est vrai que c'est un bon moment
pour réfléchir parce que c'est quand
même un moment critique bon écoute je
crois que les trois résultats sont
possibles dans cette partie on peut
aller voir peut-être michera contre
ericansen qui a quand même été
miraculeux miraculé dans la partie
précédente
contre Kaisa
quinzen
contre un Inde
je vous fais un plus tu as dû te
dire pas mal de il y avait des pas mal
de siciliennes
comme ça avec un an de Carole première
partie du match champion du monde en
fait non c'était la deuxième partie en
2013 il a joué une 44 ok
[Musique]
on l'a vu qu'une fois donc voilà ce que
j'en pense enfin voilà ce que Magnus en
pense il a joué une fois il a pas joué
de donc
c'était top of qu'il a joué aussi il y
avait eu aussi
donc autant de niveau c'est pas du tout
joué en fait au top niveau il y a 4 5 et
jouer 4c5 c'est tout
il n'y a pas le reste on le voit c'est
des très très rares apparitions
donc le Marshall la berlinoise quand on
joue aux quatre auto de niveau c'est
Marshall berlinoise je suis
c'est à peu près tout en vrai
[Musique]
la pétrole c'était pas mal aussi
qui a joué à marche champion du monde
d'où tu as aussi qu'un expert la pétrole
aussi
grosse ouverture évidemment donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans celle-là ça
c'est une nage d'offre comme comme on
les aime
et à 4 qui va arriver
au centre ouais on est pas mal on a on a
quand même j'aime bien les Noirs ici
parce que j'ai l'impression que les
blancs sont en retards ils jouent H4
pour essayer de rattraper son retard
mais il menace pas vraiment j'ai cinq ça
sera pas un drame donc là du coup
peut-être à 4 mais des coups pas non
plus
donc là il y a pas de cavaliers des
cartes qui tiennent je pense pas
et c'est pas la petite combine
habituelle tu sais où je perroquet quand
même parce que sur dame principe j'ai ça
donc ça me fait toujours peur ces trucs
là
mais bon ça va pas marcher
[Musique]
c'est des idées moi je crois pas trop
mais
ok donc ça c'était Matic aussi pour
ralentir lattes du des blancs de données
spion et c'est vrai que le temps qu'on
mange le pion les Noirs ont le temps de
s'organiser par exemple à 4 cahiers des
deux et on voit que les les blancs
peuvent plus défendre c'est un coup
moche comme ça il y a trois
et là on prend les deux attaque la tour
si on fait B3 c'est l'accident c'est
l'accident mortel
c'est terminé donc c'est une façon
intéressante de ralentir l'attaque en
donnant un pion
et de pouvoir contre-attaquer aussi de
dévier Adam bon c'est quoi ton prono sur
cette partie et les parties sont chaudes
il peut tout se passer moi j'aime bien
les noirs
il aime bien les positions chaudes et
puis j'aime bien la position noire je
trouve qu'elle est plus facile à jouer
en tout cas le noir de fallait blonde à
faire vraiment attention quand
j'apprécie là
tu vois les Noirs ils vont juste de la
tour en cellule jouer à 4 et 3 quoi
enfin tu vois les coups sont déjà là
alors que les plans ben là en fait
mais bon mais je suis d'accord j'aime
bien les noirs et dans la dernière
partie entre les joueuses donc Jade et
Kais
donc
qu'est-ce que ça donne qui a les blancs
ça doit être OK et puis en plus pour les
Noirs quand même il y a un pion qui a
été mangé en B4 comment il a été mangé
dans quelques instants a été a été mangé
en B2 qui s'est passé
quelque chose d'hybride
et en fait qui avait le cadre qui
ressemble à à Marc et avec ses deux qui
menacés
mais bon elle a fait ça en disant c'est
pas grave c'est qu'un pion et on peut se
venger sur B7
on a quatre parties chaude bouillante on
retourne chez Magnus Carlsen parce que
c'est là où c'est là où tout se passe et
là où on pourra voir une grosse surprise
vous prendrez 5 fois 6 il a décidé de
prendre le pion ça me sévère ça c'est sa
nouvelle génération on va prendre les
pions quoi qu'il arrive il a beaucoup de
jeux Magnus du coup
oh là là mais que c'est chaud cette
partie et F5 joué par Samse vient de
caméléon 4 le coup du retour qui est ici
on va les mettre à l'image des deux
joueurs parce que cette partie ça fait
peur
et attention que le prix d'un G6 prise
son tour point F8 il y a dumberghemats
déjà d'accord donc F5
mais là je marche non c'est pas
compliqué
j'y crois pas une seconde
comme ça
il fait pas crédit
si peu encaisser l'encaisse
mon écran toutes les parties et tout le
monde joue le matin c'est très très
chaud et il a mangé F5 d'ailleurs bon
mais du coup ça va être abandonner un
tour je pense parce que il y a pas
longtemps
ça pourrait être un coup mais bon c'est
vraiment pour vraiment rigoler
[Musique]
alors c'est pas c'est pas le point de la
gagne mais c'est le point des 8 points
ça veut dire qu'il y a plus le droit à
l'erreur derrière pour les pour les
passeurs et franchement du coup ça Ritch
qui
qui est en train de faire qui frôle
c'est très très chiant il y a 27
secondes pour bortnite sur une position
où tout peut se passer
il est très mal
finalement
et chez les filles c'est compliqué alors
ça c'est bien pour le suspense
quand même avoir des dernières parties
chaudes après je dis qu'il est moins
bien parce que voilà voilà position ça
m'a l'air compliqué mais en fait j'en
sais rien
j'en sais rien il a 3 minutes contre une
et la position elle est très compliquée
G3
jolie
mais on peut pas prendre parce que puis
on prend échec au roi ok j'ai 5 F4
mais on sent qu'on va pas enfin on a pas
de raison de faire une pièce quoi voilà
c'est ça que je veux dire donc surtout
qu'il y a pas de menaces ici donc c'est
quand même ça la l'avantage
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici je crois
que manus va nous le montrer trois
secondes il a joué avec trois secondes
ça me fait Viane
je crois pas mais bon
et jouer
c'est une boucherie totale de bortnik
franchement toi tu peux aller changer on
peut dire ça
évidemment qui va gagner
contre 2 minutes et
c'est c'est très compliqué à calculer
11 sur 12 sur la compète et ira tomate
c'est pas mal tu vois comment on gagne
des points de 1850 c'est comme ça
fait j'ai gagné qu'est-ce que tu as fait
j'ai encore gagné voilà on sur 12 c'est
c'est le tarif
ça joue
fortunique mais bon il y a pas de temps
obligatoire maintenant c'est du must win
partout chez les Garden States passeurs
et G5 qu'est-ce qui s'est passé sur G5
pourquoi surproupant il veut faire de la
ou là F4 là une pièce qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé apparemment j'ai 5 étais une
gaffe ça ne marchait pas du tout
pourquoi je vais tricher
6 et sur pion prend C6 il y avait Dame
des 7
effectivement beaucoup trop dur
c'est fini c'est fini
il peut faire ouais il regarde j'ai
l'impression essayé il a fait nul il a
assuré le coup et oui pourquoi parce que
ils ont le droit de regarder les autres
échiquiers et évidemment que
Ivan ça il a suivi ça et ça joue pas
pour le hello ça joue pour rien du tout
ça joue peut-être pas le nom de
chaise.com mieux et on s'en moque et
donc il prend la nulle pour assurer la
victoire en chessbra 8 et demi 5 et demi
on va quand même aller voir les deux
dernières parties
tu as une pièce d'avance mais on s'en
fout le but c'est quand même de gagner
le match donc nul super
[Musique]
ce qui reste compte plus pour rien donc
il y a michera du coup qui joue contre
Hansen
il reste pas grand chose à ton côté je
vais lancer
après
compte pas pour hello non non ça compte
pas pour le vélo
cher
Florent
ça compte peut-être pour j'en sais rien
ça franchement oui mais ça fonctionne
c'est pas
il y a beaucoup de gens qui me portent
beaucoup beaucoup de
d'importance à ça mais
finale l'enjeu est bien plus important
que trois petits points et l'eau
en tout cas il joue ils ont bien raison
de s'amuser et d'essayer de gagner une
partie ça fait toujours c'est toujours
mieux de gagner que de perdre ça c'est
évident est-ce que il y a des partages
ils prennent des points peut-être je
sais pas
moi
pour la phase finale donc ah oui abandon
partir il a abandonné mais bon ils sont
foutait un peu je pense en scène là mais
en scène moteur
un demi sur quatre ouais c'est pas
beaucoup hein effectivement c'est dur de
faire moi c'est possible de faire moins
mais c'est quand même faut s'appliquer
ouais enfin il a 2006 quoi tu vois
[Musique]
scène qu'on pense avec ses quatre
surprises derrière c'est vrai que quand
tu es locomotive devant qui fait 4 sur 4
c'est
c'est pas mal les joueurs se sont barrés
toutes ces pièces là
les parties quand on s'en décalés oui
non je sais mais du coup malgré tout
dans son corps ok c'est vrai qu'il y a
40 secondes contre une minute 56
3 4 5 bah écoute les noirs sont gagnants
le roi blanc est complètement
complètement ouvert c'est un pion de
plus et mes pièces sont trop fortes tu
les cases noires le cavalence C5
mange d'avant qui a été complètement
raté ils ont pris un trou et demi 0,5
donc
ça va se jouer à rien au final ouais le
match d'avant a été
a été terrible
[Musique]
c'est un peu comme NACA quoi tu vois
c'est une valeur sûre quoi
au minimum 3 et le plus souvent 4 tu
sais qu'il va faire le job
et donc
c'est pas terminé on regarde la fin
d'ailleurs on va commenter
ça commence mais nous on est là
donc on arrive vers 16h15 on commence le
stream et on a une carrode à kamura face
à ces chinois très surprenant l'équipe
emmenée par VI mais c'est Gotham Knight
sont de très très gros clients ça c'est
absolument certain
donc ça sera intéressant et ensuite vous
aurez le match de l'équipe française
Blitz avec greatchouk Maxime
très beau match à suivre
demain à 19h
et je te joue la petite finale avec 12
points de plus ça va être gagné pour car
ils sont qui a été
très très forte aujourd'hui très fort
parce que là et demi du coup sur 4 elle
arrête de faire plus parce que elle a
vraiment mis en difficulté manus et
surtout en scène elle a fait nul mais
elle l'a bien mal quand même si tu
regardes
quand même c'est celle qui
a donné le plus de filiards en fait au
final
puis même dans le match en fait tu vois
elle
a quand même bon elle elle a fait du
blanc de sel elle a battu la féminine et
elle aurait pu être carcène mais surtout
rendre ça n'aurait pu le battre en fait
elle aurait pu limite faire deux et demi
voire plus quoi quand tu vois les guides
d'en face bon enfin on est quand même
débouché quoi entre
elle a mis une fourchette pour terminer
une belle
performance de karisa qui ne sera pas
suffisante en tout cas pour aujourd'hui
pour son équipe mais belle victoire des
chaises Brown et on est content parce
que finalement c'est sympa ça veut dire
qu'on va avoir Magnus pendant au moins
deux semaines de plus voir
encore plus en tout cas pour début de
tournoi pour être chaise bras avec deux
sur trois on va faire un petit point dix
fois classement si tu le veux bien même
rapidement alors je vous le mets tout de
suite et vous avez alors c'est pas
encore mis à jour mais on voit on voit
énormément ce qui ont gagné donc 2 1 et
chess Brack y avait un un et donc il
passe de la bonne partie du classement
ce sera tout l'enjeu pour demain pour
l'équipe Blitz tandis que Gotham Knights
contre les Chinois ça joue plus étendu
hein ils ont déjà deux victoires donc
une troisième victoire leur garantie
quasiment l'accès aux huit premières
places je pense que même ça garantit en
fait
et tandis que une défaite les mets
les mets un peu dans le ventre mou mais
dans le ventre mou plus donc c'est
beaucoup plus décisif pour Blitz mais en
tout cas ce sera un très très beau match
entre une sorte de qualification en fait
qualification directe pour tu as deux
chances pour la calife et c'est la
première demain c'est exactement ça
bah écoute il me reste plus qu'à te
remercie à te souhaiter un bon stream
alors je ferais bien en raid mais non
alors je vais essayer de le faire je
vais essayer de le faire moi-même je
suis pas sûr que ça marche mais en tout
cas les gars je vais lancer un stream
sur ma chaîne
donc bon j'ai coupé les micro pour
l'instant je suis pas encore là mais le
stream qui va partir du coup merci
beaucoup Laurent de m'avoir invité
demain à 16h30 pour ce supermatch avec
Naka je vais essayer de me faire un
petit raid
et puis ça marche pas et ben
c'est le meilleur moyen que ça marche
moi je vous le dis et ça marche ça
marche donc dans quelques secondes vous
êtes sur ma chaîne donc du coup bah
merci à toi merci demain 16h15 ciao ciao
yes ça marche à bientôt ciao ciao